foreign
Microsoft Excel is the simplest yet an
important skill required by ID employees
Excel improves the data management
effectively and escalates the
productivity exponentially the simple
spreadsheet software is now an integral
part of most business organizations
across the world msxl is used for
various needs and requirements of
business organizations in fact a few use
Excel for tracking sales Trends and
generate valuable insights from the
business data the simple interface helps
users to easily understand the software
and perform basic activities in this
excel fill course we will be learning
the topics from the advanced Excel
section but before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our Channel and
don't forget to hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply run one
of the major advantages of Ms Excel is
its flexibility feature this feature
allows users to define the structure of
information they need to manage with
ease Excel is so simple to use that even
a completely new user can manage to
implement a few functionalities in Excel
for complicated tasks the user needs to
undergo training and gain hands-on
experience to use it in a better manner
even after three decades Ms Excel is
still the most preferred and used
spreadsheet software around the world
excel's updated features help users to
connect to a variety of data sources and
import data the data collected can be
cleansed modified and prepared using
Advanced Excel features the fine-tuned
data can be run through formulas and
necessary insights of the data can be
extracted not just this users can also
visualize the data reports making Excel
one of the most powerful business
intelligence tools the Visual Basic
support from Excel will allow users to
customize and generate interactive
business reports and dashboards anyhow
the top uses of msxl are as follows msxl
is commonly used for financial related
activities the reason for its popularity
is that the user can Define custom
formulas and calculate quarterly half
yearly and annual reports for the sales
and marketing Community Excel helps to
effectively keep track of the sales
leads project status reports and invoice
reports Microsoft Excel Excel also very
popular among
traffic from data science background as
it allows them to easily work with
statistical formulas and graphing the
finance department makes use of Ms Excel
for payroll expenses tax calculations
leave reports timesheets and employee
performance analysis another important
use of Ms Excel for any industry is
forecasting this helps organizations in
Revenue projections cost projections and
manage their supply chain effectively
now let us go through the salaries of
data oriented jobs that require Ms Excel
the average salaries of data oriented
jobs with excellent requirements is
anywhere between 5 lakhs per annum to 10
lakhs per annum based on experience and
job roles and responsibilities having
the introduction and applications of
excel discussed now we will go through
the agenda for today's session we will
start off by discussing Excel basic
knowledge where we will go through the
fundamentals of excel followed by that
we will start with learning how how to
lock or protect cells in Excel followed
by that we will learn the print plate
setup in Excel next we have goal seek in
Excel charts in Excel and then we will
go through data validation in Excel
followed by that we will go through the
lookup functions so there are basically
three types of lookup functions which
are vlookup Edge lookup and X lookup
followed by that we will learn slicers
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel budget template then we
will understand what exactly is Mis
report in Excel then we will dive into
Excel macros and visual basics for
beginners then we will learn regression
in Excel followed by that we will go
through Excel power query then the
perfect tables in Excel and finally to
make things interesting we will go
through the most frequently Asked Excel
based interview questions and answers so
I hope I made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with the
advanced Excel tutorial
what is Microsoft Excel so Microsoft
Excel is a software product designed and
developed by Microsoft store in data in
an organized way that is rows and
columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical operations
followed by that
Microsoft Excel is also used to extract
the insights from the data and represent
it in the form of visually appealing
graphs and charts now we have a basic
understanding or an overview of what a
Microsoft Excel software product is
now moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
so following are some fundamentals that
you need to know before getting started
with Microsoft Excel so basically when
you install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so when you get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page
so this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel home page where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
Microsoft Excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way through the Practical
session so once you get started with the
sheet you will have some more options so
this particular option is called as the
toolbar menu you will have the file home
insert draw paste layout formulas data
review View and help so these are the
tools that you will be using to work on
your data using Microsoft Excel
furthermore we have a toolbar ribbon so
when you select sum or the other option
from the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help buttons you will have a ribbon so
for example you can see that I have
selected the Home Tool here so when I
press on the Home Tool this is the
ribbon which Microsoft Excel gives me so
this ribbon has some options in it which
can perform various operations now in a
further a more detailed way we will have
toolbar groups so when you see in the
previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste Cut Copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the phone bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions
so each set is called as a group
and I think you can see a small Arrow
option over here so this Arrow option is
used into the toolbar groups when the
group is not able to fit all the
operations or all the functionalities in
one single provided section so when you
click on this particular Arrow Mark you
will have another dialog box so this is
called toolbar more options so you can
see that when I clicked on this icon you
can see a new dialog box which opens me
a new set of operations which are not
able to be fit in this particular group
so we will also see more about this in a
better way in the Practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a Microsoft Excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address B3 so B is
the column name and three is the room
name
and apart from that you can have the
sheet tracker in the bottom left corner
of the Excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets
and in the bottom right corner you have
an option of increasing or decreasing
the sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the Practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so now we enter the demo inventory in
Microsoft Excel so we will be using
Microsoft Excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company
so basically an employee in a company
has employee ID name and designation
salary etc etc so we will be trying to
create the same table using Microsoft
Excel but before that let us understand
the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
through the Practical demo first so I
have started my Microsoft Excel and this
is how the home page of Microsoft Excel
looks like so you have a blank workbook
over here if you want to create a new
workbook you can select new Option so
Excel will provide you with various
variety of sheets you can see money in
Excel adjustable meeting agenda
streaming show list small business cash
flow and many more if you're not able to
find what you're looking for then you
always have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers list budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the Excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the Excel is
loading few types of sheets
so you can see that Excel has provided
us with some online varieties of sheets
for example any calendar business
expenses Channel marketing budget budget
summary report blue product list etc etc
you can see construction proposal
invoice your name Excel has got it so
Excel will provide you with some variety
of options based on your requirement now
for this session let's get started with
a blank workbook which looks something
like this since this tutorial is based
on the fundamentals we'll go with the
blank workbook
now over here you can see the toolbar
that we discussed earlier that has the
file home insert draw base layout
formulas data review View and help so
this is the toolbar and under the
toolbar I have selected home and you can
see this is the particular ribbon what
we discussed about this particular
ribbon belongs to home page and when you
select file option you'll get back to
home and if you select insert option
you'll have another different ribbon
with different groups etc etc so every
particular tool has different ribbons in
them and remember the extra options that
we discussed when you press over this
Arrow key this is it so when you press
the arrow key you'll have few more
settings which cannot be fit in this
particular section of groups so you can
have some variety of options over here
of changing the font changing some FX to
the text font size and font style etc
etc apart from this we have also
discussed about the cells in every sheet
so this particular cell has an address
so you can see the address over here
which is B3 so B happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name now we also had a discussion
about the shear tracker right now we
just have one sheet if you want multiple
sheets you can just feel free to select
on the plus option which will always
create you some extra sheets
and you can navigate through sheets just
by pressing on the sheet name
and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with 100 percent
now these are the few fundamentals that
you need to keep in mind before getting
started with Microsoft Excel now that we
know the fundamentals of Microsoft Excel
let's get started with a practical
session which is about the employee's
details in a company
now let's select this particular cell
and let's type in employee details
yeah we have the cell
now an employee details table will have
the information related to employees so
the information will be about name
it will be about employee number
it will be the designation
and maybe salary
and maybe blood group as well
and let's take another one which is
phone number
yeah
so so far so good and you can see that
we have some problem with this
particular column the designation and
the name the name of the designation is
practically good but it is not visible
so when you uh when you're not on that
particular cell you can see that the
name is incomplete over here so you can
always fix that you can just you know
manually change the size of the row or
cell or you can also feel free to you
know double click on that cell which
will automatically you know set the size
of that particular cell and same goes to
the blood group just let's try to double
click on that and same goes to phone
number
great
so you can see that the employees
details are just confined to the first
two cells it's supposed to be somewhere
in the middle right so no problem we can
do that as well we can select all the
cells and we have an option of merging
them
you can just select this one which will
help you with merging and centering that
particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it
now let's get started by adding the
names of the employees
let's add the names Joe
John
uh Mary mark
Susan
and then
Jennifer
let's open mic
let's open them
chef
Jeffrey
yeah we have a couple of employees now
let's type in the employee numbers
yeah we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose Joe to be the CEO of the company
and John as the software developer
and Mary as tester
Mark and finance
Susan also in finance
and Jennifer in testing
and Mike in marketing
same goes for Tim
and again Jeffrey into software
development
and uh
login into testing again
now let's click on C so that it gets you
know resized according to the length of
the text
now it's done so let's get into salary
uh ten thousand dollars
and fifteen thousand dollars
and
nineteen thousand dollars let's increase
the salary of a CEO so let's keep it one
lakh dollars
and finance again twenty thousand
so yeah the salaries are allocated again
the blood group
foreign
groups now let's type in the mobile
numbers
[Music]
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well
so uh yeah this is how you can add in
some data into your table
and now let us imagine that you forgot
to add or remove a column so let's
imagine that we wanted to add a serial
number as well but somehow we forgot to
add it now you can always add a new row
or column for example here we wanted to
add a new column so we just have to
right click on a select the insert
option
here we have a new row now
let's type in serial number
and let's type one
now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right click
and
fill series now we have the employee
number starting from 1 to 10.
that's how you do it and apart from this
you can also uh you know change the font
of the entire row you can change the
font to
say
aroni and you can always also change the
font
and same goes to the employee table we
can select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select a
color for the text maybe a different
color green would be better
and you can also select the entire cells
and align them to the center
looks more good
and you can select or double click the
row names so you'll have the proper
spacing between all the rows and columns
so we have double click on the column
right yeah so basically that's how you
make things happen now let's save this
so I'd like to go to the save option and
amp data
let me save this in my local location
and just save it's done
so that's how you work on your Excel
file with some basic data and to learn
more don't forget to get subscribed to
Simply learns YouTube channel and don't
forget to hit that Bell icon to stay
updated so you are the first person to
get an update on any technology not just
Excel now we are on the Microsoft Excel
and this particular spreadsheet is
related to employee details
yeah now the screen is visible a bit
better now let us imagine that this is
our confidential data and you want to
edit only two columns that is the
designation column and phone number
column now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes so now the minor edits that
you want to make are related to the
designation column and phone number
column now you can see that all the
columns that is the blood group new
salary salary hike current salary and
name of the employee serial number
employee number everything is editable
so in such kind of scenarios when you
pass on this data there might be a
possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this sheet
now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can log the
cells by the following process
so in this process you have two major
steps first one is to lock the cells and
the next one is to protect the cells by
a password now when you select all the
cells in this particular sheet you can
just click on this edge here and you
have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
cells
so in this particular option you have
some options provided which is number
alignment font and you want to go into
the protection part so you can see by
default Excel keeps all the cells locked
now we want the phone number and
designation to be unlocked okay so let's
cancel it for now and get back to the
sheet and select the columns D and I
and now let's right click and go into
format cells and in the protection
option make sure that you uncheck the
locked icon now select OK and now
okay so you cannot include the merge to
sell fine we have a cell here which is
merged okay let's remove that
foreign
now again select the entire column
right click get into format cells and
uncheck the lock option select ok
now we have finished the first part that
is locking all the cells which you don't
want to get added and unlocking the
cells where you want to make some edits
now the second stage is protecting the
sheet now right click on the sheet name
and you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select love cells and also select
envelope cells so let us provide a
password here so let us use some simple
password so that we don't forget that so
I'll be selecting one two three and now
select ok
re-enter the password to proceed now let
us type one two three again now select
OK and now the sheet is protected
now we have successfully logged and
protected all the cells in Excel now let
us verify that the cells you wanted to
protect are really protected and locked
or not so we have unlocked phone number
and designation and everything else is
locked now let me try and edit the blood
group so when I double click or try to
edit this particular sheet then I'll be
receiving a warning from Excel it says
the cell or chart you're trying to
change is on a protected sheet to make a
change unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a password
so it says that this particular cell is
locked and you cannot edit it now let us
try to edit the phone numbers which we
kept as unlocked
so you can see I can really edit the
unlocked cell here now let me try to
change this phone number let me enter
some random phone number
so you can see the cell is editable now
let us go through the designation column
and try to edit this particular column
now since I said that there is a
promotion happening in the company so
the deputy CEO is now the current CEO of
the company
and software developer happens to become
the cemia software developer
and the tester as well let us imagine
that he will become the senior
and so on
okay so this proves that this particular
sheet is editable not the entire sheet
but only the sense that we kept in the
analog mode
okay
now this is how you lock and protect
your cells in Excel page setup in Ms
Excel
so to understand the pitch setup in Ms
Excel we will go through a demo
inventory in Excel where we'll be
considering some restaurant data
now without any delay let's get started
with a practical demo
we are on the
X the data I was talking about the
restaurant data where we have the First
Column that is Rank and next we have the
restaurant name followed by that we have
the sales happening through that
restaurant and then we have the segment
category that is what kind of service
does that particular restaurant offers
now this is the list what we made and
what if we wanted to represent this data
and the form of a printed paper right so
I guess you can see all the columns and
rows here so you can see that we have
almost like 250 rows so there is no
chance or there is no way to print all
those 250 rows in one page of course it
is practically possible but when you try
to read the content it'll be so tough to
read Because all the rows will be club
together so closely so that you cannot
read it so uh you need to print them
Page by page so and you need to also
take care of the data is aligned
properly according to the page size
everything and even you need to take
care of the margins of your page right
so that's what paid setup basically
means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we are trying to
make now let us see how page setup is
possible in Ms Excel so to go to the
page setup menu or go to the page setup
options we have three methods let's
start with the simplest method so the
simplest method is by just clicking on
file and go to print option
and you'll see all
options right over here
and you can also go to print menu by
pressing a shortcut method that is Ctrl
p
so you'll directly end up on the page
setup options now let's look at the
second method so the second method is
you can see the toolbar over here right
which has file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help so the second method we can use
page layout option from the toolbar and
you can see when you click on the page
option from the toolbar you have a new
ribbon over here so this ribbon is all
about page setup options so it will
offer you margins it will offer you
orientation size print area breaks
background print tiles etc etc right so
all these options are menus in this
ribbon belong to page setup now let us
look at the third method so the third
method is something similar you have
view option on the toolbar so just
select a view and you can see we have
few page setup options over here as well
the normal page break page layout custom
views and we have gridlines formula bar
heading zoom in zoom out select to zoom
free certain panes right so all these
are also the page setup options so we
have the three methods to enter the page
setup options now we are familiar
earlier with those now let's get started
with the Practical mode on page setup
for that let me use the simplest method
that is holding the control key and
pressing P which navigates me to the
print option
now we have various set of options here
we have no scaling normal margins letter
portrait orientation collated print
active sheets and Note 1 for Windows you
can see this option is a printers option
for example if you are connected to a
printer which is the hardware printer
then your Ms Excel will show the
printers name here so other than printer
you can also make some other
arrangements where you can just directly
print your complete data in the form of
PDF and then you can export your PDF to
your recipient that's also possible okay
now let's get started with the first
option that is print active pages okay
to understand this better we need to
create a new sheet not a problem so you
can see that we just have one sheet over
here
so let us kind of select all the items
and create a new sheet and try to paste
it over here
or let's try to paste it over here
okay
now let's try to extend these
yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet
sheet uh
or let's rename it as
restaurant
sheet 2.
for our reference now let us get back to
the print sheet option so I'll use the
shortest method that is holding the Ctrl
key and press p now you can see that
here we have six pages in total from the
active sheets so the current active
sheet is the top 250 sheet so this
particular sheet is the current active
sheet so if we print the entire data in
this particular sheet then we will end
up printing six pages now let us select
the other option where you have to print
the entire workbook right so now you can
see that there is a change in the number
that is 12 pages so what is a workbook
so basically workbook is the collection
of entire sheets and your Excel home
page so in this particular Excel
homepage you have the first sheet that
is top 250 and the second sheet that is
the restaurant sheet 2 right so the
combination of these two sheets make up
a workbook
so when you select the entire workbook
option you'll have 12 pages so that's
how we use this setting where you select
the active sheets the entire workbook
and there is another option where you
can only print a selected item so if you
want to do this then let's get back here
now what if your customer or what if
your client wanted the top 10
restaurants only so you can select the
top 10 restaurants
bye doing this
now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to print
so you can see Excel has automatically
selected the selection only print the
selected content only so you can see we
have only the top 10 restaurants or top
11 restaurants that we have selected in
our sheet and it is ready to get printed
so this is how we use the first option
now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again now you can see the next
option that is collated
right so in collated you have different
different options that is one two three
one two three and one two three and the
next one which is uncolated one one one
two two two three three three so why are
these numbers uh present here and what
does collected mean anyway so this is
your question right now the answer for
this question will be a little similar
to your examination Hall okay let us
imagine that you are an examination Hall
and you are the invigilator and you have
10 students in your room
so you wanted to provide question papers
to all the 10 students okay so you have
your question paper distributed into
three sheets that is you have marked
questions and your questions are fit
into three papers right in this scenario
we have 250 rows and all the data is
split into six sheets that is sheet 1 or
page 1 page two page 3 page four right
now if we wanted to print 10 copies then
the arrangement of papers will be page 1
page 2 page 3 page 4 page five page six
in continuous order right that is
collated if you wanted 10 copies of
different different ways where you
wanted to print the first sheet first
then you wanted to print the second
sheet second and the third sheet third
that is you'll have 10 copies of first
page 10 copies of second page 10 copies
of third page and so on that particular
approach is called uncollated approach
and if you are printing the pages in
continuous order for 10 times then that
particular approach is called as
collated approach so this is what we had
to learn about collated and uncolluted
now let's get back to the third option
now let's press again print now we have
our data over here
there is something wrong
select all the elements Ctrl V yeah now
we have our data pack now we have the
third option that is the portrait
orientation okay so when we click that
we have two options that is portrait and
landscape so you might be having a good
idea like when you try to click a
picture in your phone we have two modes
as well that is portrait mode and the
landscape mode so when you click on the
portrait mode this is how your data will
be looking now to understand the
difference let's click the landscape
mode so when you click the landscape
mode this is how your data
representation will change you'll have a
wider page to print so this is why we
use the page orientation for now let's
keep the page orientation as portrait
orientation
and we have now the fourth option so
what is the fourth option we have
various sets of options in here that is
letter and A4 size there are also some
more page options over here where you
can select the page types you want to
print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is A4 A5 A3 Etc but here we
just have two that is A4 and letter so
basically you'll get those options and
followed by that next we have margins so
here you can see we don't have any
margins for our data okay so now we can
add some margins by setting up this one
as an option like last custom setting or
you can also choose normal wide narrow
right so your page will be changed
according to your margin size
right so this is how you can change the
margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the
normal one
now we have the next option that is
scaling option
so here you can see we are trying to fit
the page so when you're trying to print
these sheets using no scaling then the
actual size of the page will be printed
now we can also modify that you can fit
and print these sizes so you can
remember the first option that I said of
printing all the 250 rows in one single
sheet this is how you can fit it so fit
the sheet on one page where you can see
all the 250 rows are fit into one page
but the data is not readable so but we
don't want this type of an approach
right so let's keep it as the default
one which is no scaling so these are the
variety of options in print
now if you wanted to print the all the
six pages into the PDF format and mail
it to your client you can also do that I
think I have explained it in the first
place so you can see we can do it by
just selecting this option where you can
print all the six pages and into PDF
format and then you can mail them to
your client
and you can also select the number of
copies you want you can increase the
copies to 2 3 and any number of copies
you want for now I'll keep it as one
copy
[Music]
now let's print this
now let us select the
location
rename it and publish
now let's get back to documents and see
if the page is printed or not
here here we have the restaurant data in
the form of PDF
so we have our entire six pages of data
in the PDF format
now we are back on the home page now we
had some limited functions in the print
functions over here
we have tried to export the data so you
can also export the data or try to print
it from the print option over here you
can just select that as well
PDF
yes the pages are printed now
there you go we have the restaurant 2
PDF data
so that's how you can print all your
data you can either choose
the export option or you can either
choose print option now when you see
into the print option we have limited
number of page setup options over here
now let's check out what we missed so we
are in the page layout here so we had
gone through the margins we had set all
the margins and then we have also gone
through the portrait and landscape now
you can see this size when we were in
the print menu option we had only A4 and
letter but here you can see there are a
wide variety of options that is other
than later we have tabloid legal
statement executive A3 right we have A5
and many more other options and if you
want some more paper options you can go
to more and you can always select few
more options that's how you do it and
yeah we didn't had the break option so
remember when we had been through the
print option we did not have the break
option there
let's select this to normal A4 so you
cannot see the break option over here
right so here we have the brick option
so what does break option does right you
can actually break the page remember we
spoke about the top 10 things or the top
10 rows you can always do that so you
can just keep the top 10 restaurants in
your first page and then break the
remaining and to set page breaks you can
select the cell now I need the top 10 so
I'll select this particular cell which
is in the 11th position
and now I'll try to implement the page
trick insert a page break and now you
can see on my sheet there is a thin line
which is separating the two pages that's
how you can see the indication of app
page break implemented onto your page
now how do you see it you can see it by
selecting Ctrl P where you can see the
first top 10 restaurants being printed
on your sheet so there you go we have
the first top 10 restaurants printed on
our sheets so that's how you use the
page break
now let's try to eliminate all the page
breaks so you can select breaks and
reset all page tricks so the page break
has been eliminated
now you can always choose a background
for your data as well you just if you
want you can add a picture to your
background I think that's not
available for now
okay you can work offline as well let us
select this one
so you can see that we have added a
background to our data
we can select all the text files and
then you can change the color so that
the text becomes a little visible
yeah that's how you do it now if you
don't want the image to be added on your
file you can also remove that delete
piece background and there you go all
the images are gone
now the next important part that is the
print titles
now why do we need print titles for that
let's try to print this
so now you can see the first page in the
first page we have the title rank
restaurant sales segment category but if
you go to the second page you don't have
that title right you don't have the
title rank name of the restaurant sales
and their service category so if we want
that then we need to add Titans
now for that let's select the print
titles option
now let's select the rows to repeat on
top
now for that we need the first row
select the first row and this particular
row will be repeating into all the pages
now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the titles are
being added to all the sheets you can
see the page 2 page 3 page 4 page 5 and
page six so you can see the title is
added to all the sheets
so that's I use the print titles option
so now we are on the Excel sheet and you
can see that in this particular Excel
sheet we have some student details we
have the serial numbers names row
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social JK and the final marks
obtain percentage and total marks right
so let us imagine that a company has
come for an interview
so all these students are going to
attend an interview and the minimum
percentage to attend the interview will
be like 75 percent so you can see that
we have 75 here and all the students
have got above 75 except for the one
student who watches mic right so for
Mike to attend the interview he needs 75
percentage or above so uh he can make
some modifications in one of these
subjects right so there is always an
exam after the exam called as
Improvement exam so if you can like this
course and extra marks in the subjects
which you have scored less so that you
can make up to the percentage what
you're expecting you can do that so here
in this particular sheet uh Mike has six
subjects right and in such subjects you
can see he has code 76 91 45 71 94 and
62. so out of these he have scored less
and one subject compared to all the
subjects one subject is really low that
is computers so what if he can give an
improvement exam and increase his
percentage to 75 right so that can be
done so if we can do some Brute Force
methods like we can change the marks
like 55 and then check this particular
one so it's getting 74 right so using
the brute force method will be little
bit lengthy so you can do this because
it is just a small table which has least
number of data and you just have one
single cell to modify so that can be
done in small tables but what if you had
some table with hundreds of rows or
thousands of rows that will be time
consuming right so for that we have some
inbuilt functionality in Excel that is
called goal seek in Excel
so for now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65. now we need
the target as 75 okay so let's write it
as
Mike's Target right we need mic so mics
new Target as
75.
[Music]
okay now to make sure that we need a
Mark here which can get mic to 75
percentage we will use the data
operation so here on the toolbar which
has file home insert Etc we have one
other option called as data so when you
click on data from toolbar you'll have
this ribbon and in this ribbon we have
various options so when you come into
forecast group we have an option called
what if analysis when you click on
what-if analysis you'll have a set of
options out of which we have goal seek
now for goal seek we need to select a
table cell that is this particular table
cell that is M9 so we need the value 75
here right so what is the cell that you
need to change here for that you need to
select this one and select this
particular cell here right and now you
can select ok now you can see that Excel
has automatically run all the
permutations and combinations and has
come up with a number so that the
overall percentage of mic will be 75
percent right so the expected marks that
Mike should be getting in his computers
Improvement exam should be equal to 56
or greater than 56 to get the final
Target as 75 so that he can attend the
company's interview so this is how we
use goal set or goal seek in Excel now
let's quickly get onto the Practical
mode where we will have some data sets
over which we will be trying to apply
the charts now there are various types
of charts in W and those are the pie
chart the column chart the bar chart
column versus line preview chart and
sparkline charts so we will discuss one
after the other first let us discuss
about the pie chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which I have personally
created and this deals with the
companies and this deals with the shares
of the automobile industry so now for
this let's create a pie chart
select all the data and then get into
the Tuple bar and inside the toolbar you
can see various options and inside that
we're gonna use the insert option and
when you select the insert option you
will have a ribbon here and inside the
ribbon you can see groups tables
illustrations add-ins and here you go
these are the charts so now we needed a
pie chart so select on that icon and you
have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimension pie charts donor type of
charts
Etc right so I would like to go over the
three dimensional pie chart as it looks
a little more appealing and easy to
understand and now there you go this is
the title of the chart and these are the
legends of the chart and this is the
chart area and these are the values now
we can you know kind of add the data
labels as well so you can just have to
press the plus icon over here and you'll
have the options you can add the data
labels which will give you a lot more
interesting values
and you can also turn this around
as you can see we on double clicking any
part of the pie chart you'll get this
option which is called as format data
point and let's imagine that you wanted
to show the information related to this
particular one which is a Volvo which
has the biggest share so this is in
front right now now what if you wanted
to show the information related to Tata
which is over here right for that you
can select this particular Arrow key and
you can just twist it and there you go
it is coming in front this will be a
great way of presenting your data to
your clients right
yeah and there is another option where
you can directly explore this like you
can pick it out you can see this right
Point explosion where you can split it
out and you can show that especially
like you can highlight it and show it so
that's the you know a great way of
presenting your data so that's how you
can work with pie charts in Excel now
let's quickly move to the next one that
is the column chart
and in the column chart we have the data
related to some company and the profits
of that company based on a year so you
can see that the year has started from
2008 and it has gone until 2021 and
these are the profits of that company
year after year so since we are dealing
with column chart I'll tell you the
simplest way to create a column chart
there is a shortcut key for that
which is alt F1 and there you go you
have the chart right on your screen
now you can expand the chart just by
dragging it like that and
you can see that there is some problem
with this chat that is we have numbers
here instead of years right you can see
that the First Column is the es which is
2008 to 2021 but here you can see we
have one two three four which is not
proper right so to change the
axis that as you can see the axis which
is one two three four from one two three
four to the years 2008 2009 2010 11 Etc
you just have to make one change here
and also you can see I have pressed the
plus icon over here which will open the
option where you can include the access
titles if you have and data labels
everything right so for now I think I'll
keep it as it is so you can include the
data table as well as it is here and you
can include that in the chart there are
various options that Excel provides you
so now let's focus on changing the axis
from one two three four to the ears for
that you need to select the chart design
and inside the chart design you have an
option called select data press that and
here you have various set of options you
can see profits you can see EOS now
we'll select years and we will remove
that and now you can see the edit option
here right select that and now it will
ask you which column to be selected for
the access range for that let's select
this and now let's select the years here
hmm press ok
and there you go again press ok so there
you go you have the ears over here
instead of the numbers which you had in
the first place so that's how you create
the column chart and we have the next
type of chart which is really simple
now you know it kind of change this
chart directly into bar chart there is
no big deal in that
so uh for that you just need to select
the change chart type option over here
you're just changing the chart type and
you can get the paragraph over here
column and bar graphs are completely
same to each other only that you can see
these uh bars in the horizontal way
rather than in the vertical way and
let's do that let's not create a new
thing for that so uh yeah there you go
when you select the change chart type
option you have various set of chart
type options on the menu bar over here
so what we needed was the bar chart now
let's select that and there you go
let's select OK and you have the bar
chart
right and if you want you can include
the data labels which look a little bit
more interesting you can also include
the data table as well
okay for now I think we have to expand
the chart to get the Clear View
yeah that's how you do it
right now let's move into the next type
of one here we dealt with the bar chart
so we'll directly enter into the column
versus line chart
so we have a similar kind of data we
just had ear and profits in the previous
part now we also have included the
expenses right we needed another column
to showcase the line chart compared to
the columns right so for that I've
included a new column that is expenses
all as well now just let's select the
data
and let's select the option
alt F1 to create a chart
right now automatically uh Excel has
provided us the column chat we have The
Columns of expenses we have the column
of profits and we also have ears now
let's change the data as we did before
select uh here and remove it and then
edit
select edit and select the year that is
from here to 2021
select OK and we have the ears over here
now what we needed to do is change the
chart type right select the change chart
type option and since we wanted to
create a column versus line chart it is
a combination whenever you want one or
two types of charts included in one
single chart window then it is a combo
option so here we need to select the
combo option and inside that we have
various types of combination charts we
have clustered column we have clustered
line or secondary axis we have clustered
stat areas clustered column and the
other one is custom combination so let's
go with the first one that is clustered
line
let's select that and there you go we
have the line graph with the column so
that's how we create the column versus
line and if you want you can include the
data labels and you can include the data
table as well yeah
okay I think we need to expand the
canvas a little more to get a clear view
yeah
so you have Legends over here you have
the data labels and accesses everything
and chart title you can always change
the chart title so for now let's uh
rename it as
profits versus expenses
yeah that's that's how it goes
done
spelling mistake here
yeah it's clear now
the next type of chart we're going to
deal with is the previous chart
so uh we have dealt with pie chart
column chart bar chart and column versus
line now previous chart is a little bit
different it's like you're going to
create some active chart which responds
to the variations you are making to your
data so to understand that better let's
create a practical chart over here
I select all the data
okay
yeah I have selected the data now
to create a pivot chart
so let's select
the insert option from the toolbar and
inside the ribbon we have charts group
and inside that we have debit chart now
let's select the PB chat option
and there you go now it's asking for
range and we have selected the range
over there
and uh we are not going to create a new
worksheet for the entire chart we are
going to create the chart inside the
existing worksheet itself so for that
let's select the uh area where we want
to select the chart to be present now
for that let's select this and
yeah select ok
okay there is some error
and let's cancel this and try again
let's select the data
and preview chat again
we have selected the range
here
that's how you select the range
and now select the position where you
want to create it existing worksheet we
have selected that and press OK yeah
that's that's the way we've got our
previous chart over here and you can see
our previous chart is completely blank
right now it will respond to the changes
you make to your previous chat for now
we have serial numbers and these are the
names of the guys who have
okay so these are the names of the guys
you who have some dealerships for
various car makes such as Ford Ferrari
Honda Kia Alfa Romeo BMW etc etc so uh
we're gonna change or we're gonna see
um you know we're gonna make some charts
of the persons who own the cars or the
car brands or dealerships in various
regions so we're gonna work on that now
let's drag in the name
and uh let's drag region
and cards
and units
yep so we have our chart over here
column chart which has the different
different names and the dealerships and
some of cars over there right so you can
see that we can also change some values
over here what if we wanted to know only
uh the details regarding Jennifer you
can do that you can unselect everything
and you can just select Jennifer and
press ok now you'll have the details of
only Jennifer of having the car brands
so we have the regions as well so
Jennifer owns dealerships in two
different regions that is South and West
and the sum of units and count of cars
as well
so that's how the PV charts are used in
real time
and now let's select sales and track the
sales as well
yeah it's been dragged and you have the
sales of Jennifer
the details of her sales
and let's move the chart a little bit
and you have the plus icon where you can
include the data labels for a better
information
yeah so that's how you use the previous
chats so we are on the last type of
charts which is the sparkline chart Now
to create a sparkline chart we need to
get into the insert option and inside we
have the ribbon and inside the ribbon we
have the group that is sparklines now
to generate our sparkline chart we need
to select this particular column and
then select the type of sparkline you
want to create so now let's create the
column type of sparkline chart yep
we have to flop these cells together
first we've got that because we're gonna
insert the sparkline chart right above
here
now for that let's merge the cells
[Music]
yeah
so we wanted to create the
sparkline chart of column type and now
it's asking for the location where we
want to create the spark launcher so
this is the location now let's select ok
and there you go we have the sparkline
chart right over here
now you can see that we have a negative
Point here so if you want you can change
that from negative to positive and it
will automatically update that and if
you want to add the access to this
particular chart you can select the
options parkline and there you go you
have certain options like High Point low
point and if you wanted to add some
margins then you can also do that
at the data type access and they're
going to have the access
show access yeah you have the access now
and you can have the high point and low
point for that as well which is the you
know the biggest change and the smallest
change in this particular segment that
is few Furniture yeah Furniture has the
highest sales in January and Home
Appliance at the lower sale and you can
also change the color
and let's type of change the color again
yeah we have a different color over here
which resembles a little bit more better
or you can also go with this one
and if you wanted to add the same to all
these tables you can do that just by
dragging it and you have it for all the
six months
now if we wanted to add some new data in
this row or you wanted to add a new
complete row then you can do that as
well and change that and bring that
change implemented in these charts as
well
now let us try to add a new row here
which includes the miscellaneous we have
that data right over here let's select
that
copy and let's paste it over here
so there you go we have the extra row
here so yeah now we have added the
miscellaneous row and right now we have
the sparkline chart for only four
columns or four rows that is financial
technology home appliances and office
needs and miscellaneous is missing now
to add that as well let's select
sparkline
and inside sparkline just select edit
Group location and data and now let's
select the entire data
and now select ok
there's something wrong
you can
sparkline edit data
select range
this should be helping yeah there you go
we have all the five rows now including
Furniture technology home appliances
office needs and miscellaneous so what
is data validation in Excel so it is a
feature by Microsoft Excel where it can
restrict data entry into certain cells
by using data validation
and it will prompt the users to enter
valid data in the cells based on the
rules and restrictions provided by the
creator of that particular sheet now
this would be a little confusing to
understand so to understand it in a much
better way let's get back to the
practical way where we will start
entering some data validation rules to
our Excel sheet and try to enter data
into it now we are on the Microsoft
Excel and this particular sheet is based
on employee ID employee name employee
Department employee salary fiscal year
and work timings of the employees
now we will be applying some data
validation rules to each and every
column and try to enter data based on
the rows we have entered now for the
first one which is the employee ID we'll
enter rules based on the employee ID
number so to apply the data validation
you need to go into the data tab on the
toolbar
and inside the ribbon you can see data
tools group and in the data tools group
you have the option of data validation
now select the entire column go to the
data tools group select data validation
option and you will have this particular
pop-up menu
and here you can see different types of
options so since we are entering
employee ID it would be a whole number
so let's select whole number option and
now here you can see the option of
between not equal to equal to not
between greater than less than Etc
so let us select between and let us
assume that your employee ID has five
numbers and it should be between 10 000
to
11 000.
so let us provide 10 000
and 11 000.
now select ok
and now the new rule has been applied
so now the minimum value of each and
every employee ID should be equal to or
more than 10 000 and less than 11 000
and it should have five digits
now let's try to enter a wrong employee
ID that is just one
there you go you can see that Microsoft
Excel is not allowing you to include a
wrong number it says this value does not
match the data validation restrictions
defined for this cell so now you can
press retry and try to enter some number
which is in between 10 000 to 11 000.
now it is 10901 and this will take the
entry
now let us assume that because I am the
creator of this I know what should
be entered here but what if I give this
to you and you are the person who
is trying to enter the number and it
shows the error and you don't know what
was there
right to avoid this kind of confusion
what you can do is you can do some uh
ways where you can provide the message
to the user so that can be done by okay
let's select this sheet again and go to
the data validation and here you have
the same settings now here you have
another option saying input message
so before input message let us go to
error alert now here
the error title would be data entered
is not valid
please enter this is the error message
please enter
EMP
between
10 000 to 11 000.
press ok
now when you try to enter the wrong
number it will show that particular
error alert message
see data entered is not valid please
enter employee ID between 10 000 to 11
000. now this is fine but how long this
will be you know what if there is an
option where you just hover over to the
cell and it automatically tells you to
enter the value between ten thousand to
eleven thousand without having to face
the error yeah even that can be done so
you can select the entire column go to
data validation and here this is the
input message this is where you can do
that so here you can write the message
name validator
please enter
data between
10 000 to
11 000. now when you hover over to any
excel in this particular column it will
automatically show you this message
where you can avoid all the errors
just select OK see when you select any
cell in this particular column it will
automatically tell you please enter data
between ten thousand to eleven thousand
so here you don't have to face any
errors right now let us try to enter the
valid data
1 0 9
0 2
and it will take it as the correct value
and again 1 0 9 0 3.
now in case if you try to provide the
wrong number it will show the error
see
so that's how it is now we have finished
the whole number part now let's get into
the employee name where we have to
provide
the second type that is text length now
let us imagine that uh in your company
you're trying to provide ID cards to
your employees and you know that ID card
is really small and inside that ID card
you need to include the employee
photograph and your company name
employee ID blood group phone number
address everything and also you need to
include the name of the employee so what
if there is an employer with very
lengthy name like 30 characters 40
characters yeah in India it is really
possible that you might have a lengthy
name so what you can do is you can
provide the text length where the text
is limited to like 15 or 20
characters so you can include that name
in the ID card so you can do that by
allowing the data validation criteria
with text length minimum can be anything
so minimum can be one and maximum here
you can provide 15. and press ok ok
minimum will change it to at least two
and yeah let it be one
so minimum is one and maximum is 15
characters and press ok
and let us also provide the input
message
enter
enter character type character data
please enter valid name
and error alert
invalid data
please enter validator
please enter characters
less than
50.
press ok
now let us try to enter a random name
okay we'll enter characters more than 15
here equality
see It'll be uh yeah it's like one two
three four five eleven
okay now this is more than 15.
okay I think it's not more than 15.
let's try to enter a little bit more
characters
now we have entered more than 15
characters and it is showing please
enter characters less than 15. so now we
can retry and try to enter some valid
name
uh
now we have characters less than 50 so
it will take as the proper name
now let us try to enter another name
I'm just entering some random data
so another name maybe
great now the next type of data
validation is also done now let us get
into employee Department employee
department is something really superb so
I'll tell you about it it's actually a
list now let us finish the other ones
first that is employee salary fiscal
year and work timings after that we'll
learn about the list one
now let's come into employee salary so
salary is something where you have to
include decimal points so now let us go
to uh data validation and inside the
values we have already dealt with whole
number
uh text length
yeah now we'll deal with employee salary
that is decimal
now minimum is okay what is the uh
minimum can be one
point zero zero and maximum can be
one lakh
point zero zero or let us
put that as 10 lakhs
press ok
not not just them and enter valid
salary
okay now let's change it to minimum as
10 000.
so the employee minimum salary will be
ten thousand and input enter valid
salary
and uh
between
ten thousand
to 10 lakhs
let us include a comma here too
thank you
now error alert
invalid salary
please enter
between
10 000
to 10 lakhs
press ok now the message and the data
validation conditions are applied to
this column now let us try to enter some
invalid data first
we'll show the error
now we need to enter the valid data
yeah now it is taking the valid data let
us provide twenty thousand
and this is 35
000.
now the next one is fiscally let us
imagine that we wanted to you know work
on the employees for current working
gear that is 2020 to 2021 and or you can
consider 2021 to 2022 not more than 2021
and not less than 2021. for that you can
provide the year option as well so for
that you need to select the entire
column go to data validation settings
and inside here you have an option of
date
so let us provide the date option as
between and start date is 0 1 0 1 slash
2021 and end date is
0 1 0 1 slash
and input message
let us provide it as current
fiscal year
Current financial year
date
between
2021 to 2022.
let us copy this and go into error alert
error message will be saved invalid
[Music]
select ok now there are message and the
data input message and the data
validation rule has been applied for
this column so let's try to enter some
date here
you can enter 0 2 of February
2021 it will take as the correct data
now let's try to enter some wrong data
which is apart from 2020 to 0 to 0 2
22 it will not take this it will throw
error
so that's how it works now let us try to
enter as 2021
and this is March
it will take it now another data
0 4 this time and 2021
so that's how your date data validation
will work now coming into the next type
of data validation that is time
so we have time here let us imagine that
you are providing some work timings to
your employees that should be from 9 am
to 5 PM not more than that so you want
to keep your work life balanced for all
your employees so you just want them to
work between nine to five and that
should be fine and anything apart from
that time should be invalid so you can
do that by selecting a Time option
between it should be in between and the
start time will be 0 9
0 0 and this should be
uh
17.
that is 5 PM in the evening
and input message
please enter
time between
9 am
to
okay
5 PM
this should be the input message
now error alert
invalid time
error message
now
okay
work timings now
this should be okay
we can do this as two columns actually
let us
cancel
let us copy this and paste it here
you can do it as login
timing and this should be okay
this should be a log out
so this should be
okay so this will be considered as login
and logout times
now let us provide the login time
this should be the right time and
let's try to provide wrong timings zero
eight now it will not take it it will
throw as error
so it's working fine let us provide 10
now let us provide the logout time it
should be below 5 PM
so let us provide five it will take it
okay
let's try to provide something just one
minute less than five
that is 59
okay there is some problem in this let's
check it
okay it is taking uh three that is
including seconds
okay let's provide seconds as well
zero five zero zero zero
because still there is some problem
okay we have entered four we should we
are supposed to enter 24 hour timing
right
okay it should be 17. I think this will
work yeah
now we are following 24 hour timing here
so let's provide another timing that is
300 this will be valid and 1530
this is also value now we have finished
almost all types of uh data validation
things that is we have finished with any
value whole number decimal date timing
test length and the last one is list so
this is where things get interesting now
let's cancel this now
select the employee column now if you
are running a company then definitely
you will not have only one Department in
it you might have multiple departments
right so let us consider that you have a
software development company so in that
the basic departments will be software
development team and software testing
team
so what you can do is you can provide a
list
so using that list you can just hover
over to that cell select the drop down
menu and inside that you can select the
option so we will try to work something
like that if we have selected the entire
column
the selection okay
yeah let us select the entire column
again go to data validation the
selection contains some cells without
data validation settings do you want to
extend data validation to the cells yes
now let us provide the list option
and
here Source you can provide us
developer
and test
press OK OK
now input message
select one
error alert
invalid
data
select from drop down
only
press ok
now when you select the cell you can see
small drop down icon right so when you
press it you will have developer and
tester option
so you can select developer for first
one and for second one you can select
tester right okay this is good for uh
one or two options maybe three or even
maybe like five but what if you have
more departments okay let's go to this
uh second sheet where we have the
department data so here we have like 14
departments no 15 departments or 15
employee type names so the first one is
see your second list developer tester
quality analyst system analyst Finance
human resource so so many options are
there so you cannot keep on typing all
of them right so here it is 15 what if
you have like 25 like 50 departments
right it will be tough so for this you
have another option so let me select all
this data and copy this from this sheet
to our employee sheet
let us paste it somewhere
here
let's expand this
okay now we have our list over here now
let us remove the data validation from
this column
clear all okay now everything is clear
let's select ok now let us erase this
data as well
now let us apply the list data
validation again from scratch go to list
now here we can select the source
select this particular cell
and drag it until here and it has been
loaded
now go to input message
data options
select one
from the menu or the drop down
copy error alert
select only from the drop down menu
invalid entry yeah
now let's select ok
fine now you have the icon here you have
all the provided options
you can scroll down and select any one
of these you can select knowledge
transfer for the first one
and second one would be
system analyst
and the last one would be
human resources
now in the list everything is fine okay
this is showing you the menu options and
everything
so but what if you provide this sheet to
your new joining or new employee in your
company and by mistake he messes up
something like deleting this okay so we
have deleted systems analyst and when
you click on the options here you don't
have systems analyst in that place you
have blank space right so there is a way
where all your you know data can be
messed up so to avoid this what you can
do is
you can actually
um
save this data in a different sheet like
I did here like Department data you can
hide the sheet or you can protect the
sheet with password or something so that
nobody can mess this up so now let us
get back to the employee data and select
this column and uh clear everything
press ok
and let us also clear this
and this as well in this one too
now let us eliminate the rows our cells
the employee everything
okay now we have basically removed this
data from here
now let us try to apply the data
validation once again
now here
let us select as list
and
here let us provide the option
let us go to next sheet let us select
all these options
press ok
let's provide input message
data options
are Department options
particularly
yeah now let's select ok
now let's hide this sheet
the sheet has been hidden and you still
have the options
developer
or let us provide see you
then we have developer
then we have
test
so that's how you can protect your
sheets as well now this is how you apply
data validation in your Excel what is
Excel vlookup
vlookup stands for vertical lookup
vlookup lets you search for specific
information in your spreadsheet it
allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same row
vlookup takes advantage of vertically
aligned tables to quickly find data
associated with the value the user
enters now let's look at the syntax to
write a vlookup function so vlookup
takes four parameters or arguments you
can see it here there are four arguments
in the Wilco function
so the first argument is called the
lookup value the look of value
represents the value that you are
searching for next is the table array
the table array represents two or more
Columns of information the third
argument is called the column index
number now this represents the column
number in the table from which the value
must be returned the First Column is 1
the second column is 2 and so on and
then we have the fourth parameter which
is called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match
so if you want to find an exact match
you need to enter false or 0 meanwhile
if you want an approximate match you
need to enter true or one if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
now let me give you a brief overview on
what's going to be in our demo
so for our demonstration
we'll use a sales data set you can see
the data set on the left
using this data set we'll understand how
vlookup performs an exact and
approximate match we'll see how vlookup
is case insensitive
then we'll perform a wildcard character
search
will understand how to handle errors
when a match is not found and finally
you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how
vlookup works
so we want to find the units sold by
Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has
some rows and columns so these are the
columns which are order date region
there's a representative column item
units this unit cost and total and from
this table I want to find the units that
were sold by Morgan if you look at the
table at the bottom you can see the
representative name Morgan and Morgan
has sold 30 units now I want to find
this value using the vlookup function so
here on the right you can see I have my
lookup value which is Morgan and this is
my vlookup formula and using this
formula I am getting the result as 30.
now let's go to our Excel workbook and
perform all the demos one by one so this
is my Excel workbook that we are going
to use for our demo and here is the data
set we'll be using now this is the same
data set that you saw a while ago
so this data set has seven columns you
have the order date the region
representative's name item this units
unit cost and total which is basically
the total or the amount of sales that
was generated
now we are going to use a chunk of this
data set and perform our vlookup
analysis
so let's see our first example and the
problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab
all right
so here
I'm going to use this chunk of data
which is actually taken from the
original data set so we have taken the
first
11 rows from the data set you can see
from Row 2
till root 12 is going to be a data set
that we'll use
so we have a question here
we want to find the items sold by
Thomson so here
Thompson is my lookup value which means
looking at Thompson I want to find the
item that is sold
so if you consider our table here you
can see we have the representatives name
Thompson
right here and from the table you can
see Thompson sold pencil
and I want to get this value which is
pencil using my vlookup function so
let's go ahead and write our vlooker
function
I'll consider this as my lookup value
and here under item I'm going to write
my vlooker formula
to write the vlooker formula I'll write
first equal to
and
I'll write vlookup now if I hit tab it
will auto complete all right now let's
give the parameters so first is going to
be the lookup value which is nothing but
Thomson so I'll just select this cell
which is j17
comma now it's asking to give the table
array so the table array is the table
from which you want to retrieve a value
one thing to keep in mind is that the
value you are looking for should be the
first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find
so here I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of the item column which is
going to be my table array then I'll
select the column index number so the
column index number is based on the
table array you have selected in this
case my column index number is going to
be 2 because we have selected just two
columns and the value which I am going
to find is in the second column so I'll
give 2
comma now the range lookup I'm going to
give is false because I want to find an
exact match so either you can hit tab
or you can write 0 which means false
if I close the bracket and hit enter
it will return me the item that Thomson
had sold which is pencil you can verify
from the table that Thompson had sold
pencil all right
now let's try to change the table array
and see what result are we getting so
this time I'll slightly change the table
array so again we are trying to find the
item that Thompson had sold so I'll
write my formula equal to vlookup I'll
hit tab to auto complete I'll give my
lookup value as Thompson
comma this time I am choosing my table
array starting from the representatives
column till
the end of the data set which is
till p12
again my column index number is going to
be 2 because if you consider this table
array the item column is the second
column in the selected table array so I
am going to write it as 2 comma
the range lookup I want to give as false
because I want to find the exact match
if I close this and hit enter you can
see it has written me the same result
that we saw earlier
now suppose let's say this time I want
to start my table array from the region
column which is this column
so I want to select my table array
starting from the region column now this
is going to show me an error because
your table array should always start
from the lookup value column so if you
consider Thompson as the lookup value my
table array should always start from the
representatives column so let's just try
this example
so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value I'm going to give it as
Thompson comma the table array as I
mentioned earlier I am going to choose
from the region column and let's say
I'll select till the item column give
another comma and this time a column
index number is going to be 3 because
since the table array has three columns
and my item column is the last column so
I'm going to give my column index number
is 3 comma I want to get the exact match
so I'll give 0 if I close the bracket
and hit enter you can see it has given
me an error
okay now let me just show you another
method to use vlookup in Excel so here
on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select lookup and reference
if I click on this
and if I scroll down below you can see
there's an option
called vlookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give
your lookup value your table array
column index number and the range lookup
under this function arguments dialog box
so here I want to select my lookup value
as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be 2
I'll write 2
and range lookup I'll write as false
because I want the exact match
now if I hit OK you can see it has given
us the exact same result so this is one
of the other ways to use vlookup in
Excel now let's move to the next sheet
which is regarding approximate match
okay so sometimes you might have cases
where you don't have the lookup value
present in the table in those cases you
can tell vlookup to return an
approximate match
now one thing to keep in mind is that
your lookup value column should always
be sorted in ascending order while
trying to get an approximate match so
here we are going to use this table and
my lookup value column which is going to
be the representatives column is already
sorted in ascending order
and let's see the question we have here
so I want to find the item sold and the
unit cost format so my lookup value is
going to be matte now if you see this
table I don't have the representative's
name matte anywhere in the table now
using an approximate match I want to
find the item and the unit cost so let's
do it
so here under item I'll write my vlooker
formula
so I'll type vlookup I'll hit tab to
complete it
and this time meluco value is going to
be matte so I'll select this cell comma
my table array I'll select
from the representatives column till
the end of
item column because I want to find the
item value format
I'll give a comma
my column index number as per the table
array is going to be 2
comma my range lookup this time I am
going to give is true or one
so I'll write 1
close the bracket hit enter
all right it has written me binder was
the item sold by Matt
now let's try to figure out why vlookup
returned binder as the item
now let's see you were asked to insert
the name matte to the representative
column in alphabetical order so where
would you place it ideally you should
Place between qvel and Morgan
since this column is already sorted
matte should appear before Morgan and
after cubelle so in an approximate match
vlookup will consider the previous
highest value
in this case the previous highest value
before mat is Q Bell and hence vlookup
returned the corresponding item
purchased by kevl which is binder now
similarly
if you wanted to find the unit cost
format
again vlookup will return the unit cost
of ql which is 125. let's just try it
out so I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is matte comma my table
array for this time is going to be from
Representatives column till the unit
cost column I'll consider
I'll give a comma now the column index
number as per the table array is going
to be 4 we'll give another comma and
this time I'll double click true because
I want an approximate match we close the
bracket hit enter you can see it has
written me 125 which is actually
cables unit cost okay we have another
question and this time I want to find
the units sold by Rob now Rob is going
to be my lookup value
if you see the representatives column we
don't have Rob now let's see what
vlookup is going to return as the item
for Rob so I'll write vlookup I'll give
my lookup value as Rob comma my table
array
is going to start from the
representatives column I'll select till
here I'll give a comma my column index
number is 2
we give another comma
I'll double click on true
so close the bracket hit enter you can
see vlookup has written me pen now let's
understand why vlookup returned pen for
Rob now if you are asked to insert the
representatives name Rob
into this column so ideally Rob would
appear somewhere between Morgan and
Sorvino because
since this is sorted in ascending order
Rob is actually greater than Morgan and
is less than Sorvino so as you know
vlookup in an approximate match Returns
the previous highest value which is
Morgan here and the corresponding item
for Morgan is pen and hence we look up
returned pen from Rob all right
now moving to the next sheet
which is another property of vlookup
which tells vlookup always looks to the
right this means that your lookup value
must always be on the left
and the value you are going to find out
should always be to the right of the
table now consider this scenario where
you look up value is on the left in this
case it is the representatives value and
I have taken cervino for an example
and we want to find the order date for
Sorvino now if you consider this table
your lookup value which is sure we know
is actually this column the
representatives column and we are going
to find out the order date so your
representative's name is on the right of
the table and the value we are going to
find out is on the left of the table
now as per the property vlookup only
looks to the right
so if I use the vlooker function for
this example here I'll write vlookup
I'll give my lookup value as sorpino
comma
multiple array I'll consider from the
order date because I want the order date
till
the representatives column I'll give a
comma and this time my column index
number is actually the first column if I
consider my table array as the first
three columns selected
and my range lookup is going to be false
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me an error the reason is
vlookup always looks to the right and
this time the value we were trying to
find out was to the left of the table
now
if you consider
the opposite case suppose you have the
order date and you want to find the
representative's name you can do that
easily because you look up value which
is the order date is on the left and
your representatives column is on the
right so let's just try this I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is going to be
order date so I'll select it from the
table
I'll give a comma my table array will
start from the G column let's say I'll
select the entire table
comma and my column index number will be
3 if you consider these as my table
array
comma my range lookup is zero if I close
this hit enter you can see we have got
Sorvino corresponding to the order date
all right now let's move to the next tab
now this tab says vlookup returns only
the first match so we have a question at
hand the question is
find the units sold by Jardine
if you see this table
we have the representatives name Jardin
twice you see here and if you look down
we have Jardin here as well but the
items sold by Jardin at the first
instance is pencil and at the second
instance it's desk
now as per the property vlookup always
returns the first match now ideally when
we write the vlookup function and look
for the units sold by Jardine you will
see vlookup will return
36 instead of 3. let's just try it out
I'll write the vlooker function
my lookup value is Jardine
comma my table array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of
units column
will give a comma my column index number
based on the table array is three I'll
give another comma Now I want the exact
match so I'll select 0
close the bracket and hit enter
now as you can see it returns me the
first match of Jardine which is 36 so
vlookup did not consider the second
match
now similarly
if you consider this table
we have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here
we have Jones
here for the second time and also we
have zones for the third time
and let's see you want to find the unit
cost for Jones so if I write the vlookup
function
I'll consider my
lookup value as Jones comma my table
array
I'll select from the representatives
column till the end of unit cost column
I'll give a comma based on the table
array my unit cost column is at the
fourth index so I'll write 4 comma the
range lookup is 0.
if I click on this
and hit enter you can see it here
vlookup has returned the first instance
of Jones and it did not consider the
second and the third instance so our
unit cost
for Jones is 1.99 because vlookup only
Returns the first match
okay moving ahead to the next example we
have here is vlookup is case insensitive
if you consider this table
I've added another
Row in green
so if you see here I have a
representative name called Gill which is
in proper case or
popularly known as sentence case here I
have added Gill's name in
capital letters are all in uppercase so
I want to find the total revenue
generated by Gill the total revenue is
basically the total column
let's do it I'll write vlookup
my lookup value is Gill which is
actually in upper case
I'll consider my table array from the
representatives column till the end of
total column or the sales column
based on the selection my column index
number is 5.
comma the range lookup is false so I'll
just double click on false
if I close the bracket hit enter
you can see it here
our vlookup function has returned the
total as
539.73 which is actually
the value for this row so clearly
vlookup did not consider Gill which was
present at the bottom of the table in
upper case
so this shows that vlookup is clearly
case insensitive
all right
now moving to the next example the
vlookup function supports wild cards
which makes it possible to perform a
partial match on a lookup value for
instance you can use vlookup to retrieve
values from a table after typing only
part of a lookup value to use wildcards
with vlookup you must specify the exact
match by giving false or 0 for the last
argument that is range lookup now we
have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with Ki
make now here sales represents the
total column actually
so I want to find out the person whose
name starts with Ki
so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is key well so
using Ki as my lookup value I want to
find the total so let me show you how to
use wildcard characters and find
the value using vlookup
so write my function vlookup
okay now in lookup value I'll give Ki
after that I am going to write Ampersand
followed by
double inverted commas
then I'm going to write a star and close
the inverted comma this means the value
starts with k i am percent actually
represents concatenation and star
represents anything followed by Ki
so this is going to be my lookup value
in total
I'll give a comma
next I'll select my table array starting
from the representatives column till the
end of total column because I want to
find the seals
give another comma
my column index number based on the
table array we have selected is 5
comma the range lookup is 0 because I
want to find an exact match
let's close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here vlookup has returned me
999.5 which is actually Cable's total
now there's another way to do it
instead of selecting the cell in which
we have the lookup value I can directly
write it in the vlookup function
so I'll write the vlookup function
something like this so my lookup value
I'll pass Ki within double inverted
commas because Ki is a character value
So within double inverted commas I'm
writing Ki
followed by Ampersand which is for
concatenation
followed by
a star
within double inverted commas so this is
going to be my lookup values
this in total means anything that
appears after Ki will be considered as
the lookup value
again the table array I'll select as
these rows and columns
comma my column index number would be 5
comma the range lookup is zero if I
close the bracket hit enter you see we
have the same value so this is another
method or another way of using
vlookups
okay now moving ahead let's explore
another feature of vlookup so if the
vlookup function cannot find a match it
returns a has an a error now if you want
you can use the if any function to
replace the hash any error with a
friendly message so suppose
you want to find the region in which an
order was placed on 10th of May 2018.
now if the order date is not found I
want to return a message that is invalid
date
so
if you look at the order date
column we don't have any value for 10th
of May 2015. you can see these values we
don't have any value corresponding to
this date
so
if my vlookup function cannot find this
lookup value I'll return invalid date so
let me show you
how to write this
I'll type my vlookup function
I'll give my order date as 10th of May
2015.
as my lookup value and then
I'll consider my table array starting
from the order date column till the end
of
region column
will give another comma my column index
number would be 2 this time based on the
table array we have selected comma
I want an exact match
so I'll give 0 close the bracket and hit
enter
there you go it has written me an error
now I want to convert this error to a
friendly message saying invalid date so
let me show you how to do it I'll do it
here so to return a valid message
I'll use the if any function
and within if any function I'll give my
vlookup function
so let me type if n a
I'll hit tab
now for the value parameter I'll use my
vlookup function so my lookup value is
going to be the order date
comma my table array I'll select from
the order date column till the end of
region column comma where column index
number is going to be 2
comma my range lookup is 0
I close the bracket give another comma
Now if this expression results in an
error I want to display a message that
is invalid date so I'll put invalid date
within double quotes
since it is
a text message
I close the bracket hit enter you can
see
the result which is invalid date
now moving on to the final section of
the demo
we have two-way lookup
now in the vlookup function the column
index parameter is normally hard coded
as a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column
and this technique allows you to create
a dynamic two-way lookup matching on
both rows and columns
now let me first show you how a match
function works so suppose
I want to find the index where unit cost
column is present
so here I'll use the match function
I'll give my lookup value as the unit
cost column name
comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type as 0 for exact
match
if I close the bracket hit enter it
returns me 4 because
my array was selected from the
representatives column till the unit
cost column and in this array unit cost
is at the fourth index
all right now using this idea let's
solve the following problem I want to
find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan
so let's
write our vlookup formula
write B lookup
my lookup value is J5 which has the
representative's name as Morgan comma
while table array I'll select from
C2
till
F12
I'll give a comma and this time I know
that my column index number is at
4 but I'll be using the match function
to find the same
so I'll write match
my lookup value is
unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till F1
comma my match type is 0
I close this bracket give another comma
and I'll give my range lookup as 0
close the bracket hit enter you can see
for Morgan the unit cost is 19.99 you
can verify from the table for Morgan the
unit cost is 19.99
all right now
we have another question here
I want to find how much sales did
Andrews make in the central region so
here I have
two lookup values one is Central one is
Andrews now looking at these two values
I want to find the total
to solve such problems
let me first create
another table
I'll place the table somewhere here
okay so let me just paste the table here
all right now I'll create another column
where I'll merge the values of region
and representatives so here let me
create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep
all right now this column
I'll use the concatenation operator
so I'll Select East
use Ampersand and then select Jones I'll
hit enter
now the same thing I'll just duplicate
it
for the other rows as well so I have my
new column created Now using this table
I can easily solve the problem
now to find the total I'll write my
vlookup formula
so my lookup value
will be a combination of j11
ampersand
k11
comma multiple array will start from the
region rep which has the values of
region and rep combined
till
the last column
and from this table array my column
index number is 5
and my range lookup is zero if I close
the bracket hit enter you can see
for central region which is this one
and for Andrews representative the total
is 149.25
all right now we are done with our demo
let's have a quick glance at what all we
did in this demo
okay so first of all we saw our data set
which was a sales data set that we used
then we started with our first example
to see how vlooker performs an exact
match we also saw how using the formulas
Tab and lookup and reference you can
write vlookup in
another way so you can use the function
arguments to give your vlookup
parameters next we saw how vlooker
performs an approximate match so we had
mat and raw which were not present in
the representatives column
after that
we saw an important property of vlookup
that is vlookup only looks to the right
followed by
vlookup only Returns the first match
following which we saw
that vlookup is case insensitive so here
we had added a new row where Gill was
present in uppercase but still we look
up
found the total revenue for Gill which
was in sentence case or properties next
we saw how we can use wildcard
characters to use vlookups
and here we saw how to use an if any
function along with vlookup and finally
we saw how to use two vlookups choose
from over 300 in-demand skills and get
access to 1 000 Plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of Microsoft Excel and here
you can see some data on my sheet
that is employee name employee ID and
salary
so here we are going to perform our
horizontal lookup but before that let me
show you that this particular drop down
menu so this particular drop down menu
has all the names of the employees in
this particular table and we have
created this using data validation in
Excel if you want to create the drop
down menus just like this then feel free
to check out our data validation in
Excel tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement each lookup in Excel so here
we have employee name but we want to
find out the employee ID so for that
let's create the hlookup now for that
equals to hlookup
now the first one is the lookup value so
this one is the cell which is the
employee name now after that the table
array we have to select all the table
arrays here
now
the row index number so the employee ID
is in row index number 2 according to
the table so for that provide 2 and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false and close the bracket press enter
and there you go and if you select jet
then you'll find the employee ID of
check and if you select jury you'll find
the employee ID of cherry reflecting
here now similarly let's find out the
salary of all the employees using
hlookup so equals Edge lookup
and lookup value that happens to be the
name of the employee now the table array
and next we have row index number that
is salary happens to be the third row in
the table so three and
exact match
close the bracket and enter so now if
you change the values in this particular
drop down menu you will find the
employee ID and their particular salary
so Jack happens to be carrying the
employee ID as one zero zero one and his
salary is ten thousand so similarly
let's try to find out petos employee ID
and salary
so there you go 1005 and 50 000 as
salary so that's how you use hlookup in
Excel here you can see the first chart
so this particular data is converted
into a table format to avoid confusion
while you're fixing the data so here you
can see the name of the employee
employee ID Department salary and date
of churning and here you can see the
salary column and the bonus percentage
of each and every employee based on
their salaries now coming to the new
data table and here on the tables 2
which is an updated table here you can
find we are going to find out the
department of the employee and the
current Department of employee and the
bonus percentage based on his or her
salary so why are we finding current
Department again
so here you can see that we have an
intern Emily who has joined in the year
2020 but recently she got promoted as a
developer so her department has been
changed from Department in turn to
Department developer in 2021 so that's
what we're gonna find out here in the
current Department using xlookup now
let's start to implement X lookup so for
that
equals to X lookup
and for lookup you can see we need to
find out the lookup value lookup array
return array and all the other two are
not important right now but you can use
them to get some exact matches in the
future we'll also use that in the future
for now let's try to use the first three
parameters that is lookup value lookup
array and written array so the lookup
value is the name of the employee Mary
and lookup array is right here which is
this one
now we are going to select the lookup
array then comma and we're going to look
up the department so this is the
department lookup array
and that's all we need
close the bracket and press enter
okay I think we missed out the lookup
value
so the employee or the lookup value
which we required was missed so I've
added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is Miri and
there you go
press enter and you have the department
here now let's add it to all the rows
and here you have all the rows and all
the data related all the employees now
we will find out the current Department
as you can see here you have Emily as
intern which is the older data but what
if we needed the latest data that is the
developer in the year 2021 right for
that you might want to throw up the X
lookup formula a little bit so let's try
that X lookup
lookup value which is the same and comma
now where you have to look for the array
that is lookup array this one and the
return array which happens to be this
one
and next
you can find the exact match for this
one so that's all right exact match and
here comes the important part where you
have to search last to first by default
X lookup searches for first to last that
is like this in the starting place to
the last place so that's the reason why
we had Emily as intern so now if we give
last to first then it retrieves the
latest data where Emily will be shown as
developer now select that and now you
can close the brackets and press enter
so let's add that to all the rows there
you go now you can see Emily Clark Peter
and James all they have got their
updated job profiles as you can see in
the original data Emily is a developer
now so is Clark who was originally a
tester and he got promoted to
development team in 2021 similarly Peter
became a senior Finance executive in
2021 and James the manager of sales now
let's try to find out the bonus for all
these employees based on their salary so
this one is quite simple
so X lookup
now the lookup value is their existing
salary
comma and the bonus part so the lookup
array is the salary range
then here is another important point so
here you might want to find the exact
match but finding an exact match will
not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why I'm
selecting that so now let's close the
bracket and enter so
so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows I mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is thirty eight thousand
twenty two thousand thirty nine Etc but
here in the ranges we have provided 10
20 30 1450. so what if the value is
between 1320 that's when you want the
less number right that's when you want
the number which is equivalent to 30 or
less than 30 which happens to be 15
percent so that's how it has worked here
that is 0.15 bonus to the actual salary
so slices in Excel are software filters
used along with Excel tables or Excel
pivot tables over a large amount of data
not just filtering out data but slices
also help you with an easy understanding
of the information being extracted and
displayed on the screen now Microsoft
Excel slices are compatible with Windows
and Macintosh operating systems now let
us understand how to implement slicers
in Excel so for that we might want to
get back to the Practical mode that is
starting a Microsoft Excel
now we are on our Excel sheet and as you
can see on my screen there is some data
available on the Excel spreadsheet and
this table is not just any table this
table from Microsoft Excel has been
converted into an actual table as you
know by default Excel considers all the
data which has been inserted into the
spreadsheet as a database and to
implement this slices in Excel we might
want to create or convert the format of
database into a normal table for that
you can select all your data and just
press Ctrl T and that will allow you an
option called convert the data into
table
now since this table is already
converted as a table we can directly
start implementing or inserting slices
into the spreadsheet
now for that select all your data
then go into the insert option
and in the insert ribbon you can see the
filters group and in the filters group
select the option called slicer now you
will be provided with multiple options
since we have the columns employee ID
employee name Zone designation
Department salary employees date of
birth and employees date of Journey so
we can choose any of the options
available according to our columns and
create the slices now let me select the
first one that is Zone next designation
department and let's also select
employee name
now press OK and there you go we have
our slices
now let's try to rearrange these slices
all you can do is just select and drag
them up
and done now let us imagine that we want
to see or take a look at the employees
who are working in the East Zone then we
have all the information displayed on
the screen who are working in the East
Zone they are Jack Tony Banner Fred Etc
and their Department designation etc etc
all on one single screen so this really
helps you while you're presenting your
data in a presentation now for a change
let's try to select the department now
if your client wants to select the data
from only analytics Department then you
might want to select on the analytics
key on the department slicer and there
you go you have an employee called look
hops who works in the East Zone and his
department is analytics and his
resignation is contract based and the
salary he is getting is 65
000.
now similarly
uh you can see that we have only
selected analytics and your client also
wants data from it support now you can
see that analytics is gone but what if
we want both analytics and ID support
then you have an option called selected
multiple then you can select analytics
and ID support and if you want HR you
can also do that and in this Zone if you
want West along with East then you can
do the same east and west and you have
all the employee details and in the
designation let's try to Select Senior
trainee
okay select multiple senior trainee and
manager so that's how you do it
so that's how it's done and that's how
you implement slicers in Excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on slicers in Excel so on my
screen you can see an example Excel
budget template theme
so on my screen you can see a column
where you have the debit amount so in
the I column we have all the limit
amount what we are spending for a month
and on the right column will be the
balance amount or the running balance of
that for example you can see that there
is a row number five where the debit
amount is 8000 for our genes Levi's and
it is done through UPR payment now if I
change this value of 8000 to 4000
something
and then you can see that the running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if I change this
value from 8 000 to 4000 then all the
running balances will change let's do
that so for that let's press enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running violence are
also changed until the last date which
is the March 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in January and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance after one lakh has been debated
into the account in the month of
February as February income now the
current available balance is 1 lakh
13200 and the total expense in February
is 1 lakh 4500 right
online doing all this looks so much
interesting right now let's do this
practically
so for that I have already created a new
sheet and I have included all the data
that we have used previously the income
of that particular month and all the
expenses of that particular month
now without further Ado let's begin to
implement the Excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in Excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database type table into the
pure table type table so for that select
quality data and press Ctrl T and then
you have an option to convert this data
into a table and remember to check this
particular checkbox and tell your Excel
that your table has headers so we do
have headers here so now press OK and
your table will be converted into a
natural table
now let's type in the formulas
so now let's select the cell J2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to add the sum of J2 plus H3
so which is this particular cell and
removing I3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance let's press
enter and there you go
so it means that you received 1 lakh
rupees in the month of January and out
of that one lakh you spend 15 000 rupees
for something maybe your educational
load or something and then the remaining
running balance out of 1 lakh Rupees is
85 000 rupees now let's copy the same
formula to all these cells
and there you go now the running balance
has been calculated for all the cells
here now remember the monthly income
available balance and effort for
generating final buttons now let's try
to calculate that for all the three
months so here we have three months that
is January February and March now let's
do a simple calculation to find out the
available balance of that one and the
total debit made by that person in that
particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done right
there you go so the total expense of the
month January is 93 800 rupees now let's
calculate the total doubt of February
month same formula that is
calculating the sum of
all the expenses made in the month of
February
they
now let's also calculate the sum of all
the expenses in the month of March
done so we have the final values of all
the total expenses made in those
particular months
now let's calculate the final balance
now I think I forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available values
that is the available balance after 1
lakh Rupees is created into our account
and along with the savings that you have
from your previous month right so that
we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the uh income cell with the
balance cell that's all
so there you go now after crediting one
lakh rupees and adding up the uh balance
of that particular month that is we have
13 200 remaining from the month of
January and the month of February we
have income of one lakh so the total
amount is 11 300 and yeah I don't know
it is one lakh 13 200 yeah now we have
the final balance that is the difference
between the available balance and the
debit made in that particular month so
in the month of February we had a total
balance of one lakh 13 200 and the total
debit of one lakh four thousand five
hundred so the final remaining balance
is eight thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of March and the
final balance we have is thirty seven
thousand three hundred so that's how you
implement budget template in Excel all
simple formulas and you have all the
numbers at your filling tips so first
let's understand what exactly is Mis
report in Excel
so Mis stands for management information
system Mis reports provide data on
different categories for accurate
decision making so Mis in Excel is a
procedure to create interactive report
using Microsoft Excel so Mis reports
help management to access the
performance of organization and allow
faster decision making so if you know to
create the Mis reports using various
business intelligence tools such as
Excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a well established
company now let us try to learn how to
create Mis report using Excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel IF getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
so here you can you can see that I've
got some sales data of various car
manufacturing companies and I've also
got some slices so using these slices I
can get the real-time information from
the dashboard
so I'll select an ear from the first
slicer and I'll go into the second
slicer and I'll select a company now
I'll select BMW and SUV type so we have
the data of all the SUV types cars
manufactured by BMW car manufacturing
company in the year 2018. now let's
start and create something similar to
this one
so how did I create this mis report
let's go through this in a step-by-step
way
so on my screen you can see that we have
created a completely new Excel workbook
and we have some sample data with five
rows and 20 columns
so this particular data is based on the
manufacturer and the car manufacturing
company and the type of the car
manufactured and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
Now to create a minus reports we need to
play around pivot tables so we also have
tutorials on pivot tables and you can go
through that in our simply learn YouTube
channel and also we will try to link
those in the description box below
now let's select the entire data and go
into the insert ribbon and there you can
see the first option that is pivot table
so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialog box where it will ask you for the
range of cells you need to select and
the next one is to
create the pivot table in the same sheet
or a new sheet so we'll take a new sheet
here now select OK and there you go you
have the pivot table here so first you
have an empty pivot table and on the
right side you can see we have pivot
table Fields now you can either drag
these options into the rows and columns
or you can also click it so now let's
drag and drop these first we will select
here
and card
followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to columns
so there you go we have our pivot table
now
let's select all the data in the pivot
table
and again let's get back to the insert
option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that and you will
have various favorite chart options here
now you can select any one which you can
prefer or which you like or whichever
you think can represent your data in a
best way possible so now let's go with
column chart first
let's select OK and we have our column
chart over here
now this happens to be our first chart
now let's create a few more chats
so to create few more charts we'll go
back to the same original data select
again insert and pivot table
now again a new worksheet
so here we have another empty pivot
table in the similar event let's drag
the same data into rows and columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot chart
go to insert option
favorite chat and now let's try to
select pie chart
select ok
and we have our pie chart over here
now let's try to create one more
same procedure select table select pivot
table then create new worksheet for the
new pivot table and now drag and drop
the data
now let's go to insert again
let's select all the data go to insert
option and pivot chat now let's try to
select the bar chart
select OK and there we have our bar
chart
now
remember the first chart we created that
is in sheet 2 this one so we will try to
move all the charts to this particular
table or this particular worksheet
so let's get back to the sheet number
three right click and you can see an
option called pivot chart analyze so
from here you can move the chart select
the option of moving the chart and don't
select the first one select the object
in option and select the sheet number to
which you want to move this chart for
now we want to move this chart to sheet
number two select that press ok now we
have the chart moved to the sheet number
two
and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four and let's move this
particular chart to sheet number two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number two
now you can insert the slices
so we have selected the third sheet or
third chart and inside the pivot chart
analyze option we have an option of
inserting the slicer now we will insert
the slices for year
car
and
type
now select OK and you will have all the
three slices onto your sheet
now let's rearrange them
so I'm just organizing them in a
neat way
there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the charts
so that they look a little more better
now if you see
if I make some changes only one chart
will be interacting for this
right so if I select Ferrari and year
2020 and option as Sports you can see
only one chart is interacting to these
particular slices why because all these
slices are connected to just one chart
here so you need to make sure that all
the slices are connected to all the
three charts what we created so let's
erase all the filters and select one
slicer at a time right click and you
will see an option of report connections
select that and you see that the
connections are only connected to the
pivot table 3. so select the remaining
pivot tables as well select OK and in
the same way select the second slicer
select the report connection option
connect pivot table 1 and 2 and select
copy and in the same way the third one
so now all the slices are connected to
all the pivot charts now if you make
some changes here they will respond
automatically in the same way
now let's select the code company the
year 2019 and hashback option and you
have all the cars which were made in the
year 2019 from Ford Company in the
segment of hatchback
so this was the sample data set that we
worked on now you can also work on some
complex data sets such as this Superstar
data set
now one thing you need to make sure that
when you're working with Excel Mis they
need to make sure that all the macros
are disabled on your data set and you
convert the entire data into the regular
table format of excel right now Excel is
considering this particular data as a
database so for that you need to select
all the data press Ctrl T and then
convert the entire data in the form of
tabular data and also don't forget to
click this icon which reads my table has
headers so the first row is the headers
now let's select OK and your entire data
will be converted into tabular form now
let's reset this to the normal
okay type which has the clear color not
all the fancy colors now the entire data
is converted from the dbms to the tablet
form and now he can start implementing
the Mis reports and pivot tables so
that's how you work on Mis report in
Excel so what is Excel macro you do
certain daily tasks and daily reports or
monthly reports that you generate and
you use data from your Excel and you
scrub data and you basically have the
same things performed or done on the
Excel sheets every time and every day or
monthly or bi-weekly or any number of
times that you open your Excel you
remove certain columns you add certain
things and you change certain values and
these are the things that you do and N
number of times on an Excel and this can
all be done by simple automated way
which is macros so what it does is it is
a set of tasks that you can execute as
many number of times as you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it in extract certain data and
remove certain columns that you do every
time that you open that sheet for
instance you remove that column I which
has the absolute values of your of your
accounts or the sheets that you have and
you remove that column and you edit some
names you add such things every time
that you open that report and then you
format it in a proper way and send it to
your management so this can all be done
in a simple running script called macros
so what you do is you record those
Mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically a
set of codes or task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
n number of times so it makes your life
easy now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your Excel it's a
simple tab that you need to add in the
ribbon section which I'll be showing you
across and this will enable the macros
on your Excel so you go to files
good options
and then you need to customize your
Ribbon click customize ribbon and then
there is a developer tab which you see
here it should be activated so you just
need to select that
click on the tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it all
on your Excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon customize ribbon and
you can add or remove your Macros from
here so this is two ways that you need
to that you can activate uh your Macros
so how you record a macro is the next
thing
so here I have a work orders sheet that
I receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do and you know this report has so
many things that are obsolete which you
do not need which has to be put across
to your management or your for your use
so how you record or start a macro you
go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro as soon as you click
on this record macro button it will
start recording your keystrokes on the
mouse mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do so
this is the sheet that I have and we'll
try to run a macros on this and see what
it does
so here I have and
this actually works this way uh I need
to go to the developer tab and start
recording a macro so when I click record
macro it starts uh recording my mouse
clicks and keystrokes so in this sheet I
have to you know remove some columns and
the columns that are Obsolete and the
data that looks weird here should be
removed and all what I need is the work
order number the district and the
tactician name and the kind of service
that we provide and the requested
workday
the cost
and the payment so this is what I want
and I do it every day when I receive the
sheet and I have to make these changes
and send it across to the accounts team
so what I do is I simply automate this
by running a macro
so I go to
let's see how it records the macro
if I click record macro I save it as
work
order
accounts
and I'll add a little description like
work order
for
accounts keep
costs
click ok
and
see what I do is basically I add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper and then I
do not want this column I delete it I do
not want the number of technicians that
are there I do not want all these and I
also want the laborers the account and
what kind of payment this is very
crucial for the accounts team I do not
want any of these obsolete data
so I just delete this okay and then I
just want to have some cosmetic changes
done so
I make sure this doesn't have any border
and that's it this is the task that I
prefer
every day I still don't need it
and I go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now I have the macro
save and when I have it I have you know
automated these all these steps in one
simple click and how I execute it in
another sheet so I will show it across
to you
the next thing so here I have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and sent it across so I simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab and go to the macro and I
have this macro C which we ran the just
now and I simple with a single click I
will be able to do these daily tasks and
execute in a Flash so I just click run
and it does the rest for me I have my
report ready and is in a proper format
that is required and it can be sent
across so here as we see it is done in a
single click by running a simple macro
continuing our uh to work on macro we
can simply do this by a single click of
a button by adding a button so what you
have to do is go to the developer tab
and in the control section you will see
the insert
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see a form controls and you can
say select a button and here I select a
button and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when I just
assign that macro to this button I can
edit the text by
work order accounts just to make it
simple okay
and now if you see if I just click this
button it will run the macro
and format RC
So This Is How We Run The macros in
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros and instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros or you can record
and you can edit your macro so when I
click view macros it will show you what
are the macros that I have and that I
can run and you can simply run it
alternatively and you can record a macro
as well instead of from the developer
tab if you just click on record macro it
will do the same function that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have to use a
simple application in Excel which is the
BBA Visual Basic application to edit
your macro you go to the developer tab
and then click on Visual Basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on and you
can edit the
macro here
so as we see if you go back to the Excel
we see that our sheet we have been
working on the sheet and it has the
column still K and the actual sheet is
this so if I go to the Visual Basic
editor
and I'll make sure you know I remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m and I just delete that
and I click run
I go back to my sheet and you see these
changes are not there
okay
this is your old macro and this is our
new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority of my orders so
these are the things that we can edit
with the VBA
so here we are what is VBA Visual Basic
application it is basically a Visual
Basic application language that is used
for macros in Excel
so what it basically does Visual Basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate tasks by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our TDS daily task by running a simple
macro now to help us you know write
these macros and help us get the best
use of our abilities to
is our work and automate our task we use
VBA
so why we be there are many advantages
of using VBA and why we prefer VBA in
macros for excel
so basically it is a very simple
language it saves time in performing
tedious tasks you have number of tasks
that you do every day as we have seen in
the previous section how we we can
simplify your daily task by just running
a simple macro and this VBA helps us in
performing those tasks in a very simple
manner another thing is it supports
english-like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic English language
statements and this can help us or it is
very easy to program our code or edit
these commands you can select a range
you can it is like a if an else
statement and things like that we will
look into those in details in the next
sections now one more thing is it
improves the functionality of excel by
allowing you to make Excel behave the
way you want there are multiple
functions that you perform in Excel like
selecting a number of rows or columns or
selecting a set of cells in particular
you do it in a daily basis so these
things can easily be performed and
easily be edited and executed by using
VBA we will look into those in detail
now what is the BBA editor interface
this is particularly uh
an interface which you will have look in
detail
where where you can edit your commands
or your codes for your Excel now how
this is achieved we will see it here now
these are the this is basically the VBA
editor interface where you can see the
uh this is the toolbar section where it
shows all the options wherein undo or
save or file they will see those details
in the next section this is basically
the toolbar section of the VBA editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important menu
bar option and when you can insert
different modules and buttons and all
we'll look into those in details run is
one more important thing all these
things fall under menu bar the next
thing is the VBA code window VBA code
window as it says is the code window
where your actual code resides wherein
you can go into it and edit the code or
write the codes and select the different
range of functions that you can perform
and this is basically the VBA code
window where you edit your or write your
codes
the next thing is the project Explorer
project Explorer is simply like a
Windows Explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your VBA
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the of the Excel sheets
or the worksheets that you're working on
or the modules that you have saved and
so on basically it is an Explorer for
your PBA like a Windows Explorer which
is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties Windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on for instance here we are
working on the sheet2 and it shows the
properties what are the kind of uh
worksheet that we have the page break
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that the next thing is the immediate
window and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool or
a window wherein you can run and execute
simple lines of course individual Excel
code that you can run it will allow you
to test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when
you're writing and debugging course uh
the output if the lines that you execute
can be seen here in the immediate window
whereas watch Window watch window is
similar to it but it displays the value
of the watch expression in its currently
current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the VBA code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the U the advantages of
having a watch window in your VBA
interface
so these are the things that we learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
Visual Basic for application for macros
and I'm going to show you how to you
know run some codes and run some macros
and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the VBA for macros so there are
two ways to open the Visual Basic
application and the first thing is you
can run alt f11 click on the sheet and
then just press and it will open the
um Visual Basic for application window
or alternatively you can just go and
click on the Visual Basic and it will
open the sheet for you I mean the code
window for you and as we have discussed
before these are the windows that we see
this is the code window and this is the
project Explorer
and this is the immediate window I will
you can run some testing course
immediately it will show you the code so
here we see the project Explorer window
where we see the modules and all for our
Visual Basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see how
the code develops okay so I just go here
and click record macro
and I save it as a format
and
columns
[Music]
this QuickBook and I just save it
and it has started recording so now what
I'll do is as make it simple and I just
delete some columns here
okay I do not need this
I delete this is there a wait I want
this I want the mode of payment parts
cost labor hours I do not want this
number of technicians forget it
okay
and I go further left and see what all
do I need I need I don't need this
I delete all these and
I just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then I want to change the format I
mean the hot
so I select this
[Music]
and I change it to timestrone
okay
I'm going to go back to my developer tab
click stop recording it is saved
okay
now go back to my code
and see the
macro here
so we see the macro here and we can see
uh in detail what it looks like so we
see the code what it's doing and what
the macro run has generated the codebook
so we see we have basically the name of
the macro is format columns and what it
is doing we're just selecting The
Columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee selected is the E
column that we have selected and then
again so on and the next thing is the
font selection that is mentioned we are
changing it to Times New Roman size is
11 so it is basically
a basic VBA code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with m sub so this
is the code or a format of the VBA code
that it looks like and we'll try to do
some basic functions with the
and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation I have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and I'll try to explain some
basic
functions and the commands and the
quotes that we use to accomplish the
tasks that we with PBA
so as we see this is the blank sheet and
I have selected a new module for it
so here I start the code and as it says
it starts with sub and I am specifying
the
module name as number so I'll just try
to make it quite simple and
you know so we as as soon as we enter
the sub it sends with the ends up and so
this is the start of the code and this
is the end of the code and whatever is
there should be here and this is the
name of the how do the macro now uh I'll
explain it further about the game
statement why is it used and what is it
used for so dim is basically a keyword
which is the a short form of Dimension
and it is used to declare a variables in
the VBA so here I am trying to specify
uh
a variable called X and how I'm going to
do it I will as it have it as a number
or an integer or anything so here in
this example I'll put it as an integer
or a number okay and as I put as it
populates the prompt so I select integer
and for example I select the number to
be
500 okay and here I'm trying to assign a
variable integer a cell a value of 500
with a limb keyword
so where exactly I want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay range I am selecting it should be
under course where I'm going to put the
value of x as and I close the bracket
and what should be the value
we will value should be X so now as I
click runs up
or you can do it with the by running the
alt or F5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the Excel sheet
it executes the value of the cell B5 to
be 500 so this is one simple function
that you can do with the dimension
keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain or example some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now I'm going to show you what dim can
be execute I mean used as to set
variables then can be used as
double
is basically a longer form of single
variable it usually takes more space but
uses needs more larger numbers okay and
then you can set
double and I just uh Chrome specified
and we can view State it's basically
stores the date values okay and then
again string so what string does if you
use string it stores the text it can
contain numbers it will have some text
as calculations or anything can be
performed so these are the basic thing
that I will cover and
you can also use different uh values for
it so I will discuss this in the next
example
okay
so in the next example I'll try to
use a string value for it and
value
[Music]
this is my name so as soon as I hit
enter it ends with the answer prompt and
now I can get my code so I put it as
name book it as
okay
okay now
I'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value of a
country to one of the cells so let's see
how it goes and I select country and in
country I select the Mac
[Music]
okay now what is the value or the cell
that basically takes the or we will put
the name of the country as so I have to
specify a range and as soon as I hit it
goes and I have to specify the
the cell here so here I put it as G
and four okay
so I close it
and I put a value what value I am going
to assign it is a country
[Music]
try to run this code right
and see G4 the name populace as a
country here so this is a dim keyword
being used as a string in our VBA code
so
we can also use
VBA to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be executed
using a
code here which I am going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
I'm going to name it as double value and
again the green keyword I'm going to use
the
keyword as double
y double is used is basically it gives a
longer it can be used for a longer form
of single variable ticks it usually
takes more space and larger numbers and
we'll try to assign it okay now I'm
going to pop up a message in the which
says value of a is so and so so I'm
going to give value of a as
250 okay and how I it pops up a message
okay so there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value I mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and you you can enter
the text and you can enter a very so
here I'm going to Bar write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is signed so
the value of a is
I'm going to put it in in percent code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay
now that's it and let's try to run this
and you will see a message popping
message box popping up
okay so the value of e is the message
box
pops up saying the value of a is 250. so
in the next example I am going to write
a code wherein you know you can give a
value or a string you can assign it to a
selected cell and this basically used
when you have some you know when you
have a task of you know giving a value
to a particular cell or you have to
assign a text or say something about a
report okay so this let's see how it
goes and we use the
I will say it as
fun with some procedures
name
again name
so here I am giving to I am going to
give a user input and it will be as a
string okay you can give anywhere I mean
any string or any statement what my user
input will be I will Define it here
[Music]
of course
this is the
the report
let's make it simple
okay
and where I'm going to put it is
in the active cell or the cell that I
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
I have defined user input as this is a
report for VBA so this cell turns into
you this is a report for VBA
I run this and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and you know it makes life quite simple
when you use VBA for this as we have
seen before we have used message box now
I'm going to use the same message box
to display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes I'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays here name
and I'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to run it
see here
so it pops a message saying that my name
is it fun so this is a message box that
you can display and I can do anything
with this
[Music]
oh
okay I run it again and it pops this
message so these are the things that you
can use to customize or you know when
you open an Excel sheet or try to run a
Workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or you know Define a
report or kind of data in it and this
can be used using run using the message
box
and now I have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell Excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so here it is
put it as sub
and
will again populate a message box
which
will set it to
the
we entered
value
is
and it should tell me
which or I specify which cell it is that
we are going to find the value of okay
so I give a range
[Music]
I have to give it
completed
[Music]
which tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
E1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use Excel to
determine our show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
I can change it to
a
4.
as well and try to run it and it will
give me the number so this is simple way
of you know populating a message box
which will tell us the
value of a
let me show you one more simple example
where in a message box pops up or a
welcome message that can be power set
when you open the Excel or worksheet so
so let's uh
name it as Auto
open
and then again message box I wanted to
populate and
what does it say
codes will come
to power
or sheet
um Workshop
it's very simple you just run it and
see it pops up a message saying it
welcome to a workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to a simple
welcome message on Excel
next I'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
good
so we name it as add value
now I specify the range I mean where I
am going to specify a cell
where the value will be given to the
[Music]
I'm going to
give it as V5
okay to put it as curves close the
parenthesis
what is the value that I'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0. okay so now with this code I mean
I'm going to assign a value of 250 to
the cell cell B5 let's see
run it see
again I do it to be 10.
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now I can run the same thing and give a
range of cells I mean
let me make it very simple here
B
I give it as B1
through b
as
four five zero so let's see what it does
see here I am going I am specifying the
range to be B1 through B5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay in the
and then I can give another set of range
here
like let me specify it
means to be
[Music]
c one
I have to give it a course
give me an error
will call in put C4
and I separate it with a comma and I can
specify another range so the next one
will be D1 to D4
and then I close the codes close the
parenthesis
I ordered the value that I give is
let's say
two three zero
and I try to run it
so it gives the value of c 1 through C4
and D1 through D4 as 230 as we specified
in the
code
so this is one of one more example
bearing you can assign values to the
uh so range of cells or cells and with
the VBA
one more thing I can you know assign a
value to a particular cell by specifying
these cells it's a very simple just
specify the cells like
oh six
[Music]
seven
I assign a value to it value equals
10. see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
Root 6
and column set
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario wherein you need to select
a
range of cells in a sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using VBA so I will show you
how
this is our
let's say selector
range
okay
and I am going to set a dim variable as
an example okay let's say it has example
and um what I'm doing is I'm specific
range because I need to select a range
of itself okay now I'm going to set the
variable as
set example where I am going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected so let's say a 1 t
5.
okay this will be the selection
and what I'm going to
set the value okay I am going to set a
value
example
I'm going to give it a value of
256 so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here I'm selecting a set of
cells a range of cells and I'm going to
assign a value with this function so
this makes it quite simple and this will
be used in a regular daily task wherein
you know there is there will be a
scenario where you have to select a set
of cells and give a give a value to it
so you can do it with the click of a
button with a DPA
now I can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so there is
I'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value I'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then it's it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or sales with these
probes
now what if I want to do a selection of
the same rows and columns in the next
sheet and I can do this with the
set up another set of commands so I will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing and we specify the worksheets
okay the worksheets I want it in sheet 2
okay so I just put it as sheet and I
activate it basically
activating it and now I am going to
specify the worksheet
2 and what is the range that I'm going
to select the same thing okay
the range will be
will be
A1
to
D Phi
okay
what I'm going to do I am going to
select it
okay and see what happens here
okay okay
so here I am selecting the worksheet
tool as I'm activating it and I'm going
to assign range and I'm going to select
it so I can just copy the same or select
the same set of cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be as I said
there will be a you know by requirement
where you need to copy some cell
contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a copy and paste I'm
just making it simple by giving
something that we can understand and
relate
paste
okay
so what I'm going to do is I am going to
select this range and I'm going to copy
it and paste it somewhere here okay so
let me just remove this
and actually first we have to specify
the range where you want to copy the
cells okay so let's say it is again A1
it should be in codes D5
[Music]
of course
okay I am going to select it okay
then what I'm going to do is once you
select this the selection that you have
should what should be the function and I
am going to specify the selection and
the function should be copying it
okay so I just said that and where I'm
going to paste it so I have to now
specify the range where I have to paste
this selection and you can just mention
the
column here let's say G
uh
10.
okay
close it
I'm going to select it and then where
I'm going to paste it I can do it in
this sheet okay active sheet
and paste it so we are selecting a range
of cells
selection and that selection what we are
doing is we will copy it and now we are
going to specify the range where you are
going to
select it and then paste it
quite simple let's
okay see
and
just change it so it is visible on this
G5
important
okay
so this makes quite easy and you can run
it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to get the count of the
number of cells like you have to have a
selection and you need to count the
number of cells so this can also be done
and it's quite easy
I am going to show it to you
let's say the survey account
it says
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is the output and why you're using
it and I'm going to set a variable let's
say I'm going to set an example for this
and what we're going to do is we are
going to specify arrange first okay we
will specify the range of
the cells that we are going to that we
need to count basically so I'm going to
set a variable as array and then
what we are going to do is
specify the range here
you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the where you
need the count of the number of cells so
even
85 oops
this is n now how you want the output
you want it you want a message box to
pop up
so you will set up
and
what should it give it will give you the
count of the variable that is the
variable is here is examples Okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this area
okay
let's see it says
okay here typing enlisted so I just
specify the number here and let's see so
it gives you the number of
count and this is 20 okay
now let's see I'm going to six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and wherein you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well I can further tweak this and to
determine the uh the county number of
rows or columns so it's again very
simple I just need to do some changes
here I have to set the
column count
so if I want to
calculate the number of columns
just
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message the number of columns
yet see it gives there are five columns
okay one two one two three four five
okay so it gives us the number of
columns here if I change it to should
give me
four four
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
foreign
okay
should give me a number
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of cells number of
columns number of rows
with this
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the most widely used statement and
one whoever is in programming I'm very
much familiar with this function so what
it does is we specify a condition if a
condition is met then the out should
output should be such and such we can
specify the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there and if
it is
if it is achieved then you will have to
specify the output as well so this can
be achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh English
language so it's not very complicated
and I'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition and if
that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result port
so this is one thing and then you can
specify the s or else condition where
you know you specify the condition 2
then the result should be
this
so here you are going to
specify two conditions or multiple
conditions where you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or Max
and you have to select the result you
can do this manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
I have it here
okay
let's
I specify as
if
statement
okay now I have to specify the variables
now I have two available I have a score
and I have a result and the score is an
integer the number and the result is a
string pass of a so I specify this okay
dim
score
I specified as integer okay
and then there's another variable that I
have to set result
as string
okay
now what the score will be the score I
have to specify the range
score I am giving it as a range admin at
the
a 109
cell A1
okay I specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
should be alert
and then I'm specifying a condition here
if
core value the variable
is greater than or equal so as I said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
English language functions available
then
the result result is another variable
that I have said result what it should
be it should be
and codes
okay so if this condition is met then
the result will be this okay and now
where I want to specify my result I
should give a range for that as well
as well so I give it in the next column
or anyone
this is the basic example
value should be the result
okay let's see how it runs
see
this verse
change to 40
.
it doesn't give me anything because I
have specified only one condition here
okay
kind of 75 let's see how it comes
see so they say it's very basic
condition that you are specifying you
are specifying two variables the score
and the result and then you are giving a
value for it and you are specifically
condition if the score is greater than
then the result should be passed
now in the next section uh we will
simply tweak this and use an if then
else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition and see so here again
we'll use two variables that is the
score as integer and the result as a
string and let's uh stick to the same
values
and now
um I'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before and then
I'm going to specify another condition
here else
the result should be
okay
and now I have to put it as a and if
statement I have to specify the answer
and the result will be again in the
value I mean the range will be leaving
so let's see if it is more than 60 then
it is passed otherwise it is fail
I think this path let's see
40 and
run it again
it's okay so we are specifying two
variables again we are giving at a range
and we are specifying one condition if
this condition is met the result is
passed otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
the next statement that we use or we are
going to discuss is the
Loop statement that is the for Loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations and uh tasks that
you need to execute and you need to do
it several number of times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next is taken up so
and then the next and so on so these
Loop statements allow us to execute a
statement or a group of statements
multiple number of times many number of
times and this happens only when the
first task or the first task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we will discuss a
simple example of the for Loop statement
so let's see how it
works and I'm going to set up a
Loop statement okay again the I'm going
to make it as Loop one so here it is I
have to specify the
variable that is dim
and I'm going to specify X as an integer
okay I'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it
executes okay for x equals to 1 2
94 okay let's see and I'm going to
specify the range
as so what I'm going to do is basically
I'm going to fill the column A from 1 to
24 with some value not from 1 to 24 with
the values of 1 through 24 okay
so I'm setting up a range
and How It Ends is it gives me a value
now index use this and goes to the next
one I'll explain you have it so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up an
integer a variable X as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here for 1 it executes the first
thing is it it takes X as 1 and it fills
in A1
and then the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to A2 and fills the value as
2 so just let's try to execute this and
you will see the
row column A filled with 1 through 24.
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as X
and the number of values is going to be
24. okay so this is one basic example of
a purloop statement
now let's do some more addition to this
uh
example by you know executing another
setup for Loop and giving the output and
we'll code the output to be the color
code advance in the column B so how we
do it it's a basic simple example that
I'm going to take and again what I'm
going to do is I will have this values
here and I am going to calculate the
V column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see in
what I'm going to do is I'm only going
to change the B
and what action is going here we put a
value now we are going to select it and
with this selection
what I'm going to do is if you select it
and it should color the interior with
what
the color index okay
and the value of x
and then I'm going to specify the
pattern what uh pattern it will take for
the box to be colored and I'm going to
put it as a solid
you can fill this whole thing with the
solid
and then I just execute it see
it takes this
color B
and it's coded like this
so these are the simple things that you
can set up with the
codes and for Loop statements so there
are numerous examples and exercises that
we can perform tasks we can perform with
the BBA
and this can be found in detail
and then exclusive Advanced courses now
what is regression so when you talk
about statistical modeling regression
analysis is used to estimate the
relationship between two or more
variables and basically we would want to
look at two or more variables and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response or the
Target right so for example if we look
at our data here we have temperature we
have price of ice cream and then we have
units sold and we can go ahead and make
predictions so for example when you look
at regression here you see something
like this which is regression statistics
you have Anova you have different plots
which we have here which is X variable X
variable two and then you have normal
probability plot now we have already
seen how you can have your add-in that
is data data analysis which helps you in
doing different kind of data analysis
here right now how do we do this so we
have our variables here which is
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and when we talk about regression
we need to understand which one of these
are independent variables which one of
these are dependent variables right so
when you talk about your X that's your
independent variable or we can say
predictor or explanatory so when you
talk about your independent variables or
as we say predictors or explanatory
variables these are the factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or Target
that's the main factor you are trying to
understand or predict so we can plot a
scatter plot to see relationship between
variables if they are linearly related
are they positively related negatively
related and so on we can also get values
such as R square which is coefficient of
determination regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so here is one of the links of
one of my edit other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
Spark
now here let's see how we do this in
Excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold and then get
these plots so what we can do is for
example I can get rid of this and might
be I can just say
no borders and when it comes to these
plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal using your data analysis
add-in tool so we have been given
variables here now as I said when we
talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have multiple variables right so
you might have heard of univariate
analysis by variate analysis and so on
well here we are focusing more on using
Excel
to do our regression analysis so I'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as Basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis what does it do it helps you
understand how the dependent variable
changes when one or more independent
variables vary and it basically allows
us to mathematically determine which of
those variables really has an impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so mainly the
goal of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line if there are residuals
that is points which do not fall on the
regression line and in terms of
statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression models which basically
gives you the relationship between
dependent variable and one independent
variable using a linear function and if
you use two or more variables that is
explanatory variables to predict the
dependent variable we are actually
dealing with multiple linear regression
so if the dependent variable is modeled
as a non-linear function because the
data relationships do not follow a
straight line we have to use non-linear
regression
now what we will do is we'll see how we
can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this might
be based on temperature price of ice
cream we would want to find out how many
units were sold now what we can do is we
can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
Excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert you can then choose the
kind of plots which you want and here
you have insert scatter plot so we can
choose this and you can choose the first
option so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want X values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
That's your dependent variable or your
response or Target so that is in our
case units sold and X values are 1
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here I can click on this
series X values and then I can select
this
now in y values what I can do is I can
select these and then I can just say
Okay so that shows me that it would be
giving me a regression scatter plot now
let's say okay and we have some points
plotted here now if you would want to
see the impact of one individual
variable such as temperature or price of
ice cream you could as well do that now
what you can also do is you can add more
meaning to this by giving in a title or
you can also go into Quick layout and
you have various options here so you see
it gives you what is the access title
what is the series and I would prefer to
use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your R square and that gives you
your Y and X that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change the chart title to something else
say scatter plot of dependent
uh West independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning and we can get
rid of this one so we have series and we
can say what are these points if you
would want to add in Legend if you would
want to do that or I can just get rid of
this and I will keep these values here
which we will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always compare these values so here I
have created a simple scatter plot
and then I can look at dependent West
independent variables
or I could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can hear
say for example just say Y and might be
here I will say x and we can rename that
later now how do we perform data
analysis or get into regression
right now what we would want to do is
we would want to get or we would want to
do the regression analysis to
demonstrate the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
normally when you talk about your linear
regression equation you might have known
about it so it is basically why when you
say y
equals you can say BX plus a plus c
and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression where X is your independent
variable Y is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected mean value of y when
all X variables are equal to 0 so
basically on a regression graph that's
the point where line crosses the y axis
and that's your intercept
when you talk about B that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as X changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your sorry
that's basically your random error term
right which is basically the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise right now what we can
do is we can also reduce this
equation to Y is B X plus a and that's
the equation of a line we can look into
this and the linear equation can be
understood mathematically in this way
now how do we do it in Excel so what we
can simply do is
here let me
yeah
so we need to get into data and then
here we have our data analysis add in
you can click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as I
said you will have to select the
dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your X and Y so y being your target
that's basically your unit sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to X either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so I
will select temperature price of ice
cream and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels right now
we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that so you can say
whether you want it in a new worksheet
or you can just say output range and I
will probably just click here and select
one of the cell here now we can also
choose the other options which we would
want to see as a part of this regression
analysis so basically we have selected
input y range which is your dependent
variable you have selected X range which
is your independent variable and if we
are building a multi regression model
then we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both now we can choose the labels
which we have done we can choose your
output range which is basically on this
sheet and then we can select the
residuals so that basically gives you
your residuals now we can also get your
line fit plots which you were seeing
earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and let's say okay and that basically
gives you your regression analysis
output so we
basically have your summary output we
also have Anova we have our serial
output that's from the previous one and
basically we can get rid of this that's
not required
I can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these so we have
our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this and then what we can do is since we
had some existing data it has
overwritten so let me get rid of this
and I'll repeat this step again
and let's say no water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis so we go get into
Data we get into Data analysis we choose
regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c x range is multiple
variables we have gone for labels output
range which we would want to select a
particular cell so let me select this I
am going for a serials line fit plots a
normal probability plots and say okay
so now we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature here the variable is price
of ice cream right so that's your one
variable and second variable and then
you also have your normal probability
plot now to interpret this or to
understand what we have here where we
look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what Excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
Excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at multiple r value here and we
can
let's also fine tune this one
yeah we have our values here and if you
see we have our R square now we can then
basically look at our multiple R so what
is your multiple R that's your
correlation coefficient which basically
measures the strength of linear
relationship between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient it can be any value between
minus 1 and 1 and its absolute value
indicates the relationship strength
so the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all now when you're looking at R
square that is the coefficient of
determination which is used as an
indicator of the goodness of the fit so
it basically shows how many points fall
on the regression line so your R square
value is basically calculated from the
total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about looking at the
value of your R square so it is
basically we can be seeing that this is
0.450788 that's the value which I am
talking about so it basically means 45
percent of our values fit the regression
analysis model so in other words 45
percent of dependent variables that is
your y values are explained by the
independent variables that is your X
values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit and here we have considered multiple
variables now when you talk about your
adjusted R square it is the R square
adjustment for the number of independent
variables in the model so you would want
to use this value instead of R square
for multiple regression analysis
such as in our case now you also have
standard error so that's basically
goodness of fit measure that basically
shows the Precision of your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain you can be about your
regression equation so when when we talk
about your R square that represents the
percentage of dependent variables
variance that is explained by the model
and standard error is basically an
absolute measure that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that then you
already know what I'm talking about we
are just seeing how Excel easily helps
us in doing these things now we can also
look at observations here which is
basically the number of observations in
our model which is seven
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your Anova values here
so we basically see DF you have s s m s
f and significance F now to understand
these so basically what we are doing is
or what Excel is doing is it splits the
sum of squares into individual
components that give information about
the levels of variability within your
regression model so when you talk about
your DF that's basically the number of
degrees of freedom associated with the
source of variance you have sum of
squares that is your SS so smaller the
residual SS compared with the total SS
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about Ms that's
your mean Square you have f is basically
the F statistic or you can say F test
for the null hypothesis basically it is
used to test the overall significance of
the model and then you finally have your
significance f which is the P value of f
so uh when we when we usually talk about
scene simple linear regression the in an
over part is uh not uh really used or
it's rarely used right but when we look
at the significance F value that gives
an idea of how reliably or statistically
significant our results are so if
significance f is less than 0.05 that's
5 percent our model is okay if it is
greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at so you basically have
your intercept here so when you talk
about your intercept temperature price
of ice cream so we know we are looking
at our variables and then we are also
locate looking at our intercept which
basically gives you
more details on your coefficients so the
the main important thing when we talk
about regression analysis is basically
your coefficients it basically enables
you to build a linear regression
equation
uh in the form of y equals BX plus a
which I explained earlier and then
basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12 the second one is 15 and
here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right so obviously there will be or
there would be some difference because
independent variables are never perfect
predictors of your dependent variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values so that's what we see
here in the residual section so for
example when we look at this one which
is 11.209 and the actual is 12 we see
what is the residual and how far is the
predicted value from the actual value
so similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables we
are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically uh add in
more details to this particular plot and
you also have normal probability plot
which is basically getting your values
from your probability output here so
this is how you can perform a simple
regression analysis and now what you can
do is you can as I said you can
basically be looking at your scatter
plot you can be looking at your y e and
x and your R square values right but
remember what are the variables which
you are selecting and then you can
compare these with basically the values
what you see here
so remember here I've chosen my both set
of variables and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so it's pretty simple here you can add
more details to your scatter plot or the
plots what we have created or Some
people prefer to do it using formulas so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as you have
linuist you have slope you have
intercept you have correlation and so on
so basically you can use these
particular functions and what you will
have to do is
you will have to basically go in for a
function if that's what you would want
to do and then you can search for
functions and say for example I'll just
say Lin nest and say go and here I have
my function so if I would want to really
use this one I can do that what I will
have to do is then select the variable
so if you just say okay and that
basically says your known wise known X
your constants your stats and basically
you can use the formula also but we are
not covering that here might be in the
later videos we can do that so just try
out and perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of Performing regression
analysis using your data analysis add-in
in Excel power query is an advanced
feature of Microsoft Excel that allows
you to prepare your data for analysis
you can perform numerous text
computations and numerical analysis to
make your data more powerful and
informative Excel power query is a data
preparation and transformation engine
it allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources
now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power query
earlier in Excel there was difficulty in
data connections Now using power query
you can connect to a broad range of data
sources such as relational databases web
files text CSV Json files and even fetch
data in the cloud volume variety and
velocity are the characteristics that
define Big Data it was a major problem
to handle such data
Now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any sheep of data
from any source
earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query reputable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the future
in Excel it was not so easy to reshape
transform and manipulate data but using
power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data now
from Excel 2016 onwards power query on
Windows has been fully integrated into
Excel but in Excel 2010 and 2013 for
windows power query is a free add-in
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the Excel ribbon now
coming to the features of power query so
Excel power query allows you to clean
transform manipulate and process your
data for analysis it helps you to
automate repetitive tasks that you want
to do it over and over again you can
search for data sources and make
connections as and when you want Power
query helps you to prepare and shape the
data in the right format for performing
analysis
and finally once your data is ready you
can share your findings or use your
query to create interactive reports and
dashboards
now let's have a glance at the demo that
we are going to work on in this video
so we look at how to load data from
different sources
you will understand how to extract
tables from web files so we'll extract
tables present on Wikipedia Pages then
you learn how to sort and filter data
up next you'll see how to group your
data how to split a column into multiple
columns
and then pivot and unpivot your table
then you are going to work on date
columns and make some transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open MS Excel and start with
importing a simple text file so you can
see here I have my Excel file opened
and in the middle you can see I have my
employee txt file
now this is a comma separated file
meaning that the values are separated by
commas as you can see it here
The Columns have been separated by
commas and all the values have a comma
between them
now this text file has information about
the name age company and the city to
which the employee belongs to
let's see how easily you can import this
EMP text file into Ms Excel here I'm
using Excel 365 or Office 365 where
power query on Windows has been fully
integrated into this version of excel
so what I'll do is first
let's go to the data Tab and
you have this section called get and
transform data so I'll click on get data
under get data I'll go to from file
and select from Text slash CSV
once I click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there so my file is on desktop I'll
click on
power query files and here you can see I
have my employee txt file you can see
the type here it says text document
click on EMP
and hit import
now this will take some time to import
the file onto Excel
it's establishing a connection you can
see
there you go so here you can see the
file name emp.txt you can see the file
origin as I said the delimiter is comma
and we have the data type detection
and here you can see
we have a text file so Excel power query
feature has automatically detected the
column names so we have name age company
and city as our columns and these are
the values
now let's hit load
so this will load all the rows and the
columns onto Excel
there you go it was really quick
Excel has automatically loaded our text
file
now you can see here we have another tab
called queries and connections so we
have made one query and have loaded the
employee data
it gives a preview also you can see it
here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later
now you can use this data to create
simple visualizations
so let me show you how to do it
so let's first select the data and
we'll go to the insert tab under insert
tab I'll click on recommended charts
let's say I want to know how many
employees belong to a particular City
so I'll click on the second chart which
says the count of Name by City And I'll
click on OK
here you can see
we have a nice clustered bar chart and
you can see in Bangalore there were five
employees in Hyderabad we had two and in
nashik we had one you can see the count
here this is a pivot table
if you go back to our actual data here
you can see
in Bangalore we had Vidya Sonam Avinash
Varun and himani
and there were
two more people from Hyderabad and one
from nashik
so you can use the Excel power query
feature to import data onto Excel and
make some visualizations
now if you want to fetch some data that
is present on the web or on the Internet
Excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well
we will now see how to import data
specifically a table that is present on
the web
here I'll be using a Wikipedia article
on the list of European Cup and UEFA
Champions League finals let me show you
the page first
so this is my Wikipedia page on the list
of European Cup and UEFA Champions
League finals if I scroll down you can
see all the details here
and I would like to import this table
which has the list of all the finals so
we have columns like season winners
score Line run us up venue and
attendance let's import this table onto
Excel
so I'll copy this URL first
now let me open a new sheet I'll go to
sheet1
and then on the data tab
under the get data section
I'll go to from other sources and here I
have from web which allows me to import
data from the web either you can follow
this path or if you see here there's an
option to get data from the web if I
click on this
it is asking me to enter the URL so I'll
paste the URL of the Wikipedia page here
and let's click on OK
now it's navigating and okay
you can see
power query feature in Excel has given
us a list of tables which you can see
here we have something called as
document
there's a key table and here you can see
there's one table which was extracted
from the Wikipedia page
and the table which I am interested in
is this table which has the list of
European Cup
finals
you can see it here
Excel power query feature has
automatically detected these rows and it
has given a
list of columns as well you can see
these are the columns
now we'll explore the transform data tab
present in the per query
now if I click on transform data it will
take me to the power query editor
let me just click on refresh now this is
the most important section
using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data
and make it ready for analysis
now let's explore a few tabs available
here so we have a Home tab that has
a query section you can see you can
reduce rows manage columns sort the data
transform the data combine different
tables
now there's another tab called transform
which allows you to select your data
type transpose your rows and columns
pivot and unpivot your columns and here
you can see
you can find out some summary statistics
and you can manage your date values as
well
now if you want to add some new columns
to your data you can do that as well and
you also have a view tab
now here
if you see the first two rows the values
are the same you can see season season
these are all repeated
which we actually don't need
and these are pretty similar to our
column names
similarly if I scroll down
you see there are some rows
which have null values
so actually these rows do not add up any
value or do not add any value to our
data so we'll clean this data first
so let's see how to do it
now if you want to remove certain rows
in the table what you can do is
go to the Home tab and under reduce rows
click on remove rows
and then choose remove top rows
if I select remove top rows it will ask
me how many rows do you want to remove
from the top
you can see it here I'll give I want to
remove the top two rows
now let's click on OK
you will see
that the Excel power query editor has
removed the first two rows and on the
right you can see the steps that were
applied
you can see it here
previously we had these two
rows which were redundant
and once we applied this step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly let's go down and remove the
last
one two three four five so we are going
to remove the last
seven rows from the table
so again I'll go to reduce rows and
click on remove rows now this time I'll
select remove bottom rows
and here I'll choose
I want to delete seven rows from the
table
from the bottom
I click on OK
if you see
the last seven rows have been deleted
now let me show you the last row which
is this one
so the last season of
UEFA Champions League was held in 2020
which is this year
and Bayern Munich won the Champions
League against
a French team that was Paris Saint
Germans by a score of 1-0
now if you see the last value that is
the attendance
you can see the value is 0 which means
there were no Spectators in the stadium
it was because of the covet conditions
now let's do some more manipulation to
our data suppose this time I want to add
a new column let's say a stadium name by
extracting values from the venue column
so let me just show you the venue column
so this is our venue column so the first
value is the stadium name
then we have the city in which the
stadium is there and finally we have the
country name
so I want to extract only the stadium
name so you can see we have some
stadiums like Santiago bonobo
this Wembley San Siro
another stadium so I want to extract
only the stadium names
so let's see how to do that
I'll click on the venue column and go to
add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have extract now if I click on this drop
down there is an option to select
text before delimiter so if I choose
text before delimiter
here
I'll give my delimiter as comma
so everything before the first comma
will be considered as the stadium name
now let me click on OK
now here you can see under applied steps
it says inserted
text before delimiter if I scroll to the
right you can see the last column
has our stadium names
let me double click on this and change
this to
stadium name column
and hit enter even this step is applied
here you can see renamed columns
similarly
let's explore a few more features
now I want to add a new column called
Stadium City
so
if you consider this venue column
whatever is there between the two commas
is the stadium city so for example
Santiago bernabao is in Madrid similarly
Wembley Stadium is in London sancero is
in Milan so these middle values I want
to extract into a new column called as
Stadium City
so let's see how to do it
so I'll click on the menu column and go
to extract
and again I'll select
the extract tab
and here now I'll choose
text between delimiters
and my first delimiter algae was a comma
and a space you can see here all the
values
have a comma and a space
and my end delimiter will be another
comma
then I'll click on OK this will add a
new column
to the extreme right of the table you
can see here we have text between
delimiters and it has extracted the
stadium city
let me go ahead and rename this
column as Stadium
City
and hit enter
you can see the applied step here
now
I want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column
and
the left value presents the number of
goals that were scored by the winning
team and the right value presents the
number of
goals that were scored by the losing
team
so here I'll split the column into two
columns as winner score and loser score
so what I'll do is
select this column and go to the Home
tab under the Home tab we have split
column
I'll select split column and then choose
byte delimiter
so automatically Excel power query
detects that this Dash is my delimiter
and I'll split at each occurrence of the
delimiter
let's click on OK
now you can see
the score column has been split into two
it has renamed the column as score.1 and
score.2
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and
will rename this column as winner score
and this will
rename it to Loser score
I'll hit enter
and I have renamed it successfully
next
let's change the windows team and the
runner sub team values to uppercase
so suppose I want to change all the
values or the club names of the winners
team to upper case so what I can do is
I'll select this column and go to the
transform tab under transform tab I have
this option called
format
so here
I'll click on format and then
you can see I can change the keys to
lowercase uppercase capitalize each word
so here I want to make all the winner
teams as uppercase I'll select uppercase
there you go we have successfully
converted all the winner team names to
Upper Keys
similarly let's do it for the runner sub
team as well
so here I have my Runner sub team I'll
go to the transform tab click on format
and select uppercase
now we saw
how to do some simple
manipulation of our data so we created a
few columns split a few columns
now to save all this I have to go to the
Home tab and then click on close and
load
this will take some time and load our
data onto this Excel sheet
you can see here it's loading the data
this will take a bit of time there you
go
Excel power query feature has
successfully
perform some manipulations on our data
some calculations on our data and then
it has saved the final version and
loaded it onto Excel Now using this
clean data we can do some analysis let's
say I want to find the seasons in which
the Winner's team scored more than three
goals so we have a problem statement at
hand we want to find the seasons in
which the winner team had more than
three goals scored
so what you can do is select any cell in
this data and go to the insert tab and
click on pivot table
here I'll click on existing worksheet
and then I'll give my location
I'll place my
pivot table somewhere here and click on
OK
all right now
since I want to know the seasons I'll
drag season onto row
and I'll also drag
the Winner's team
column onto rows
then I'll choose my winner score under
values
here you can see we have the pivot table
ready
now we need to filter this table to see
all the winning teams that scored more
than three goals so what I'll do is
I'll select this winner score column and
place it under filters
and here you can see I have my filter
let me click on this drop down
and I'll select multiple items
from this multiple items I'll choose 4 5
and 7 because these values are greater
than 3 and click on OK
here you can see I have filtered my
pivot table and
to the left you can see the season
and the winner team that had scored more
than three goals in the finals
all right
similarly
you can perform some more analysis
suppose I want to know how many times
Real Madrid won the championship so
let's see
I'll click on one cell in the data set
go to the insert Tab and click on pivot
table
I'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location here
let's say I want to place my pivot table
here
click on OK
all right so the question we have is how
many times have Real Madrid won the
championship so I'll choose
the Winner's team column and place it
under rows
and
let's say
we'll select the winner score as well
and let's convert this winner score from
sum
to let's say count and click on OK
and
since I want to check only for Real
Madrid
so what I'll do is I'll go to
the insert tab and I'll insert a slicer
here I'll choose
winner teams as my slicer and click on
OK
and out of this
I want to choose only
Real Madrid so I'll select Real Madrid
you can see it here Real Madrid have won
the championship 13 times
okay let's say you want to compress your
data and remove unnecessary columns
without losing any information you can
do that using a feature in the power
query editor called unpivot
to perform this task we'll use a census
data of India from Wikipedia so let me
first show you the Wikipedia page
so this is my Wikipedia article which
says list of states in India bypassed
population
and if I scroll down
you can see it here there's a table
which says by past population from 1947
to 2011.
so there are a few columns like rank
this state or Union territory and we
have population starting from 1951 till
2011 which was our last census
here you can see if I scroll further
there are
nearly 29 States and we have seven union
territories so we will extract this
table and load into Excel first
okay so let me click on a new sheet
and will follow the same drill I'll go
to my data tab
and click on get data under get data
I'll go to from other sources and click
on from web
here it will ask me to provide the URL
link of the Wikipedia page so I'll paste
the URL here and click on OK
now once I have done that
it will load a few tables
onto Excel you can see there are a few
tables here I'll click on the first one
so we have our table here
now let's do some transformation to this
data
this opens in the power query editor
okay I'll click on refresh first
this will take some time to refresh the
entire data okay we are done now if you
see this data clearly
the first row in this table is not
necessary at all because these are our
column names so we also have our column
headers already present so let's go
ahead and delete the first row so we'll
go to the Home tab under remove rows
I'll click on remove top rows
now I'll give my
number of rows as one so we want to
remove the first row only I'll click on
OK
you can see the first row has been
deleted
if I scroll further
I actually don't need the last row as
well which is the total so what we can
do is we can also remove the last row
from the bottom
so I'll
select one
click on OK
you can see the step has been applied
and
you don't see the last row that was the
total row anymore
so the task that I want to do here is
I want to compress
all these columns which are basically
the population columns
so I'll
select my state or Union territory
column
and go to the transform Tab and here I
have the option to unpivot columns so
I'll click on this drop down and select
unpivot other columns
you can see here the step has been
applied and
all the population column from 1951 till
2011 have been unpivoted if you want you
can go ahead and
rename these columns let's say I'll
write it as population column
and
let's say this is
I'll rename it to total population value
foreign
all right now we are done with our
preparation of data let's go to the Home
tab and click on close and load
now this will take some time to load the
data onto Excel
all right so we have
our Census Data here so first you can
see rank 1 is uttar Pradesh and we have
the population starting from 1951 till
2011 then we have for Maharashtra
if I scroll down you can see the other
states we have Tamil Nadu Rajasthan this
Karnataka if I scroll further
you have odisha this Telangana Kerala
now if you see here the population
values from 1951 till 2011 for the
Telangana state are all n a which means
there was no data available
now this is because Telangana was only
formed in 2014 so there was no census
for this state
let's continue with our demo and let's
explore a few more features and
functionalities of our query editor
now the next table we are going to use
is an adventure Works customer table
now this data set is provided by
Microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn power bi Excel or similar
Technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff
so let me go to a new sheet and let's
import
the adventureworks customer data set
it's a CSV file onto Excel first so I'll
go to my data tab
and click on get data from here I'll go
to
from file and choose
from Text slash CSV
you can see it here in my power query
files folder I have my Adventure Works
customer table
I'll select this and click on import
this will take some time to load the
dataset
you can see the preview of the data set
here so we have
columns like the customer key we have
the prefix of the customer name the
first name the last name of the customer
date of birth
marital status
if I go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform data
here we'll learn a few more
features of power query
okay we have our data on our power query
editor so first what I'll show you is
let's change the prefix column the first
name column and the last name column to
proper case
so you can see it here the prefix first
name and last name columns are all in
uppercase now if you want to change the
values to proper case
just
hit Ctrl and select the three columns
and
go to the transform tab under transform
tab you have format
so if you click on format here you can
see we have lowercase uppercase now
proper case is to capitalize each word
so I'll click on capitalize each word
you can see it here now
we have converted the prefix first name
and last name column
into prop case
The Next Step I am going to show you is
let's merge all the three columns the
prefix column the first name column and
the last name column into one full name
column so
what I'll do is I'll select the three
columns
and then let's go to add column and
under add column we have this option
called merge columns
let's hit merge columns
okay
now it's asking you to give the
separator I'll select my separator as a
space
and click on OK
so before click on OK I want to change
my
new column name from merged to let's see
full name
and now let's click on OK
you can see here it says inserted merged
column and if I go to my
right
you can see it here we have a full name
column now if you want
to shift the location of the full name
column you can do that as well
just
hold this and keep on dragging to the
left
this will move the entire
table to the right and you can place it
wherever you want so I want to place it
let's say here
okay
now actually I don't want all these
columns so let's delete it so click on
this and I'll right click
I click on remove
you can see we have removed the prefix
column similarly let's remove the other
two columns you can either right click
and do or go to the Home tab and then
select remove columns
all right
now
let's say we want to add a domain name
column from AWS customers by extracting
the characters between at the rate
and.com
so actually I'm talking about the email
address
from this email address we want to
create a new column called as domain
name for that we'll extract characters
that are present between at the rate
and.com
so let's see how to do it
I'll select the email address column and
then I'll go to add column under add
column I'll click on extract
and this time we want to extract
between two delimiters also I'll select
text between delimiters and I'll give my
starting delimiter as add the rate
and my ND limiter would be.com
now let's click on OK
so this will insert a new column to the
extreme right you can see we have our
domain name let's go ahead and
change the column name to domain name
and hit enter
all right
you can see the step has been applied
now we are done with
our preparation of customer stable let's
just go to the Home tab and click on
close and load
so all the transformation that we did in
the power query editor
will reflect here so you can see we have
our full name column
and if you see
we have our domain name as well
okay now using the power query editor
you can perform some
statistical analysis now let's explore
those statistical features
for this we'll be using another data set
called Adventure box product data set
again this data set is also provided by
Microsoft
so let's go to the new sheet and here
I'll go to the data tab
click on get data
under from files I click on Text slash
CSV
here you can see we have Adventure Works
products I click on import
let's click on transform data
so we have our data
loaded on to the power query editor
the data is mostly clean so let's not
alter this data let's straight away go
ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's see
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table
how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column then go to the
transform tab now in the transform tab
you have an option called statistics
click on this drop down and select count
values
now this will open another window
that will return the total number of
products in the table you can see the
value here it says 293.
now to move back to the query editor we
have to cancel this step here so let's
just click cancel or close
we are back again
all right
now let's say you want to calculate the
average product price from the product
table so if I move to the right
you have a column called Product price
so let's see what is the average product
price from the product table so I'll
select this product price column go to
the transform tab under state sticks
I'll select average
so this will give me the average product
price which is
714.4373 you can consider any unit you
want let's say this is in dollars
now then we have to cancel this step to
move back
okay
now if you want to find the maximum
minimum product price you can do that as
well so let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab under the transform tab
we'll click on this statistic drop down
and let's say I'll select minimum so
this will give me the minimum product
price which is 2.29
similarly
if you want to find the maximum product
price so select this product price
column go to the transform Tab and then
choose maximum
so this is the maximum product price in
the product table we have
let's cancel this step
okay
now you can also round the product cost
and product price column to two decimal
places so if I show you both the columns
you have your product cost and you have
the product price column you can see the
floating values of the decimal points
are not constant it's varying so let's
limit it to two decimal places what you
can do is Select both the columns and
then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding
I'll click on this drop down and select
round
now here I'll give my decimal places as
2.
if I click on OK
you can see here both the columns the
product cost and the product price
column have been rounded up to two
decimal places
I can scroll down you can see
all the values have been rounded up to
two decimal places
all right
now let's say you want to add a column
called discount price column by
multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column and let's say you also want to
round that new column to two decimal
places so how to do it
so we want to give a discount of
10 percent so I'll select this product
price column
go to add column and then I'll choose
custom column
here we'll write a formula
so I'll give my new column name as
discount price
and my formula would be
I'll select product price
I'll click on insert and then I'll
multiply this product price by
0.9
so this will give me my 10 discount
on the product price and click on OK
you see here we have a new column added
which is Discount price
so
If the product price is 34.99 if you
give a 10 discount
it's 31.491
all right
now the next question was to change the
around the decimal places to 2
so go to the transform tab under
rounding I'll click on round
let's see I'll give two and click on OK
so even this has rounded the discount
price column to two decimal places
now we are done with our mathematical
operation on this product data set
so we saw how to find
some average count how to round up
values how to add a new custom column
so let's go ahead and
close it
and load it onto Excel
you see here we have our new product
table
added here and the last column if you
see it's the discount column that we
added
okay now it's time for us to explore
another feature so we'll use a table
called adventureworks calendar table
which has basically a date column and
let's see how using power query you can
prepare that data as well and make some
manipulation some calculations
so let me go ahead and import
adventureworks calendars table again
this data set is provided by Microsoft
so I'll
go to my new sheet
and I'll go to the data tab
click on get data and from here I'll
click on from Text slash CSV and you can
see I have my calendar table here I
click on import
now this will open in the query editor
you see here this data set has only one
column which is a date column so let's
click on
transform data
okay
now if you see here the first row is
actually the column name
so
let's do the transformation here let's
push this as the column name so I'll go
to the Home tab and under Home tab you
have this option called use first row as
headers I'll select this
you see here we have the column name as
date
now
before making any
operation let's see
if all the fields are available
you see here if I click on
the date drop down
year month quarter weekday day
everything has been shaded out and I
can't access this the reason is
the date settings are not correct
so we'll change the regional settings
let me show you how to do it so we'll go
to file and I'll select options and
settings and go to query options
under query options
we have something called as Regional
settings
here
under Regional settings we'll select
English United States instead of English
India
so I'll just scroll down
and here we have English United States
and I click on OK
now once this is done I'll go to my data
type and I'll select date as my data
type
I'll choose replace current
okay now you can see my date column has
been formatted if I go to
the date tab you can see I have access
to all this
now let's do some operations on this
date column
let's say you want to find the earliest
and the latest date from aw calendars
table or the adventure Works calendar
table
so what you can do is Select this column
go to date drop down under transform and
here we have the option of earliest and
latest so if I click on earliest
this will show you the last date which
was 1st of January 2015
let me close this
similarly you can see the most recent
date
I'll go to the date
drop down and click on latest and you
have 30 June 2017 as the latest date
and close this
now let's add a new column say d name
start of the week and others so I'll
select my date column
go to add column
here under add column I have
my option to
select the D name the week name and
others so I'll click on this date drop
down and under day
let's say I want to choose
name of d
this Returns the D name
similarly
let's say
I want to find out
the start of the week
you can see we have the start of the V
column or start of V column now one
thing to notice here is
in this power query editor the week
starts on a Sunday now suppose you want
to start your week on a Monday you can
do some Transformations on this formula
tab so here in the formula bar you can
add
a 1 here to make sure your week starts
on a Monday so if I hit enter you will
see all this values will change you can
see it's 28 4 and 11 this will become 29
5 and 12. let's hit enter
you can see it here
your start of the week is on a Monday
now there's another method to make sure
your week starts on a Monday let's
cancel this step
okay I have to insert it once again so
I'll go to date and here I'll choose
start of week
now the week starts on a Sunday
so one more method is to
add D dot
Monday you can see automatically
per query is giving me a suggestion so
I'll hit tab to finish it and I'll hit
enter
now you can see the values have changed
and our week starts on a Monday
now let's see we want to add a few more
columns like start of month name of
month start of year
and the year value so you can just click
on the date column or select the date
column go to the transform tab
okay not the transform tab let's go to
the add column Tab and here let's say
I'll choose here
so we have all the year values and
similarly
let's say I want to know the start of
the year
now you can do a few more
Transformations let's say I want to know
the month
now here it gives us 1 which means
January that's February March and so on
and so forth
let's say we'll do one more
I'll click on this
go to my
date
drop down and here I'll choose let's say
I want to know
the day of year
all right now we are done with all our
transformation and preparing your data
on a date field so let me just go to the
Home tab I'll click on close and load
now this will load the
data set on to excel you can see it here
we have the data ready now you can use
this data to make some analysis
draw a pivot table draw a pivot chart
and do whole lot of things now while
working on a project it is possible that
not all your data will be in a single
file it could be stored in multiple
files so it's important to combine and
bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically
I have my data present in a CSV folder
so let me show you the folder first
so this is my CSV folder let me open it
and I have some files these are named as
project one two three four and five let
me open just one of the project files it
has a very small quantity of data
you can see it has a month column and an
amount column let me close this
and
let me show it to you again let's open
project 4.
all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column and an amount column
now we'll combine all this data together
and load it into Excel let's see how to
do it
so I'll open a new sheet
and I'll go to my data Tab and click on
get data then I'll go to from file and
this time I'll choose from folder
now this will ask me to give the folder
location of the path location where my
CSV files are
so I'll choose
browse
and here you can see I have my CSV file
I'll just double click on it
and click on open
now it has selected my
file path
or the folder path
then I'll click on OK
you can see these are the files you have
projectmon.xls
project 2.xls and so on
I'll
click on this combined drop down and
I'll hit combine and transform
now this will give you the preview of
one of the data files
you will see it now
you can see it here it says sheet1
okay
now it's processing all the data files
present in that CSV folder
and this will be uploaded onto our power
query editor
now you can see here on the power query
editor
all my
data files have been combined vertically
here you can see the month column
on the extreme right it's the amount
column and to the extreme left we have
the source name or the
source file where the data came from so
first is Project one then we have
project two if I scroll down we have
project three files project four and
similarly we have project five
now this is one way in which you can
merge your tables vertically
so we are done with it let's just go to
the Home tab and click on close and load
all the Transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final table
and we have successfully combined
five Excel files
again
you can also join your data horizontally
this would be like an SQL join where the
data is present in multiple files or
sheets based on a common key column you
can join the tables so you can perform a
left join a right join an inner join
based on the problem that you are trying
to solve so let's merge two tables based
on a column
I'll show the data set first it's an
Excel file which has three worksheets
so here is my Excel file which we'll be
using to
data horizontally you can see there are
three worksheets
the first one is year 11 which has data
regarding the student name the gender of
the student and the course the student
had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name gender
as well as the course
and finally we have a courses
table or a courses sheet which has all
the details regarding the course
so we have the course name the teacher
who teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the
number of credits and the assignment
type now we'll use this data sets
to load it onto Excel using power query
so I am on my Excel sheet let's just
open a new sheet I'll go to the data Tab
and here I'll click on get data and this
time I'll choose
from Excel workbook
and I'll select my file which is
students and courses I click on import
so we'll just see how to import two
tables and join them horizontally
so let me first select the courses sheet
and I'll click on transform data
now this has loaded the courses table
onto power query editor the table looks
fine we have the course column teacher
everything is fine now let's load one
more table and then we'll merge it so
here under the Home tab you have
a section called new source
I'll click on file I'll again select my
students and courses and click on import
and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course
I click on OK
it has successfully loaded this table
onto power query editor
now if you say this
the first row is actually are
column names so I'll go to the Home tab
and select use first row as headers
so this will push the first row
to the column names you can see we have
done it successfully we have my student
name the gender column and the course
column
now let's merge it so if you see here in
the Home tab we have a section called
merge queries
let's click on this drop down and select
here I have my table which is year 11
and let's choose one more table that is
courses
now the kind of join
I'll choose as left outer join which
means it will take all the rows from the
first table and matching records from
the second table
here I need to select the common key
column so if you see both the tables we
have the course column as the common key
column so I'll select
this and now you can see there's a tick
mark which means it has selected the
rows and the column successfully you can
see it says the selection matches 175
175 rows from the first table
and let's click on OK
let's just expand this
and click on OK
if I scroll to the right you can see I
have successfully merged
both the tables
now if you want
you can remove unnecessary
rows or columns suppose if you see I
have the course column
from the year 11 table and here also I
have
the course column now this is
redundant let's just remove one of the
columns I'll just select this column
I'll go to
remove columns and I'll select remove
columns
okay
the rest looks fine we have successfully
merged both the tables by using a left
outer join
let's just click close And load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto Excel you can see it here we
have successfully loaded it onto Excel
now we are done with our demo part
now let's just see what all we have done
in our demo so I'll
go to my first sheet here you can see
we had imported a simple
text file first and then we plotted a
graph which is a pivot chart
then you saw
how to upload
a file from the web so here we imported
a UFO Champions League table which was
present on Wikipedia and then we plotted
some
graphs and charts you can see we made
analysis using pivot tables
and then we imported another web file
which was based on a population data and
we used the unpivot option or the
unpivot feature in the power query to
reduce the number of columns
then we made some calculations to our
customer table which was from Adventure
works
then we used another table
called the products table here we saw
some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional operations
and then
you saw how we manipulated a date column
and then we saw how to append and merge
multiple tables what is the pivot table
a pivot table is a tool that summarizes
and reorganizes selected columns and
rows of data in a spreadsheet to obtain
a desired report
it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots turns
the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables especially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually
now
let's understand the different
components of a pivot table
so there are four main components first
we have rows when a field is chosen for
the row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table
similar to The Columns all row labels
are unique values and duplicates are
removed
columns is the second component
when a field is chosen for the column
area only the unique values of the field
are listed across the top
then we have values each value is kept
in a pivot table cell and displace the
summarized information the most common
values are sum average minimum and
maximum finally we have filters filters
apply a calculation or restriction to
the entire table
so let's jump over to Microsoft Excel
and let me show you the data set that we
will use in this demo so with India
being ready for its 16 census in 2021
that is next year it is a good time for
us to analyze India's last census data
from 2011 and see where different states
and cities across India stood in terms
of population literacy and other
socioeconomic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin
first I'll show you one of the features
that Excel offers us so suppose I click
on any cell and hit Control Plus Q
you can see our entire table is selected
and at the right bottom there's an
option of quick analysis
now you can see by default Excel has
prompted certain features such as
formatting we have charts totals and
this one more called tables now Excel by
default has created some pivot tables
for us now the first one you say is sum
of district code by state names
next we have sum of sex ratio by state
name
then we have some of child sex ratio
some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivot
table so let's have a final look at our
data set
so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name tested code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City
then we have the male and female
literates next we have the sex ratio
then we have the child sex ratio
next we have total number of graduates
and finally you can see we have male and
female graduates so using this table
we'll create several pivot tables
now first of all let's create a pivot
table to find the total population for
each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement
so our first pivot table will have the
total population for each of the states
in descending order
so to create a pivot table you can click
any cell
in your data go to the insert Tab and
here
left you can see we have the option to
create a pivot table so let me select
pivot table
now my range is already selected the
entire table
and here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivot table
in the same worksheet
and I'll give my location I'll point to
cell Q5
now let me click ok
you can see the pivot table Fields
appears here on the right
now since we want to find the total
population for each state so what I'll
do is
I'll drag my state name onto rows
so here in our pivot table you can see
we have the different state names listed
now
we want the total population for each of
these states
so in the field list I'll search for
total population which is this one and
drag it under values
you can see
we have a sum of total population for
each of these states by default
Excel will sum any numeric column you
can always change it to average minimum
maximum anything you want now we want to
sort this column in descending order so
I right click go to sort option and
choose Z to A that is largest to
smallest
you can see here
in 2011 Maharashtra had the highest
number of population
or the total population in Maharashtra
was the highest then it was uttar
Pradesh we had Andhra Pradesh
and if I come down we have nagaland and
Andaman and nicobar Islands towards
the end
so this is a simple pivot table that we
created now the next problem we have is
we want to find the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so let's see how to do it
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
here I can click on pivot table
my range is selected
I'll choose existing worksheet and give
my location
which is Q5
I click on OK
now here we want to find the total sum
of literates so what I'll do is first
let me drag
total literates column two values you
have the total sum of literates from all
the states
next I want to see the sum of total
literates based on states and cities so
let me first drag state name onto rows
and then
we'll drag City
on two rows
you can see here we have our pivot table
ready
to the left of the pivot table you can
see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have Bihar
and if I keep scrolling we have all the
states haryana himanchal Pradesh that's
Jammu and Kashmir which has now become a
union territory
we have jharkhand Karnataka and other
states as well moving on
okay so the next thing we want to see is
what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state
with that we also want to find the
states that had the highest and lowest
sex ratio in 2011.
so let's create a pivot table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose pivot table
click on existing worksheet
I'll select cell Q5
and click on OK
now since we want
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio so first I'll drag those columns
either you can manually scroll and
drag it or here you have the option to
search for it so if I look for child
you can see we have
the same
column listed you can just drag it from
there let me delete this
and I also want this x ratio
so I'll place it on top of child sex
ratio
next we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is
I'll take
state name and put it under rows
so here you can see we have our pivot
table ready on the left you can see we
have the different state names listed
and on the right we have the values
now we want to find the average Now by
default Excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child sex ratio so what
you can do
you can click on this drop down and go
to Value field settings
and here summarize values by you can
choose average
you can see the custom name it says
average of six ratio
click on OK
our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into average I'll again click on the
drop down
go to Value field settings
click on average
and click ok
and you can see here we have the average
of child sex ratio for each of the
states now the next question says which
states had the highest and lowest sex
ratio so we'll consider this column so
we'll sort it in any order you want you
can do it either ascending or descending
let me short it in descending order
you can see we have our
column sorted now
so in 2011 Kerala had the highest sex
ratio
and if I scroll down to the bottom you
can see himanchal Pradesh at the lowest
which is around 818.
up next let's explore one more feature
of pivot table so suppose you want to
see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivot table you can do that as well so
here we have a question at hand
we want to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates so let's see from the entire
pivot table how we can filter the top
three cities
so I'll go to insert
click on the pivot table option
go to existing worksheet
click on Q5
and hit OK
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag
City column onto rows and then we want
the female graduates so in the search
bar I'll look for female
and I'll choose this column that is
female graduates and drag it
here on to values
so I have
the sum of email graduates for each of
the Cities now since we want to find the
highest number of female graduates in
the top three cities so let me first
sort this column
I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that Delhi in Greater Mumbai and
Bengaluru are the top three cities
but it's displaying all the cities for
us
so let's filter
only the top three so what you can do is
right click
and go to filter
under filter you have the option of top
10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three
so either you can
go down like this or you can directly
type 3
your column is already selected let me
just click on OK
there you go we have the required pivot
table ready and it only displays us the
top three cities with the highest number
of female graduates
now the next thing we want to see is how
to use a Slicer in a pivot table so we
have a question here What's the total
population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
so let's create a pivot table for this
and see how you can use a slicer to
filter the table
click on existing
I'll click on a location this time q6
click ok
now since I want the total population so
I'll drag total population onto values
and then I'll select
the city
onto rows and then the state name also
I'll place it on top of City so you have
in the pivot table all the states and
their cities
and on the right you can see the total
population for each of these cities
but our question is we want to find only
for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is
go to insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivot table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer and click on this
and since we want to slice the table
based on
state that is Rajasthan and Karnataka
I'll choose state name
as my slicer field
you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want
the data for Rajasthan and Karnataka so
I'll search for
these two so here we have Karnataka so
let me select Karnataka first
and I also want for Rajasthan
so let me select Rajasthan also
you can see in our pivot table we only
have
data for Rajasthan and Karnataka
so this pivot table
shows you different cities from
Karnataka and the total sum of
population from each of the cities and
similarly we also have for Rajasthan
moving ahead now we will see another
very interesting feature of pivot that
is how you can
create percentage contribution of a
table
for example we have a question here
what's the percentage contribution of
male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that
I'll create my pivot table
click on existing
and I'll select an empty cell
okay
now here since we want to find the
percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll drag
male literatures onto values followed by
female literatures onto values by
default it has summed up the male
literacy and female literates value
and also I want to drag State column
two rows
so here you can see the sum of male
literatures and female literates per
state
I want to convert this as
percentage contribution so
what we can do is I'll select any cell
and
I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select
percentage of grand total so I'll select
this
you can see we have the percentage
contribution of mail literates to the
total
now if I sort this you will get to know
which state contributed or has the
highest percentage contribution
so we have Maharashtra for male
literatures
then we had uttar Pradesh in 2011 if I
come down
we had meghalaya nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar Islands
as two states which had little or
minimal contribution to male literates
similarly let's do it for female
literates
I'll go to so value as and select
percentage of grand total
so you can see here also Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh then Gujarat and all had
the
highest percentage contribution to
female literates
so this is another good feature
to convert your data in c10 in terms of
percentage
now moving ahead let's say we want to
find the bottom three cities from each
state that had the lowest female
graduates
we can do that as well I'll go to insert
click on pivot
go to existing worksheet select an empty
worksheet and click on OK
now since I want to see based on States
as well as cities so let me drag the
state name first onto rows
and let's drag the city column on to
rows
next
we want female graduates so let me look
for female graduates in the field list
I'll drag it on to values
now we have the list of states and their
respective cities
and to the right of the pivot table you
can see the sum of female graduates from
each City
now
first I'll
sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
shortest to largest
now we have sorted our female graduates
from
shortest or smallest to largest
now since I want to find the bottom
three cities from each state I'll come
to the cell
right click go to filter and select top
10. now I'll
replace top 10 with bottom and I want
the bottom three cities from each state
I have my column selected that is some
of female graduates if I click on OK
you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
Andaman and Akbar islands has only one
city that is Sport player while the
remaining you can find
the bottom three cities with the lowest
number of female graduates so Andhra
Pradesh had these three in Assam we had
nagao then there was the broker and
silcha similarly if I come down in
haryana we have palwal kathal and zind
if I come further here you can see for
Karnataka this kangavati this Rani
benoor and the school are similar you
can see for Kerala as well
now moving ahead
now in the next example I'll tell you
how you can create a calculated field or
a calculated column in Excel with the
help of a pivot table
so in a pivot table you can create or
use custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items calculated fields of
formulas that can refer to other fields
in the pivot table
calculated Fields appear with other
value fields in the pivot table like
other value Fields a calculated Fields
name May proceed with sum of followed by
the field name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables and
those have been categorized as fruits
and vegetables we have the price per kg
and this is in terms of rupees
and we have the quantity that was sold
now let's see if you want to find the
sales for each item in the table you can
create a calculated field
so your sales column is going to be the
product of price per kg
and quantity so let me show you how you
can do that with the help of a pivot
table
I'll create a pivot table first
click on an empty cell
hit OK
now
if you see on the top under pivot table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets
if I click on this drop down I get the
option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this
I'll give my field name as sales
and
I'll select my formula
I'll first click on
price per kg and hit insert field
I'll give a space hit shift 8 to give
the product symbol and then I'll double
click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I'll click on ADD
and I click on OK
if you see here
there is a calculated field that is
present in the pivot table fields which
is sales but it did not add it to our
original table or original table is the
same but here we have added a calculated
field which is present only in the pivot
table list now we can use this it has
already taken it under values now let's
say I want to find the sum of sales for
each item
under each category
you can see it here
we have our category fruit and we have
our category vegetable and under that we
have different items like apple apricot
banana similarly in vegetables we have
broccoli this carrots corn eggplant and
others
so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivot table
now there's one more good feature that
Excel offers us in pivot table is to
create a pivot chart so you can use your
pivot table and create different charts
so I'll show you how to do that
if I go to insert
here I have the option of recommended
charts click on this Excel gives me some
default charts which you can use
let's say I'll select this
let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivot
field list
this is a nice bar chart that Excel has
created this is called a pivot chart now
here you can see the category fruits and
vegetables and the different fruits and
vegetables or the items
in the y-axis you can see the total
sales
if you see from the graph guava made the
highest amount of sales now if I sort
this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my pivot table the
pivot chart also automatically gets
updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and
let's click on recommended charts again
let's look for a pie chart so this is a
pie chart that you can create let me
click on OK
so here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item
and the pi that has the highest area
represents
it had the highest amount of sales in
this case you can see
it is guava and similarly we have other
items as well this is fruit banana
that's corn
and we have spinach and others
let's explore a few other charts so
first I'll
click on my pivot table go to insert
and under recommended charts let's now
select a line chart
if I hit OK
move it to the right so this is a line
chart
you can see it starts
from guava which had the highest amount
of seals then it drops
and in the x axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broccoli made the
highest amount of sales with
2800 rupees and our lowest was eggplant
at 900 rupees for fruits papaya sold the
least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert
under recommended charts let's see
this time we'll see a bar chart now this
is a
horizontal bar chart and not a vertical
one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this
is an horizontal bar chart now you can
always increase and decrease the size of
this charts
let's explore
our last start let's take the area chart
for now
so this is an area chart again it looks
similar to the line chart it starts with
guava which had the highest amount of
sales similarly papaya under fruits had
the lowest amount of sales under
vegetables it was
broccoli and finally eggplant metal
lowest amount of sales under vegetable
now let's go to our first sheet and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for pivot tables in Excel so we had our
data
this is a 2011 Census Data from India we
had the different cities the state names
and we had the total population total
literatures female literatures male
literates we had the sex ratio total
graduates and other information
so we began by understanding how to
create a simple pivot table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
had the total population in 2011.
then
we saw
another preview table where we
calculated the total sum of literates in
each City belonging to a certain state
so you can see we had the
different state names and the cities
under each state
then
we saw another feature where you could
calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex ratio
after that we saw
how you could find or filter tables
we saw how to find the top three cities
with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and Bengaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
graduates
next we saw how to use Slicer in a pivot
table so we sliced our table based on
Rajasthan Karnataka State and saw the
total population for all the cities in
Rajasthan and Karnataka
in the next sheet
we explored another feature that was to
find the percentage contribution of male
and female literatures from each state
then
here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates one thing
marked that some of the states did not
have three cities for example Andaman
had only one city that was sport player
but the others we found out the bottom
three cities that had the lowest female
graduates
finally we looked at how to create a
calculated field in a pivot table so we
saw how to create a calculated field
called sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw is a column
chart we also saw or looked at
a bar chart that was a horizontal bar
chart similarly we saw how to create a
pie chart as well today we are going to
talk about a Microsoft Excel interview
questions so here I'll be discussing
some important questions that you will
come across when You Face interview for
Excel and we will start with the basics
the beginner level and most of them will
be discussed here will be the beginner
level at the beginning and then we'll
discuss it for at the further left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in Excel so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have an
Associated column number column letter
and a row number so you have to keep in
mind it will be always be a column
letter and a row number each Excel sheet
will have suppose for instance if you
take Row 5 rows will be in numbers and
the columns will be in letters column a
column B column C column D and so on and
the numbers will be for the rows so for
instance if you take this particular uh
cell the cell address is D5
column D and row 5.
so this is the cell address now let's
move on to the next one
now you will be asked what is relative
cell referencing and absolute cell
referencing
Excel
so relative cell referencing is usually
the relative references change when a
formula is copied to another cell
depending on the destination's row and
column okay so this is called relative
cell referencing absolute cell
referencing irrespective of the cell you
know you don't have to depend on the
value of the cell destination there is
no change when a formula is copied so
this way I'll explain it in the next
Slide the basic difference is this type
of referencing is there by default in
Excel relative cell referencing you just
insert the formula you don't need to put
a dollar sign in the formula whereas
absolute cell referencing if you don't
want to change in the formula when it's
copied across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add a dollar
sign before and after the column and row
address so see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as A3 into B3 so
what it will do is it will multiply A3
and B3 and it will give the product this
is relative cell reference whereas
absolute cell referencing is again the
same thing but you have to put a dollar
sign before the column and the row
number so here you are specifying this
as a pre into B2 okay A3 into B2 and it
will give you this particular answer
irrespective of that it will give you it
will calculate what is there in this and
it will give you the answer
okay now we need to move on to the next
point is basic question when you go
scroll across an Excel sheet sometimes
you have a header on the first row and
if you scroll down you will not be able
to see the first row so there is a
process uh or the there is a trick to
freeze the pains in the Excel so you
just need to have the rows locked so how
do you freeze paint this is the question
so what you need to do is you need to
select the view tab go to the view Tab
and go to freeze panes it's a basic
thing and you will see this if you see
here
select the third row and click freeze
pins so you just select this and click
free page
okay so you're going here and you're
going to the third row and you are going
to view Tab and you are selecting free
Spin so what happens is first two rows
will be locked
okay
these two rows will be locked similarly
for if you want to freeze the columns
okay it's the same thing I am going to
select this particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pin so what happens is the first
two columns are locked A and B will be
locked and if I scroll right you will
always see the customer name and
category column so these two we have
logged and the next will be scroll so
this is the function of freezing panes
okay now coming on to the next one and
you will be asked and you have an Excel
sheet or a spreadsheet and you want to
restrict you want to protect the data
for from anyone or from someone cop from
copying the cell for your worksheet so
how do you do that you need to select
that particular data that you want to
protect and then click Ctrl shift F and
then you will see the protection tab
okay you just need to go to the
protection Tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you you need to select
the sheet put a password and just save
it so I will show you across in one of
the examples here so this is particular
data that you have and you need to
protect you select it
so here as I said I selected it and then
I just press Ctrl shift F so here you
see the protection tab click the
protection Tab and then click select and
then locked and then click OK and then
you need to go to the review Tab and
then click on the protect sheet and you
are having the you need to select this
protect worksheet and contents of locked
cells so if you are selecting these and
you are protecting the content and you
just need to put some password
okay
click
okay so this is how you protect the data
on a worksheet and you are selecting
this area Ctrl shift F and just put up a
password and select lock sheet so this
is how you protect the sheet from anyone
to copy it second
and now the next question that you might
be asked is what is difference between a
function and a formula in Excel
so you will be asked this question and
you need to remember this formula is
like an equation which is typed in by
the user you are typing it suppose a 1
plus B2 you are typing this formula in
one particular cell okay whereas
function functions are predefined
calculations it is like a formula which
is already there in Excel and you can
use it so as it says here it consumes
more time and it has to be typed in
manually you this is as per the need
basis and this is particularly it's very
quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in Excel the sum and
multiplication product and various other
things that you will come across so this
is the basic difference between a
formula and a function in Excel okay
the now the next question that you might
be asked is uh or you need to know
basically is the order of operations
used in Excel while evaluating the
formulas so what is the order you need
to remember this acronym padmas p e d m
a s or another simple terms you can use
this also please excuse my dear and
Sally so these are the acronyms p e d m
a s now let's see what happens first and
you uh in math when you do some
calculations you have order of
operations okay bod mass is the one of
the order of operations now in Excel
similarly in Excel when you put up a
formula you Excel will calculate it in a
particular order and this is called the
order of operations and the Order of
Operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any X components in it
and if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is a new
multiplication or division so p e d and
then it will see if there is any
addition okay and then the last one will
be the subtraction so Excel knows this
and you have to know this so that when
you put up a formula you will know what
is going to happen first and you will
not mess up with your formula okay this
is the order of operation so it is one
of the important questions in the
interview for a beginner Excel level now
the next one is uh how will you write
the formula for following multiply the
value in a cell A1 by 10 and add the
result by 5 and divide it by 2. it is
quite simple okay so I'm just giving it
as an example in this slide and you
might be asked something else so you
will be given a task to calculate or put
up a formula for this so when you are
asked to multiply the value in a Cell of
A1 by 10 so this is particularly t Okay
A1 is the particular cell that is being
given and you are multiplying it okay
you put it in parenthesis and then add
the result by 5 so it will calculate the
parenthesis first okay and if it sees if
there are any exponents you have to
think in that way if there are any
exponents in or not and then first it
will see the parenthesis and then
exponent there are no exponents here and
then it will do the multiplication and
then the addition and the division okay
so you will get this particular answer
and if you put it simply in this way
your answer is wrong because it will
multiply it into 10 at 5 and divide by 2
so you have to check which one is right
and you have to make sure that you are
putting the right parenthesis Okay so
okay
the next question is uh there is a
different what is the difference between
count counter and count blank these are
three particular important things that
you need to these are similar but they
are quite different when you actually
see it okay so first we will see what is
count count is basically it counts the
number of cells which have numeric
values as the name suggests it is count
it will count the number of cells which
has numeric volumes okay if you see this
column and uh we are at a11 we are
putting it as count equals to a 10 to A2
to 8 and so you are taking this range
and you're finding out what are the
number of cells which have numeric value
if you see this one two three four five
so five cells have numeric values it
counts the cells which has numeric value
and the next thing is the counter okay
what counter does it counts the number
of cells which has any form of content
it can be anything it can be a number it
can be a alphabet it can be anything it
will see what are the number of cells
which has any form of content okay for
example this is the same example we here
taken here and we have put the function
as counter A2 to 18. now see one two
three four five six
seven so it sees that there is
seven cells have some content in it it
is numbers and letters it can be
anything but it has some content so
counter is the function for this then
the next one is Count black okay as the
name suggests it will count the number
of blank cells only
so again the same examples count black
A2 to a 10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two cells are
blank so it will count the number of
blank cells only okay now the next one
is uh what is the shortcut to add a
filter to a table why do we use filter
and it is one of the basics uh function
in the Excel where you need to do some
sorting and it can be done by using a
printer what is the shortcut key it's
very simple control shift and L this is
the key that is used to put up a filter
you just press this
Ctrl shift L altogether and you will
find the filter and you can sort it now
the next question that you will come
across is how do you create a hyperlink
in Excel so it's quite simple there is a
simple shortcut Ctrl
okay you press these two together and
you will get the option you will select
the it will select the cell where you
have to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to any other
document it can be a web page it can be
a Word document it can be another Excel
sheet or so on okay so these are the
things okay
now another important questions uh that
is how to merge multiple cells
text strings in a Cell so how do we
merge the text strings in multiple cells
into one cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatenate concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells okay and it's a very
simple thing you just need to put this
equals to concatenate and then if for
example this is the formula concatenate
text one text to text B or this is uh
concatenate A1 comma B1 comma C1 this is
the data in our three cells Excel is fun
in A1 B1 and C1 so now if you want to
put them all in one and you can merge it
in one cell using the concatenate
function and it's by simple concatenate
and parenthesis A1 comma P1 comma C1
okay and you will get it all merge in
one particular cell okay so this is how
you use the concatenate function and you
can also use the and operator to combine
cell values it is the same thing you can
use e and operator instead of Commerce
okay
and I will show it to you in the example
here
okay now we have this I'll just copy
this thing to
yeah okay and let's make it simple and
now I want to put this here equals
click on
concatenate
and a one
comma B1 comma c i just close it and I
put enter so you see this this all three
the different text is merge in one
particular cell and it will you can
perform various merge functions using
the concatenate function it's a very
simple thing and it is a frequently
asked questions in the interview okay
the next question uh it is very a very
important one again and a very basic as
well so how can you split a column into
two or more columns you have some
particular text or a sentence written or
data written in your cell or a column
and you want to put them across in two
or more or many number of columns so how
do you perform this function it's very
simple again you need to select that
particular cell so for instance we have
it here is India is a democratic country
India space is space the space Dem
Democratic space country so the it's a
different text here and you want to
split this particular sentence into
different columns okay you need to
select that cell and then go to the data
Tab and then choose text to columns
there will be an option wherein you need
to select text to columns okay and you
will see this screen okay and you need
to select the choose the delimiter here
and what we are specifying here is first
it is a delimited and then we are
selecting a delimiter as space because
we see that it is space here which is
very common and we want to split it so
you will see a preview here which shows
what your output will be like India in
one column is a democratic country so
the diameter is space here and T you
need to select this and then click next
Okay so you will see the options select
the columns data format and choose the
destination now you see the data View
and you need to select the destination
where you want to put this output as you
select that and then click finish and
this one what it does it it's it splits
the text into multiple columns okay so
you see this you have selected this as
the output and it starts here India is a
democratic country so you will come
across some data which is you know huge
and there are spaces or obligs or
anything that is differentiated it with
and you need to put them in different
rows or different columns so this is the
function r that you need to use to split
the text into different or multiple
columns okay okay the next question can
be very simple one or most widely used
in fact and what is the use of vlookup
and how do we use it so what is this
particular thing in Excel vlookup
function is used for looking up a piece
of information in a table and extracting
some corresponding data or information
so you have some set of values in one
particular column and you want to
retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular column
or a cell in the whole sheet okay so the
syntax is something like this it is you
need to go to one particular cell where
you want the output as and you type the
function
vlookup and you are selecting the value
where it is the cell exactly where you
want the output to be and you are
selecting the table here and the you are
specifying the column index and range
lookup so value this indicates the value
that you have to look for in the First
Column of a table okay and then the
table table basically this refers to the
table from which you have to retrieve a
value we will show this in the example
in the next slide and the column index
column index it provides the column in
the table from which we are to retrieve
a value okay we will specify the column
index which one you are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true with the if you put true
it is approximate match which is default
and false if it is exactness if you are
looking for the exact match so what is
the use of vlookup and how do we do it
okay so find the product related to a
customer name Richard okay you have this
sheet and in this one you want to see
what Richard has bought okay what is the
product that he has but and you can do
this with the vlooker function okay so
you just go here and you type in the
function vlookup you're naming it as
Richard
and first thing is the value it is H4
okay and then the next thing is the
table okay table is A2 this this is the
table okay and you're looking for
customer name Richard
okay and then you are selecting this
the whole column index which is E15 I
mean you are selecting this whole table
then 15 okay e 15 you're selecting this
and then the next thing is optional
which is give you the uh range lookup
okay what it does is it's optional it is
you're looking for an exact value or an
approximate by default it is approximate
map so how it performs the function okay
so it gives you the answer as camera it
goes and lookups for Richard in this
particular it will give you the output
here and the A2 is the table that it
will look for the customer name and it
will search for Richard and then it will
give you the arc camera now the next
thing will be we look up different Pro
lookup function how different they are
we look up lets the user look for a
value in the left most column of a table
so as we've seen in the exam example it
allows you to look for data in the lack
moves column of the table and Returns
the value in a left to right okay it
starts in left to right where lookup
function lets the user look for data in
a row column and Returns the value in
the another row or column it will give
you the lookup function in the next
workout okay not very easy to use as
compared to the lookup function okay as
we see it's a bit complicated when you
compare it to the lookup function it's
quite simple and it is used to replace
the we do car function okay so this is
the different lookup and vlookup
function now Excel is basically used for
reporting mainly used for reporting to
management you have to extract different
kinds of reports and what are the report
formats that are available in Excel this
is one of the important questions again
for a beginner level and there are three
formats basically compact form outline
form tabular form okay these are the
three formats that are available report
formats that are available in Excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does IF function work in
Excel okay the F function in Excel it
actually performs a logical test and you
will give a condition it performs the
test and returns a value if the test
evaluates to true and another value
which you again will specify if the test
result is false okay for instance we
have here the simple example which is
shown in the slide and what we are doing
here is a written record is valid if age
is greater than 20 we have age here
specified and salary is greater than 40
000 else written the record is in value
so we are giving two conditions and it
actually checks and evaluates whether
these conditions are met and it will
give you then output whether record is
valid or invalid based on the two
conditions that are specified okay and
F22 axis which is this these column we
are specifying it should be greater than
20 and G2 to G6 which is the salary
column and we are specifying the
condition to be greater than forty
thousand So based on this two things it
will check and perform if these
conditions are met then it will give the
desired result okay so this is the
function that is used in Excel IF
function okay the next thing is sum IF
function okay again the sumic function
adds the cell value specified by a given
condition or a criteria so you are
giving a condition and you are actually
doing another function which is
performing the addition okay it will add
the cell values based on a condition
again it is shown here the total sum of
salary where salary is greater than 75
000. again for example the salary column
is G2 to G6 and we are doing a sum F
function what the result will be it will
perform the addition of salaries which
are greater than 75
000 so it will see which values are
greater than 75 000 and then then the
output will be it will be adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next slide we will
discuss another important function
counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the count of function so we have a
slide uh net data here and using the
Kobe data find the number of days in
which the number of deaths in Italy has
been greater than 200 okay it's not uh
shown here for some reason but I will
show you in the Excel sheet okay so this
is the data that we have and we will try
to find the function so we'll use the
countif function and counter function is
again simple counter you are specifying
the
column that is the source that you are
looking for that is G2 the column G and
it is 2. it starts from 2 Row 2 G2 till
G 3 5 triple seven which is the end of
the column and what you are looking for
is Italy you are specifying it in codes
Italy and then the next column that it
will look for is the E column the number
of cases okay here we have the number of
cases e 2 2 again we are specifying the
range and what we're looking for is
number of cases which are more than 20.
so we'll perform this function and it
will show you the output okay I'll show
you to you in the Excel
so here is the sheet and I will try to
get the answer here and
the
so we are performing count
foreign
[Music]
uh any country you can pick up like uh
Algeria
okay
and you specify it in quotes
comma
then what is the next Target that you
are looking for is the column e various
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay so you specify the column range for
the number of cases which is again e and
then
uh
the three five triple seven I mean it's
a basically long list of data that you
are looking for and then you are what is
the condition that you want to know and
you will have to specify it in course
and what you're looking for is number of
cases which are more than
in your head and
okay so it gives you the output as 143
so there are 143 days in which the
number of cases were more than 20. so
let's refine our search further let's
see 30.
and it gives 140
so another example that you can take is
let's pick Afghanistan
I can install and put so there are about
19 days that you will see the number of
cases where more than 30 and this can be
done with the count F function
so the next question is about the pivot
table
so what is a private table it's
basically is a summary of table of the
data set I mean the data that is there
that can be you know multiple number of
rows and columns which has different uh
data that has to be uh that is there in
the reports and you need to analyze
those Trends and you need to create a
report and basically present it to the
management or in a presentation so pivot
table is a summary of table you know
whatever data is there you can put it in
a summarized format they are useful if
you have long rows or column that hold
values you need to drag okay so you have
long list of data and you need to
summarize it and put it in a
presentation or a you need to track the
values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data and then go to the insert Tab and
select pivot table okay and then it will
show up like this and you need to select
the table which is a table or range and
then you need to specify where you want
to put up this private table okay and
it's quite simple and I can show it to
you in one of the examples Okay so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate error
as we have seen in the previous slide
you need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the private table and then once you do
that you will see something like this
and you need to select these particular
fields and put it in value so let me for
example you need to select the depth
number of death you can just simply
click this select this drag and drop it
in the values okay so these are the
different fields that can be put up in
the table okay we can show it to you in
the example here
so this is our data and we need to show
it in a pivot table okay select this and
then go to the insert app and click
private theme okay
select that and it will show you the uh
table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay I will put it in the
existing worksheet okay and I'll just
select which color I'll put it
here for example and it will show you
this and click ok so this is the table
and now you need to select the fields
that you want to show in the table for
example we need to see the continents
the number of cases as per the
continents okay I selected and put it in
the row and we see the immediately we
see it in a table where you see the
number of names of the continents and
now I want to see the number of cases
and I simply select it
and put it across in the value so this
is quite simple and very informative
very short and crisp
form of presenting the data in
a private table okay so this is how it
is being used and it is being presented
you just need to go to the insert tab
pivot table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
so the next question here is how do we
create a drop down list in Excel this is
particularly useful when you need to
sort a particular data with the drop
down list where a number of different
variables are there and you need to
select one particular uh field and sort
the data so you can do this by creating
a drop down list using the data
validation in presenting the data tab
it's quite simple you select the data
and you go to the data validation tab in
the data and click select data
validation so once you select it it will
ask you to specify a range so you need
to select what data you need to sort and
put a drop down so you need to select
this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay I'll show it
across in the Excel for example what we
have here is some particular data and we
have different variables we need to sort
or put a drop down list so just go to
data as in as said in the slides and go
to data validation and click data
correlation now as you click it it will
ask you to data validation settings okay
and in the drop down go and select list
option so it will ask you to specify the
source so when you asked to specify the
source just click this particular column
and click ok so here I'm mentioning the
source is column B okay B 3 t b 14 Okay
click OK and then it will give you the
option so here you can uh you can put
this in anywhere across the Excel and
click the option okay so this is the way
to drop down using the data validation
option so in the next example we will
see so how do we apply Advanced filters
in Excel we use the advanced filter
option present in the data tab so this
is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of datas and you need to
sort it and it's it's actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field with this criteria and you
can select it and specify the criteria
and specify a range what you want to
select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified and you can just
get it in a single click so this is the
option you have to go to
data tab Advanced and you have to apply
the advanced filter and then you need to
specify the list Trend that is the is
killing the source and then the criteria
wherein you specify the criteria present
here I mean you are specifying in this
case we will take an example where we
are trying to sort the data or the
number of cases based on number of
deaths and in a particular country and
we are specifying the output the copy to
field is the output where you will see
the output so I'll show it to you in the
Excel so here we have a spreadsheet
wherein you will see all the uh data
with data that we have and based on the
countries and the continents and the
number of deaths number of cases and so
on okay and that's also a different
fields like the date year and month so
so here I am going to sort the data
which is particularly for Europe and
which has that's of more than 200 in a
day so how do we do it go to data
Advanced and the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list
screen so it's basically given in this
countries okay and the criteria range
you have to specify this so I am going
to select this as my criteria okay and
then I have to put the output in one
particular cell so I need to select it
again let's say here okay
and then I just click ok
see it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay so it shows me the deaths
which are more than 200 and for which
particular country and for which
particular are continents are all right
so this is basically made very simple
with this option the next question is uh
you know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than five
thousand dollars so what we do is we use
conditional formatting to highlight the
cells based on the criteria it's a very
useful tool in analyzing data and
Visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the data in quick flash you
will see the data and it's quite visible
using the conditional formatting so how
we do that is I will show it to you now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see who has done more sales
which is greater than the five thousand
dollars so just go to home and you need
to say go to conditional formatting so
for that you need to highlight or select
this go home conditional formatting
highlight okay and you have different
options here you select way through that
and you specify the value I here my
criteria is five thousand dollars okay
we can select which color so let's go
for green
okay
see this you will immediately see the
option you don't have to dig or look in
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index function
is a very powerful tool wherein you know
you for example you have a table of
planets in our solar system and you want
to get the name of the fourth planet
Mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time you can use the match function okay
with the match function together you can
play wonders with it okay match function
is another function that is designed to
find the position of an item in a Range
we can use the match function
to get the position of a word or look or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the index and match function to find
the city how we do that is shown here
okay it uh it looks quite complicated
here when you see the formula but I can
show it to you in the Excel and explain
it further okay so here I have and I
want to know where these people are and
where they belong to okay
so
let's see how it goes uh we have seen it
and we use the index function okay
index okay now when I have to specify
the range okay so the range is A2 and it
shows it selects the name and I want to
select it from A2 to
Excel okay E7 sorry
e
called e 7 okay so as you see it
highlights the whole table okay now what
I'm going to do is I want to match it
okay match it with a condition I am I am
specifying a condition a 10 why because
I have to specify a name here and it
will show me the city where he belongs
to okay where it shows is a
two okay if you see A2 it shows the name
through A7 I have to specify the range
here okay not just one name we are
specifying the holding as you see if you
put the values it will show you the
selection
okay it's in and what it should be it
should be the exact match so 0 denotes
the exact match parenthesis is closed
and I am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output what output is
okay
B9 okay this is my city v9 is the city
where I'm trying to find okay and what
it should look for is a column A A1
through
e 1 okay it should select these this
particular row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay let's see how it goes
if we give you an error because you
haven't put the value here okay so let's
see
foreign
index and match function being used and
it can be asked in frequently in the
interview questions okay the next
question will be uh how to find
duplicate values in a column okay there
are two ways that you can actually do
this and one is basically the very
simple one which is the conditional
formatting and the other one is we have
seen this before count if function okay
how we do that you need to Simply select
the data and go to conditional
formatting and select duplicate values
and it's quite simple and there is
another way which give you the color
coded conditional formatting okay there
is another way that is the countif
function how we do that is again the you
have to put another column and put up a
counter criteria contact function
wherein you see that you are specifying
the range
and the
the value which is being twice or enter
duplicate and you have to put up a
condition I'll show it to you in the
text so here we have the data and I need
to find the duplicate values here so I
just select this and as I said it's
quite simple go to conditional
formatting form and then go to
conditional formatting and select
highlight cell rules and simply go down
and select the duplicate values okay it
will give you which color you want you
can simply select red R anything as you
see the moment you select you will see
the duplicate values highlighted okay so
I just cancel this and there is another
way then count a function so I'll put
another column where it says duplicate
names and I will put up a counter
function here
okay
so let's see how a counter function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate name so as I said I will put
up a formula a function here for the
count if
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
counter and since it's an absolute
reference
I have to put up a dollar symbol
okay my reference here will be H the
count here h
okay
again dollar because I'm using it as an
absolute reference
colon
through
dollar symbol again
nine okay so it drags till at the whole
it tracks till the
all the names okay the H9 all right and
then
what I'll do is I'll put a comma in y I
want to do is I have to select H2
okay this is my criteria I mean it is
repeating twice all right
and
I have to close the parenthesis and if
it is more than one okay so this is my
formula I just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition and it is true okay I simply
drag it the whole thing and whether
events is repeated yes it's true Andrew
it's a duplicate entry false me is a
duplicate entry and it says true and as
you see me and events are duplicate
entries so this is how we use the
counter function and the conditional
formatting to sort duplicate entries in
the date
now let's move on to the last question
for the beginner level and since we have
duplicate entry there is also a problem
to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to Simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values select it and
delete it okay and this is one tedious
way of doing it and you can also after
deleting the values you can go to the
conditional formatting choose clear
rules to remove the rules from the sheet
so this is one way okay the next thing
is again a simple button that is there
in the data tab that is the
is one of the tools present in the data
which is simply called as remove
duplicates it's quite simple and it's
there in the data tools let me show you
in the Excel so here we are and we have
this data and we need to check and
remove the duplicate so as I said go to
the data Tab and simply click on remove
duplicates and when you click on it it
will ask you you want to continue or
expand this selection I just say
continue with the current selection and
to move duplicates okay select all click
ok to duplicate entries that were
removed previously we saw that events
and
[Music]
me weather so that has been removed okay
so
that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300 in
demand skills and get access to 1000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like a higher
level or intermediate level compared to
the previous things that we have
discussed with the basic level questions
uh for the Excel interview so let's move
on to the next thing
in
so there are there are some scenarios
where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet and
you need to find out
what is the day of the week okay so you
might be asked you a question how do you
find out the day of a week for a
particular date so that is the function
we we have a specific function and that
is the weekday function to find out the
day of the week for a particular date
okay so as we know these are the seven
days of the week and we just put the
function as it says equals to weekday
and we need to enter the column or the
area or the cell address here so weekday
is the function and it will give you the
which which day it is of the V okay we
go as it says one it denotes Sunday
okay and three is again Tuesday okay so
this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
Excel so basically Excel Sports three
types of wild card which are
asterisk the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next Wild Card is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single characters okay whereas Asterix
is it represents any number of
characters and the third one which is
rarely used in Excel it is the tilde it
is used to identify a Mobile card
character that is till the Asterix
question marks in the text okay and it
is very rarely used so you need to
memorize these three things that the
there are three types of wild cards we
can see the functions of this in the
later sessions okay the X1 is we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data values what is
what is it used for and you you should
know how to set up in an example okay
data validation is a feature in Excel
that is used to control what a user can
enter into a cell okay so you have with
the data validation you are not allowing
a data kind of data that should be input
in the cell okay for example you have
the authority and by setting up the data
validation that you can enter either a
number or at text or just a number and
so on okay using the data validation and
where is it available it is in the data
tab okay select data validation option
present under data tools okay and you
just need to select the particular cells
where you want to set up the data
validation I'll show it to you in an
example so this is how it looks like you
just need to go to data tools and click
on data validation and it will show you
and you have the options here allow and
if you click on the drop down you will
see different options like I will show
it to you in the example here okay
for this particular thing if I want you
know this column should have only names
and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay so there are some columns where you
have to put only names or you have to
put only number so you can set this up
with the data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up another so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell okay so here as an example I have
some data where I am putting the names
here and I'll put the salary here I want
to make sure that you know we cannot
enter any numbers here okay it should be
only text it should have only name so
how do I perform that how do I restrict
any user to
that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation and here in the
settings I'll go to custom there are
different options here you can you can
choose whole numbers decimal list date
time so your these are the option and I
go to custom and I am giving a
particular formula here okay what is
that it should be only text okay so it's
a simple thing it should be text and I
need to define the range okay so how
I'll Define the ring I just select this
okay and
all right select the range okay
so I have selected the range here and if
you go to input message and error alert
you can customize it and here we are
taking the default one and this is the
input message if you want to set or
customize something okay so let's see
how it works okay I have said this and
then I try to put a number here and it
throws me an error the value you entered
is not valid because we have set a
restriction a user has restricted value
that can be entered into the cell so
this is how the data validation worked
okay the next thing is you will be given
a situation wherein you have to uh you
will be given data and you have to punch
perform a function like in this example
we are taking a condition wherein you
will have data and you have to specify
the result based on the data you have to
formulate it okay so given below is a
student table write a function to add
password fail to the results column
based on the following criteria you will
be given a criteria so this is the
student table you are giving the student
names marks and attendance and then
based on that you will have to specify a
next uh a formula wherein you will see
the result okay based on the past
student data you have to put a pass fail
results in the column based on the
following criteria what is the criteria
and for example here in this example
what they're saying is you have to say
that the student is passed if his marks
is more than 60 and the attendance is
more than 75 percent okay so how we
perform this function as it says you
have to use the IF function and check
with the hand condition to fill the
results column okay so let's see this in
the example here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
IF function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so I have to put the IF function here
okay and check with the and function
okay and I have to specify the
conditions I have to satisfy where it
should see the or check the conditions
okay so we are checking the conditions
here and the marks should be in row I
mean the column U and it starts with u5
so let's see U
5 okay it will immediately go to column
U and five row five okay and then what
is the condition we are satisfying here
it should be greater than 60 okay and
the other condition is
uh the column V that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying V 5 should be greater
than
75 okay
and we just close this conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
pass
comma in quotes again
three okay so let's see how this works
okay
okay see this works okay the marks is 50
and attendance is greater than 80. so he
is failed because he has marks of 50 his
attendance must be more than 75 but yes
he is he has not scored marks more than
60. so we drag the same formula to the
whole thing and you will see the result
okay this is quite simple and you will
see this
formula and using the if and
check and check with and condition okay
now moving on to the next question you
might be asked to you know this is a
simple function wherein you can you'll
be asked to calculate your age in years
from the current date okay so how we do
that there is a particular function and
it's very simple use the ear Frac or
dated IF function to return the number
of whole days between start date and the
ended so you specify a start date which
will be uh today's date and the I mean
the birthday and then the end day will
be today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the age using the year
Frac function and dated F function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the ear flag function okay
you specify this function and then
specify the inputs that is the today's
dates and the
date of birth and the today's date okay
and this is one of the ways to get it
and there is also created F okay this
again it is dated a function and you
specify the input cells okay so let me
show you an example for the same
so here we are and we have today's date
that is 4th of May and date of birth for
anything it should be so I will specify
the efragment
okay
equals
here rack okay
and then I should as soon as you enter
you specify the start date and the end
date okay and I will specify the start
date as today's date let's fix the
column and then I put the comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay and just close it and it will
give you the
age
okay so this is the age for example if
you want to find out my age I don't want
to reveal my birthday but it's okay
let's see if it calculates
I'm 32 years old okay all right so this
is one of the ways and similarly you can
use the dated IF function shown in the
example all right now moving on to the
next question you have a nested if
statements this is very important and
you will definitely be coming across
this question how are nested if
statements used in Excel what are nested
statements the IF function can be nested
I mean it can be Loop when we have
multiple conditions to meet okay it can
be nested the false value is replaced by
another IF function okay you have
specified some condition and you are
putting up a condition and if that
condition is not there or not met then
if it will be replaced with another
IF function so the syntax will be like
this below is an example so we actually
we use two if statements in conjunction
okay so here is an example here we are
specifying a condition wherein you know
uh the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 60 it is
bad or average so this is very simple
you are perform one if condition and if
that is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements okay uh I'll
show the same example here in the Excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their Mars okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is less
than 60 it is bad or average okay so how
we get this is we use two if conditions
if
statements so uh as we have seen it if
if now the first condition is our source
or the source is B2 okay so B
to
and what I'm specifying is it should be
greater than
80. all right I just close this and the
result should be excellent okay
foreign
excellent if it is more than 80 and if
this condition is not met it will go to
the next if statement okay we are
nesting another if statement what is the
condition here for the next statement it
will check B2 is less than or equal to
60 you can specify any marks all right
so if it is less than 60 it should give
the result as bad
or average okay
specify anything and you
okay and just close the double
parenthesis so let's see how it works
okay see it works like this
now let's pull up the same formula the
for the other results okay
see if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay and now in this case for
Mark it is bad why because it will first
see whether it's excellent or not if it
is not excellent then it will check the
other condition if it is less than 16 it
will give you the bad result all right
and similarly so on for the other
months all right so this is how we use
the nested if statements
you are adding two if statement the
first condition and the second condition
with another if statement okay okay when
it comes to excel it is basically
involves a lot of data and a lot of data
to be analyzed and we have some powerful
tools which are used in Excel to analyze
the data one such uh important tool is
descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so we
might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis too
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics option in Excel for the data
analysis okay how you do that is you
have to add a pack okay you should be
knowing that you need to add a pack
which is called the analysis tool pack
which you go to uh file options and then
just click on the add-on and select the
analysis tool pack click uh Excel add-in
and just click go and it will add the
option and then when you select the data
you have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be which will
show up when you select the Addle or
when you add the add-in okay then you
need to select the descriptive
statistics what we need to do is we need
to analyze this data and it will show
you the values like mean and the you can
also customize you can you see you have
this data and for you to check each and
every row and find the mean the smallest
the
maximum number and things like that so
this can be easily done using the
descriptive statistics for the data
analysis uh I'll show the same thing in
the Excel how it can be performed so
here we are and I'll show you first how
to add the
option to it okay go to add and select
analysis tool pack as shown in the slide
and you need to click go if you just
click OK it will not add so just click
go and then you need to select analysis
tool pack okay it will give you these
are the different options uh for now we
are selecting analysis tool pack and
then click OK as soon as you do that you
will see the data analysis this option
gets enabled when you add that pack so
this is the data that you have you need
to find or analyze using the descriptive
statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there and if
you want me to show I will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
date
okay this is my input range you need to
select this labels in the first row so
that you know it doesn't take the first
row okay I'll show you
foreign
you are getting a summary statistics
which is the default and you can select
the confidence level that is the mean
value and you can set it up by whatever
well value percentage you want and you
are selecting the largest one and the
smallest number so all these data will
get analyzed and it will open up in a
new sheet and just click OK and you will
see this so these are the if you see
this is our data paid organic social and
revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more precise
okay so with a single click all our data
is analyzed okay this is the mean value
and this is the minimum is zero maximum
so you can set this is the total and the
number of count is thousand so you don't
need to scroll down and check what is
the largest amount that is paid so this
is the largest amount for the
wait okay and so on so for the largest
revenue generated all these things are
generated with a descriptive analysis
okay descriptive statistics with the
data analysis tool so the next question
is about a pivot table and this is more
refined or more advanced compared to the
last one that we discussed in the
beginner level so here you are asked to
create a pivot table to find the total
cases in each country belonging to their
respective continents you are giving you
are being asked to put up a table or
pivot table with two variables basically
each country and their respective
continent so again we have the same data
and we need to set up a pivot table
which shows the continents and the
countries with the respective continents
the number of cases okay so let's see
how we get this in the example so here
we are we have the same data it shows
the days months year cases countries
and there continents okay
consonants here and so on okay so I'm
I'll go to the insert Tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing I
will be asked to enter a input range
okay so I select this
and since it's huge I'll just
put the number to be 777
okay let's assume
now this is our input data and where you
want the output to be it's already
selected you can put it anywhere I am
putting it here okay just click OK and
it will give you the option to select
the fields now what we want is number of
cases okay which will show you the value
and the countries and territories their
respective continents so okay so this is
how it looks like and we have to check
now it is asking us to find the
countries Okay so
with their respective continents you see
this you see Africa as a continent and
you will see
okay you will see Africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of on I mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries territories
where their respective continents you
will see as such if you just expand this
you will see the countries that are
having the cases in the continent Africa
okay so country wise sorted with the
continents okay this is the other
Advanced step to get the data or show
the data in the private table okay
another question that you might be asked
this is a basic and we have already seen
this in the previous example that I have
shown how do you provide the dynamic
range in data source of a pivot table
you have to select a particular data
source in your input table uh to show up
in the pivot table so you have to select
the input range but how do you create or
how do you create or provide a dynamic
range in this data suit so just need to
create a name table to provide a dynamic
name so where is the data of your table
so as we have seen in the previous
example you will be able to select the
input range and you just need to put
this value any number so that you know
it will pick up the dynamic range for
your input source for the tape okay so
now we move on to the next one and this
is about about the pivot table again is
it possible to create pivot table using
multiple sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheets
can you create a pivot table for all the
worksheet in a single pivot table yes
you can but there is a condition there
should be a common Row in both the table
so you cannot have different types of
data there should be a common row okay
so then only it will act as a primary
key for the first table and the foreign
key for the second table okay so this is
something that you have to remember and
you need to create a relationship
between the tables and then build the
pivot table so you have to analyze what
kind of data it is it should have a
common Row in both the tables on both
the sheets and then you have to
establish a relationship between this
table and then build the table okay
there is a wizard for that well
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you I will be asked to further
refine or you know refine your search
and show it in the data so here we have
with the code data example again you
will be asked to create a pivot table to
find the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the coveted again and we have done this
before we have created a preview table
for this and we need to further refine
it showing the top three countries with
the number of cases and I will show that
same thing in the Excel and we already
have created a table and we'll refine it
further to show the top three countries
which are having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the table uh already with us and I
just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so you just need to go here and you need
to select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and now I select top 10 and what I
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these themes okay
and based on the sum of cases okay this
is our field already then just click OK
and it will show you the top three
countries so it's quite simple and it is
very important to know this feel and how
you play with the value of the filters
for each particular uh field in the
pivot table so it shows you these things
all right now you can refine it further
with the continents and all okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right we
have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay like you will be given a
situation where you need to add one more
column and show it in the pivot table
with a particular calculation or with
the particular value and you have you
don't have that actual value in your
data but you have to calculate it and
show it across in the table so there is
another option which is called pivot
table analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option so when you go to your
table and then go to pivot table analyze
you will see the option to add a
calculated field okay just go there and
click select calculated field and you
need to Define so in this example we are
going to Define another column where we
calculate the bonus of the sales and
there is a particular Formula E formula
is you put an if and statement and then
you calculate the formula you specify
what is the bonus and what is the way
that you're calculating the bonus and it
will particularly add it another column
to your table so let's see how we do
that in the table it so here we are we
have this table and I have inserted a
pivot table and I'm putting it in
output here
okay
and then you will get the table okay now
you need to select the
customer name
and the unit sold unit price sales okay
so we'll add another column to it how we
do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay you
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus
bonus and as I said we will put up a
formula for this and we will Define it
how we calculate the bonus okay and then
if and statement which we have seen
before how we
put up a
and if and statement okay now I'm going
to say it has
like this sales to my sales
should be
I'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and the unit sold okay I am trying to
put it as the units on it also depends
on the units
sold
is greater than 1000 okay for example
let's say a thousand a person who is uh
able to do a sales of 4000 and the unit
sold should be more than thousand then
the sales
what is this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus
and
sales
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus click add
okay so we have added this and we have
put up a calculation for the formula and
you will see this look so this is simple
way of adding the column to your
existing data and we are doing the
calculations and showing it up okay so
this is one way go to pivot table
analyze and field
item sensors you can select this option
and add it okay you can customize this
as I said with adding different fields
this is pretty handy in analyzing the
data which does not exist in the table
and you add some value to your pivot
table okay
the next uh question will be about
slicer you must be familiar with what a
slicer is in a pivot table and how do
you use it for the purpose of using it
and how do you put up a slider in the
pivot table so how does a slicer work
basically slicers are used to further
filter data in the pivot table suppose
you already have some data and it's for
ease that you can do it by just adding a
slicer you can select particular
data in or a field and you can see the
output for that particular field that
you have chosen in the slicer okay so
it's very simple go to the insert Tab
and select slicer under printers okay
and then it will be like this okay and
here if for example you see this is our
period table we have added two slicers
to filter our table that is month and
countries and territory so this will be
the general pivot table that looks like
and we have an added another two slices
that is month and Country so if you go
for example if you want to see what is
the number of cases and some of the
deaths for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see and do this in our Excel okay
so there is a table or pivot table
already created for this and I want to
add a slicer so how do I go ahead and do
this is I go to the
options and insert slicer okay at the
moment you click on it you will see what
are the options that you want to add you
can select different fields and
select the slicer put it uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the and again
this will be covered slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
territories okay
click on that and you will see two
simple badges here that you can choose
from so if I want to know in the month
of Feb how many number of cases were
there per particular let's see the
moment I choose the month it will show
that particular number of the
corresponding table for the whole and
now I want to further refine it to a
particular country so for example
Australia okay so there were total
number of 18 cases and zero deaths at
the same time if I go for Algeria it is
like this so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
Manner and ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country and
continues to the turkey cases again the
same example for our code the kovid one
in this time we want to show the output
as the percentage of contribution for
each country and continents to the total
cases so we have the same data and we
generate a pivot table and we should
show it as the sum of the cases to be
percentage okay and This Is How We Do It
this is our
data and I'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table and here I have to
show what is the fields that we need to
select okay first is we are just
selecting the cases and the countries
and territories Okay so
cases to be for the values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when I see
what do you see then it shows the number
of cases now if I just want to refine it
further and see it as number of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how I do it show field
list I go here and I go to Value field
settings okay then
again
number format show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing
percentage of grand total and then just
click okay
and you will see
this to be the percentage so it shows
the data in the form of percentage okay
this is very simple and you just need to
remember as we have seen before
super field and then value field
settings okay this is the thing that you
need to check okay Grant percentage
there are other options also and you can
select from whatever you want to create
in this case we are showing it to be the
percentage okay okay guys now the next
question is about a very important
aspect of presentation when we come to
favorite charts how do you create a
favorite chart in pivot tables this is
very
basic or very you know important aspect
of pivot tables that you can represent
data in a in the form of a chart and
there are different types of charts
which I'll show it to you in the uh
example okay so we have a data here and
we want to show it in and right now it
is in a tabular form okay we have put up
a pivot table for this and now if the
same thing can be put up in a pivot
chart okay so what you need to do is go
to the insert Tab and select the pivot
chart it depends on different versions
of excel that you have different uh
forms or different buttons so I will
show it across to you and this is how it
looks like okay it's very simple it can
be a pie chart it can be a bar chart it
can be different forms and we can see
that in the example here okay so let's
go to the example and
so we have the pivot tables generated
here already what you need to do is you
need to select the table and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is by bar area scattered and other parts
okay there are different forms okay so
right now what we do is we will select
the column chart here okay you need to
select the pivot table and click on the
column chart again there are different
forms which can be seen in some time now
so this is the basic form okay and it
will show you the countries I mean the
and it will show it as a form of a chart
okay again you can change the chart type
you can change it to Pi okay this
personally is very good in presenting or
doing presentation and you can select
different forms different styles okay
and also show you the percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table into a chart okay again bar type
is also there
so this won't suit here in our example
there are different points I'm just
showing it to you
as how it looks like so depending on
your I mean the aesthetic you can see
and select what kind of chart is best
suitable okay
so this is how you put up a pivot chart
in pivot tables okay
so this is when last for the
intermediate level and what are macros
in Excel create a macro to automate a
task basically you have some daily tasks
that you perform in Excel okay and
you can do this with quite ease using
the macros okay it basically is a
program that resides within the Excel
file and it is used to automate tasks in
Excel some daily tasks that you run like
run when you come across in any data and
you have to scrub that data and you do
some daily routines and by removing some
columns or adding some formulas and you
know doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a macro and this is what
macro is used for in Excel so how you
capture those steps in Excel is through
a macro to record a macro you can either
go to the developer tab in the Excel and
click on record match or you can use or
access it from The View tab Okay so
these are the uh ways to access macros
okay just go to the developer tab and
click record macro when you know when
you click record macro it will record
the steps that you are performing in
each step and it will capture that and
you can save that it is like a daily
routine that you run and you can do all
these multiple steps maybe n number of
steps within a single click by running
that macro later on okay so you record a
macro and run that okay you do it
through the developer tab go to
developer tab and click record macro and
it records all the steps that you are
performing okay you need to name it and
you just need to perform the actions and
it will record the macro and you just
save it later on whenever you come
across the same daily task that you run
you can just click it by running that
macro okay
so in a single click it will perform all
the actions that you have done or steps
that you have performed on that
particular Excel sheet or any other
Excel sheet okay this is very handy when
you have similar data and you do the
similar task each day okay so this ends
the intermediate level and in the next
slides we will see the advanced level so
now we discuss the advanced level uh
interview questions for Excel and when
it comes to the advanced level you will
come across definitely you will be asked
about what if analysis how does it work
how does it how does what-if analysis
work in Excel so what if analysis as the
name suggests you have to have
an analysis done okay with the help of
different complex mathematical
calculations like formulas and using
different formulas and calculations you
can experiment with the data and you can
analyze if this particular input changes
what will be the scenario how will your
output turn out to be so as you can see
it is about different variables to see
how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so this is what
what if analysis is and the same thing
can be done with Excel and how it is
done is you need to go to the data Tab
and click on the what-if analysis under
forecast okay so there are three options
in
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the data table so these are the
three situation or three tools which are
available in the what-if analysis in the
data tab okay so goal seek is basically
for reverse calculations okay and you
have some idea you have some set goal in
mind and you have certain variables and
what you need to do and what you need to
achieve to have certain set goals okay
you have you will set a value for the
goal and with the goal seek option you
can get to know what value you have to
achieve to come to that level okay so
this is what goal seek is it is one of
the simplest sensitivity analysis tool
and so for example you know that you
know a single outcome you would like to
achieve like you have a set goal that
you have to achieve this particular
grade
okay and the goal seek feature in Excel
allows you to arrive to that goal by
mathematically adjusting a single
variable within that equation so you set
the goal and you will do the what-if
analysis goal seek
uh option to know what you have to do or
what you have to achieve for the set
goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis okay so in this scenario
you the data tables allow the adjustment
of only one or two variables within a
data set but each variable can have
unlimited number of possible values okay
so basically they are used for side by
side comparisons and it makes it very
easy to read the scenarios okay one but
you need to set up the data table
correctly okay and what you do is you
give the input in the table and then you
set up the formula and for instance you
need to calculate the monthly payments
for a loan okay you provide the
principal amount like whatever amount
you're taking 2 lakhs three lakhs and
you set the interest rate in a formula
okay and and you set the term in and
then you need to provide different uh
input options like what loan amount that
you're taking and you set the formula
and go to data table and I mean go to
what if analysis and select the data
table table stretches across and then
you will see the monthly payment options
or the monthly Emi that you can
calculate there are different uh things
that you can calculate you can calculate
the Target or the sales bonus or things
like that okay giving different
scenarios in the variables okay but you
need to set up a data table it might be
a little challenging but yes it is a
very powerful tool okay so the next one
is the scenario manager it is a bit more
complicated compared to the other two
but then it is uh more advanced than
Google see as it allows you the uh to
adjust the multiple variables at the
same time okay
and this is very complicated compared to
the other two and it is even I mean it
gives more better output when it
compares to the other two what-if
analysis tools
so here when you go to what if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to analyze what if you
are changing the value of your interest
amount or the
term of loan or your targets like
monthly targets or an yearly targets and
things like that and you just have to uh
see what the scenario will be when you
set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in Excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
vbe okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the task it is performing okay
so when you are writing a module you
will have a function when you have a
function it will always give you a value
okay for example you are performing an
addition it using the function it will
give you a value for sure whereas
subroutine it does not return a value of
the task it is performing functions are
called by a variable okay you can set up
a variable and you can call the function
okay whereas subroutines can be recalled
from anywhere in the program in multiple
types okay in many different ways you
can recall a subroutine like we have
seen we write a subroutine and we put up
a button and we can when you click the
button it will recall the subroutine
functions are called by variable okay
you have to set up a variable and when
you enter it it will come okay functions
are used directly in spreadsheet as
formulas whereas Subs cannot be used
directly in spreadsheets as formula okay
this is very important difference and
the next thing is the functions can be
used to perform repetitive tasks and
return a value whereas users must insert
a value in the desired cell before
getting the result of the sub so this is
particularly limited okay whereas
functions can be used to perform
different repetitive tasks and return a
value user input is not required whereas
if you see the subroutines user must
insert a value okay in the desired cell
that way in a particular cell which is
defined in the subroutine to getting the
desired result okay so these are the
differences between functions and
subroutines now the next one is what is
the difference between this workbook and
active workbook in vdf so when you work
on modules and different Excel
spreadsheets and workbooks you will have
these different workbooks open and there
is a particular difference and you might
be asked what is the difference between
this workbook and active workbook so as
the name suggests this workbook refers
to the name of the workbook where the
code is actually running from okay you
are running a code VBA code and it is
the actual workbook where you are
running the code from and that is this
workbook okay and you have multiple
spreadsheets open and you are working on
particular suppose for example you are
working on a sheet X okay and you active
workbook is the workbook that is
currently active from the different open
verbs you have different open workbooks
but you are working on one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
reference to the name of the workbook
where the code is actually written
whereas active workbook is the one one
that is currently open currently active
Okay so this is the difference between
this workbook and the active workbook in
VBA as shown in the example this is a
simple sub that is written a code that
can be written to find out which
workbook is the uh it which workbook is
the uh this workbook in the VBA and the
active workbook processor okay so this
is a simple thing that you can run to
determine okay it shows the active
workbook and the this workbook okay so
as we move on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a PBF function okay
there are two ways basically arguments
can be passed to a VBA function as a
value or as a reference so this is an
example that you can see it is by
reference the key word for this is by
reference okay so when you are pressing
an argument by reference the keyword
should be by r e f whereas by value
you're specifying a value and the
keyword is by v a l value okay so these
are the two ways that you can pass an
argument in VBA
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
buyer that is the keyword before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the keyword that
is being used okay and by reference is
the default in the VBA and let's use
specify something else which in this
case is by value okay and as I said the
keyword for buy value passing the
argument y value is by v a l okay so
when you set the keyword by Van
the variable what happens is the buy
value argument function or argument uh
uh is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here which
means it assigns a value to the variable
X here okay because the variable was
passed by value in the function any
change to the value okay any change to
the value of the variable is only the
current function so it ends after it
performs the function okay then it
revert backs to the value when it is
declared again where it is set to 0 so
if the variable has been passed by
referencing the function then the
variable would have permanently assumed
the new assigned value so this is the
basic Difference by reference and by
value
so now we move on to the next one so
there might be a question that you will
be asked that how do you find the last
row or a column in a VBA okay so to find
a last row sometimes you have long list
uh data and it has like n number of rows
and N number of columns so instead of
scrolling down all together to find the
last row you can use this VBA code you
can write this code it's a very simple
one and it will give you the last row
you will find the last row with the
single click okay let's see it in the
VBA so here I have a sheet which you
know it has long list of uh rows and
instead of scrolling down I can just
find out the last row with this
VBA code okay I just click on this and
as seen in the slideshow I have just
return it and we will see the if you
just run it and you will see the number
of rows it will give you the last row in
the sheet okay similarly we can do this
for the column as well okay in case if
you have long list of our large number
of columns instead of scrolling right
you can just uh run this VBA and you can
see you can know the
last number of column okay number of
columns so as we've seen in the last row
now we'll see the code for the finding
the last column is the same thing uh
instead of row you will see it as column
all right and it will when you run it
you will give the it will give you the
last column okay
now let's move on to the next one so you
might be asked this how do we check
whether a file exists or not in a
specified location there is a code
simple VBA code that you can write and
you can run you can use this utility to
find out whether the file exists or not
okay and you need to check whether the
file exists and if it does it will give
you a message that the selected file
exist and if it doesn't it will pop up
with the message box saying that the
file selected file doesn't exist so what
you need to do is you have to specify
this function okay and check file exist
this is what it does okay you have to
specify a variable that is the store
file name where you will give the
location the location of the file and
the name of the file okay and then you
will also specify whether the file name
is there or not now so it runs this and
it will see either the file name exist
or the file actually exist or not
and it will give the appropriate message
box we can run the same thing in my PC
and we can check it
so here we are I have put this and I
have done the same thing and what I'm
looking for is this book two okay let me
maximize it this is what I'm looking for
and the location is desktop okay so let
me run this and you will see whether it
exists or not okay and it says this to a
selected file exists so it goes and
checks whether the file exists and then
it will give you the message so this is
how we check using the VB so the next
one is uh you know there is a powerful
tool called debug and you need to you
might be asked questions about how debug
works or how you check the debug okay to
debug a video code line by line you can
use the f8 key okay you can also create
a breakpoint to terminate the execution
so for this if you go to your VBA you
will see the option as debug okay you
can use this by clicking on debug or by
pressing the f8 key okay so what debug
does is it will show you the
step-by-step execution of your steps
okay it will check each and everything
and if there is an error it will pop
okay and the what is breakpoint is at
some point of time you can check one
particular step okay you can stop the if
suppose if there is a thousand line
codes and you want to check on one
particular step like maybe 800 step so
just go to go to that particular step
and you can enter a breakpoint and it
will show you what is actually happening
at the that point that particular step
and you can see this in the locals
window or the watch window okay so let
me show you some simple example of how
this debug can be used to check our
course okay so here I have written a
simple code for this and it is basically
uh let me show you how debug works okay
this is the okay let me maximize it and
we'll see okay so this is the debug
option that you can run and you will see
what happens okay this can be done by
clicking f8 all right so step into is
the option and you can check
f8 and you can press f8 again it will go
to the next step all right and it will
show you what's happening actually uh
you can see this in a uh locals window
what's actually happening let me see uh
let me maximize it a bit
so that you can actually see okay so
when I press f8 okay
step into
you will see what happens in The Next
Step okay this is what is happening a is
empty B is 0 I is zero okay I step into
it the next step again so it goes here
you can see what changes happen I press
f8 again
so this is what is happening all right
so it is checking each and every step so
debug is the tool that you can use to
check the course whether this is a very
simple program but then you will have
some different codes where you
functions are routines that you can have
where you have thousand line codes and
you need to check each and every step or
some particular step so this comes in
very handy okay let me press f8 and it
shows what happens in which uh you can
step into each and every step and see
what happens okay and now if I show
there is something called as toggle
breakpoint okay this one particular is
used by
pressing the F9 key wherein you will see
what is actually happening at some
particular step okay so how you do that
is you just need to go to a particular
step and click on the bar here and it
will get highlighted into red so so this
is what is happening okay so in the
watch window you will see that
particular step will be uh magnified or
you can see what is actually happening
in that step okay so let me start it
again
see what happens
I press f8 again
so here it sees it actually shows you
can toggle and you can see what is
happening in the watch window at that
particular step so module one ABC the
variant is empty so expression is B this
is what is happening at this particular
step okay so this is how debug can be
used
so now as we move on to the next one
well you might be asked to create a bar
chart with the given data using PBA so
you will have some data and you can
create a bar chart or a any kind of
chart with the VBA we have done it with
the pivot tables and all but then we can
do the same with the VBA so it's a
simple thing a simple sub that you can
drag and create embedded chart using
chart object this is the sub that you
can use okay you are specifying a
variable here and ambigital you need to
specify the embedded chart and which
sheet you are using and this is very
basic and the charge a chart objects
like the length the dimensions of the
chart okay and you need to specify the
source okay the source sheet for range
so and so you can specify the range here
so let's go and do the same thing in the
Maybe
so here I have the data and let I've
already copied the VBA for it and let me
simply run it okay
see it creates a chart so this comes in
very handy and you can see the as I have
mentioned in you have to specify the
source the dimensions of the chart and
so on so and so on okay you are
specifying where it's picking up the
data from and the columns I'm in the
range and the dimensions of the chart
okay you can play with this and you will
generate a chart so
well this ends our presentations in so
this is how it looks like and we have
seen that so next question is about a
VBA code again to calculate the area of
a rectangle using the PBA function how
do you include a function to calculate
the area of a rectangle we will all know
that the area of a rectangle is length
into width okay that is the formula we
can execute it with the by defining a
function in the VBA and we'll Define the
same function function is equal to area
and it is area as length into width in
this scenario I'll again show it to you
how we do this in Excel and
let's go ahead and do this
so here we are I will just go to the
developer tab and open the vpa and I
insert a module okay so here we will
Define the function okay function
as area okay this is my function and now
I'm going to define the variables okay
length
as
double because
we want to make sure that it takes the
decimals as well okay and width sorry
okay now what is the area
formula for example a equals to
length
into event
okay
very simple
okay now I go to my Excel and I'll
Define the area form function okay
let's take the length to be put in A1
and the width to be put in B okay now if
I just put the value here
it will take 12 and my width is 36 3 and
it shows the area to be 36 okay
level
so this is the area if you just go and
Define it I mean try to enter area A1
and B1 it will not so we have to define
the function here we're using the VBA
code okay now let's go back to the slide
and we'll discuss so here uh it has been
shown as if you know we have a rectangle
when the when width is not provided so
that is if the rectangle is a square
they will not be given the width so we
are defining again length as double
optional optional is we are giving an
argument that it is optional width as a
variant width as a variant means it can
be zero okay so we are defining it as if
missing width then the area should be
length into length Okay else the area is
length into width as we have seen okay
so this is one way to define a function
for the area of a rectangle okay let's
go to the next slide
so you might be asked about a VBA
function to check if the number is prime
or not we all know what a prime number
is a prime number is divisible by 1 and
itself for example 2 3 5 7 11
13 17 and so on and these are the prime
numbers and anything which is divisible
by any other number like 8 or 4 or 16
which has a divisor is not a prime
number so uh we all know this and we
will write a VBA code to check if the
number is prime or not so this is the
one that is given and we will do the
same in the VBA okay before moving ahead
I will just explain these uh the code
and what we are doing here is basically
we are defining three variables okay we
are declaring three variables one
integer variable okay and we call it as
divisors all right and then the next one
is the one long variable long
as the number and I as long okay here
long specifies variables because it has
got the larger capacity than the integer
values okay the divisor will be zero we
are initializing the variable divisor
with the value of 0 okay the next thing
is we use a input box input box to get
the number from the user that is you
will input a number when you are asked
to for the input box okay so this is the
so when the number is entered we want to
check whether this number is prime or
not okay so how do we check that okay as
we all know the condition for prime
number is it has only two number devices
that is one and itself so what we do is
we start a next Loop okay for I equals
to 1 to numbers all right so this is the
start of the loop we will Define the
conditions here
so now how do we actually perform the
operation of dividing we use the mod
operator okay this is one of the
important uh operator to check here the
mod operator will give you the remainder
of a division for example U have seven
or eight or mod by two is equal to 1
because 7 divided by 2 equals 3 with the
remainder of 1. okay so only if the only
if a number mod
I equals to 0 I is the advice divisor of
a number okay so in this case we want to
increment it by variable devices by one
so this is what we Define it as okay now
so here a check is performed like I
equals to 1. and then plus 1 I equals to
2 then plus 1 I equals to 3 and then
plus 4 I equals to
so as it goes on until it reaches the
number okay because for I equals to 1 to
number okay
so this is what is starting of the loop
now you have to close the loop so how we
do that is next I okay this is closing
the loop so this is what the loop does
now we are we have defined the check now
we have to define the result how what
happens if the divisor sees equals to 2
then the message box number should say
is a prime number all right otherwise it
should say message number should pop up
and say it is not a prime number so this
is how we Define it in the VBA let's go
ahead and do this
so here we are I have already set up and
this is the PVA so let's run it okay and
it will ask you this is the model 2
because I defined it as module two so
the message box opens up and it asks you
to enter a value now
let's see
two
is a prime number okay I run it again by
pressing the
fake key okay
12.
is not a prime number so this is how we
have in
we have coded a maybe a code a function
to check whether the number is prime or
not
so this ends our presentation or about
the interview questions with that we
have come to an end of this tutorial on
Advanced Excel if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
the session or if you require the data
sets that we used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here